[Musique]
la route bonsoir bonsoir nous vous
recevons pour une chaîne internet qui
s'appelle thinkerview nous sommes en
direct est-ce que vous pouvez vous
présenter succinctement je m'appelle
Pierre laroutureau je suis ingénieur
agronome et je suis engagé depuis très
longtemps dans tout ce qui est lutte
contre la précarité lutte contre la
pauvreté et puis lutte pour le lutte
contre le dérèglement climatique et
comme beaucoup de gens j'essaye de faire
bouger les choses pour avoir une société
plus juste plus durable et plus
conviviale il y a encore du boulot mais
j'espère qu'on va y arriver j'ai pas
entendu vous avez parlé ou du fait que
vous êtes au Parlement européen et en
plus pardon c'est vrai depuis quatre ans
je me fais depuis 4 ans je suis député
européen je suis reportage général du
budget m'a confié une grosse
responsabilité j'étais un peu étonné et
ému la même semaine j'ai eu une sanction
enfin j'ai fait rentrer 40 jeunes
activistes qui sont venus nous réveiller
sur l'urgence climatique comme du joli
bazar au Parlement donc la même semaine
j'ai une sanction et j'ai eu quand même
une responsabilités les plus importantes
rapporteur général du budget donc c'est
moi qui négociait en 2021 les 160
milliards du budget de l'Europe et je me
bats beaucoup pour avoir de l'argent
pour le climat pour aider tout ce qui
souffrent de la flambée des prix
aujourd'hui il y a des boulangers qui
ferment qui mettent la clé sous la porte
il y a des millions de familles où les
gens n'ont plus de quoi manger on est en
France en 2023 il y a des gens qui
doivent choisir entre se chauffer
normalement et manger normalement alors
qu'il y a jamais autant de frics sur les
marchés financiers donc je me bats pour
qu'on prenne l'argent là où il y en a
pour la justice sociale et pour le
climat alors on va poser les questions
pourquoi vous recevez pierre lagroute
tout roux hors période électorale et ici
on a un principe quand vous êtes
politique que vous avez fait une greffe
de la fin vous pouvez venir un peu plus
souvent parce que on respecte le quand
le politique est mordu dans sa chair
aujourd'hui on va parler de la semaine
des quatre jours de la taxation sur les
marchés financiers de la taxe carbone on
va parler beaucoup d'Europe de finances
de corruption d'écologie de prospective
de géopolitique d'énergie de retraite de
l'année
sécurité alimentaire de changement
climatique de migration de transition
énergétique d'inflation de guerre
économique et d'euros tu es chaud alors
comment on se connaît on va se tutoyer
tout de suite empêche la politique de la
maison c'est s'il y a des sources s'il y
a des choses qui sont montrées il faut
que ce soit carré sourcil cubique pas de
diffamation pas de dénigrement attention
tu veux commencer par quoi bien
je sais pas parce qu'il y a beaucoup de
sujets très importants comme beaucoup de
gens je suis en colère sur ce que fait
Macron sur les retraites et ce qui ne
fait pas sur le climat sur la justice
sociale cela donc on pourrait parler de
ça il y a l'urgence climatique au moment
où on se parle il y a plein de paysans
qui n'ont pas d'eau pour arroser il y a
des départements avec des sécheresses
terribles et ça c'est des incendies et
en Afrique pendant qu'on se parle il y a
des milliers de gens qui meurent
aujourd'hui on Éthiopie à cause du
dériment climatique donc tu nous parles
de ton petit voyage en Afrique récent je
suis allé passer je prends jamais
l'avion mais je suis allé à Johannesburg
pour travailler que c'était assez
émouvant et tous les députés du
Parlement panafricain de même qu'un
Parlement européen à Strasbourg et
Bruxelles j'ai découvert il y a un an
qui a un Parlement panafricain
Johannesburg avec des hommes et des
femmes de toute l'Afrique ils étaient
super intéressant et ils sont super en
colère contre le blabla des Européens
donc il y a plein de sujets mais je
crois qu'on a le temps on peut peut-être
commencer par le climat et on parlera
des retraites tout à l'heure quand on
parlera des quatre jours et tout ça
comme tu veux si tu as fait une grève à
la fin donc tu commences avec ce que tu
veux alors il faut l'expliquer la grève
de la femme pour ceux qui voilà non j'ai
fait une grève de la femme parce qu'il y
a deux ans et demi donc j'avais été
nommé rapporteur général du budget ce
qui m'a donné une certaine
responsabilité donc il fallait en même
temps faire le job de rapporteur général
du budget j'étais co-rapporter sur le
financement du Plan Climat et donc j'ai
fait voter par le Parlement européen
avec d'autres députés un rapport qui
expliquait comment on peut trouver des
sous parce qu'une fois qu'on a dit la
planète brut de la planète brûle ok mais
il faut des dizaines de milliards pour
les transports en commun il faut des
dizaines de milliards pour la rénovation
thermique si on veut vraiment isoler une
maison c'est 30 000 euros on va pas
demander à chaque famille de trouver
30000 euros donc il faut qu'il y ait des
subventions il faut quel type
d'isolation quel type de travail
c'est entre en gros entre 30000 et 40
000 euros ça dépend à quel moment elle a
été construite quelle est la taille
c'est une maison mais ce que je veux
dire c'est que la question clé de même
qu'on dit que le nerf de la guerre c'est
l'argent si on a compris l'urgence
climatique si on a compris on en
reparlera les lobbies nous ont fait
perdre 30 ou 40 ans c'est scandaleux il
y avait déjà un diagnostic très clair il
y a 40 ans et puis on avait commencé à
40 ans on aurait pu avoir une
métamorphose tranquille et maintenant il
y a pendant une urgence à faire bouger
les choses donc il faut le patron de la
SNCF dit qu'il lui faut 100 milliards
pour investir dans les transports en
commun et il a raison donc les pays du
Sud crève en disant depuis deux siècles
l'Europe et les États-Unis ont fait du
CO2 mais c'est chez nous qui a le plus
de catastrophes donc les pays du Sud
demandent de l'argent pour les aider et
ils ont raison donc une des questions
clés c'est comment on trouve des sous on
a entendu les gilets jaunes c'est pas
ceux qui gagnent 1000 ou 2000 par mois
qui doivent être taxés dans mon coin des
Pyrénées il y en a plein qui était
gilets jaunes et je les comprends très
bien parce qu'il n'y a aucun transport
en commun aucun donc ce SL quand du
boulot ils doivent tous prendre la
vieille voiture qui pollue et qui crache
un peu son sang voilà pour aller à
Pierrefitte Argelès pour trouver du
boulot il serait très content si elle
est transports en commun ce serait moins
cher et quand il y a du verglas il
serait plus cool en hiver donc si la
seule réponse est on augmente le prix de
l'essence je comprends que les gens
gueulent donc au niveau du Parlement
européen on a fait un rapport où on
disait voilà les moyens de trouver de
l'argent la taxe digitale la taxe
plastique data et la meilleure solution
ce que dit le Parlement pas seulement
moi c'est une petite taxe de la
spéculation l'idée toute simple tous on
paye de la TVA quand on fait nos courses
quand on achète une chocolatine ou un
morceau de pain même les plus pauvres
même les plus pauvres ce qu'il dort
chocolat un pain au chocolat pour aller
simple qui ne sont pas bernés personne
n'est parfait donc mais même je
redeviens sérieux même les plus pauvres
ceux qui m'endit à la sortie du métro
dès qu'ils ont trouvé 3 €, ils vont
s'acheter de quoi manger et ils payent
5,5 % de TVA et quand on achète un
téléphone c'est 20% mais tout le monde
paye de la TVA au moins 5,5 % même fait
les trucs fondamentaux comme avoir de
quoi manger mais sur les marchés
financiers c'est zéro virgule 0 %
0,0 %. donc quasiment tous les députés
sauf l’extrême droite ont voté un
rapport pour dire il faut créer une taxe
sur la spéculation une petite axe à 0,1%
on a pris un truc qui fait consensus il
y a des gens qui proposent des mesures
plus radicales mais pour avoir 70% des
députés ce qu'on a mis dans le rapport
c'est une petite axe à 0% et même si
elle est petite à 0,1% elle rapporterait
57 milliards chaque donc on dit pas que
ça suffit mais déjà si tu as chaque
année 57 milliards tu peux donner un
coup de main à ceux qui veulent faire de
la rénovation thermique tu peux aider
les agriculteurs aujourd'hui tous les
agriculteurs ont compris l'urgence
climatique ils sont plus de couper bien
sûr elle est européenne
sur les marchés elle est sur les au
début on voulait pour les 27 pays en
fait comme il y a des pays qui bloquent
complètement on a lancé une coopération
renforcée donc l'Allemagne est d'accord
à l'échelle européenne 50 milliards tu
as raison de préciser c'est si tous les
pays des 27 le font mais même s'il y a
seulement la coopération renforcée
seulement les 10 pays les plus motivés
on aurait déjà 35 milliards voilà ce qui
est possible ce qui est sur la table
aujourd'hui c'est une petite axe 0,1%
tout est prêt techniquement je vais
monterai un ministre elle est 1500 pages
de l'étude impact tout est prêt et les
seuls qui bloquent les seuls qui
bloquent je vais commencer peut-être à
sortir mes preuves sinon tu vas
attention caméraman bientôt une preuve
qui va sortir les écoutant j'en profite
pour me lever un peu pour ceux qui nous
écoutent en podcast on a essayé de vous
décrire à quoi ensemble les et donc le
rapport du Parlement européen qui dit
que on peut toutes les ressources c'est
ça mais vous allez sur le site taxon la
spéculation.com et vous trouvez toutes
les infos précises vous pouvez relire
tout à tête reposé tout est en français
et en anglais sur le site taxon à la
spéculation.com donc ça c'est un extrait
de du texte a été voté en novembre 2020
par tout le Parlement européen et puis
au fonctionnaire est venu me voir
discrètement il voulait même pas me
l'envoyer par Internet attention c'est
un haut fonctionnaire qui est venu de
voir discret
d'une façon officielle non-officielle
c'est un fonction
Bertrand je comprends très bien je
comprends très bien la volonté de dire
les choses de ne jamais mentir de jamais
inventer un argument mais cette lettre
est tout à fait authentique et sur le
site action à la spéculation.com c'est
une lettre de ganote Blumel qui est le
ministre des Finances Autrichiens la
droite autrichienne c'est pas quelqu'un
de ma famille politique mais le ministre
des Finances autrichien en janvier 2020
dit l'Autriche veut relancer la
négociation pour la taxe sur les
transactions financières c'est sur ton
papier là je suis sûr de mon papier et
il est sur le site taxant la
spéculation.com c'est même il y a deux
semaines si vous allez sur mes réseaux
face à Bruno Le Maire à l'Assemblée
nationale et Bruno Le Maire ne le
conteste pas Bruno Le Maire vous allez
sur mes réseaux Bruno Le Maire devant
tous les députés j'étais accepté comme
député européen on a le droit de
participer aux auditions et il a dit
qu'il allait répondre à la lettre du
ministre très chrétien et j'étais allé
le voir en tête à tête peu de temps
avant et je lui avais donné la lettre
voilà et personne ne peut contester la
vérité cette lettre donc même la droite
autrichienne dit nous voulons relancer
la taxe sur les transactions financières
mais si c'est la France qui l'emporte
nous allons claquer la porte nous
quittons la salle des négociations et
pourquoi parce que la version portée par
la France fait que 99% des volumes
financiers ce que dit le ministre
autrichien c'est que ce que propose
Bruno Le Maire c'est une taxe qui nous
concerne que 1% des volumes financiers
et aux 99% des transactions ne sont pas
taxées voilà et c'est absolument
scandaleux donc
ce pour cent en alors c'est ça tout le
paradoxe et c'est une question très
importante parce que Bruno Le Maire
répond il est il déteste les questions
là-dessus mais Bruno Le Maire répond en
disant la France est d'accord il y a
déjà une date je fais transaction
financière en France et c'est vrai c'est
le monde à l'envers c'est que après la
crise financière de 2008 là il y avait
une pression en disant les banques ont
vu des centaines de milliards pour les
aider il faut mettre une taxe et Sarkozy
avec accepter de mettre en place une
taxe à 0,1% et Hollande avait crée
vraiment à 0,2 et maintenant elle est à
0,3% mais ne concerne la taxe qui existe
en France que 1% des volumes financiers
et donc Bruno Le Maire il y a trois
semaines à l'Assemblée me dit mais
monsieur larouture il commence à me dire
oui c'est votre combat je vais répondre
non c'est pas mon combat c'est 80% des
députés tout le monde a par l'extrême
droite veut créer cet axe et il explique
que la taxe qui existe en France a
rapporté 1,6 milliard l'an dernier donc
je redis en France il y a une taxe mais
elle est seulement sur 1% des volumes
les grandes les actions des très très
grande entreprise c'est pas les
obligations et pas des produits dérivés
donc c'est seulement sur 1% des
transactions financières et elle a déjà
rapporté 1,6 milliards l'an dernier donc
il n'y a pas besoin d'être un prix Nobel
d'économie pour se dire que une taxe
sienne et concerne que 1% des volumes
elle a rapporté 1,6 milliards si on taxé
l'ensemble des transactions financières
on peut comprendre que ça rapportait
beaucoup plus et est-ce que ça
ralentirait le fait que certains font
des allers-retours
en faisant de liker fréquence
ce qui a une gestion de père de famille
ou de mère de famille qui achètent
quelques actions de Danone ou quelques
actions de ce que tu veux ou d'une autre
marque où je n’ai pas d'intérêt chez
Danone mais qui le garde pendant quatre
ou cinq ans pendant 4 ou 5 ans cela il
s'en fiche de payer 0,1% au début ils
espèrent gagner 10% avant de revendre
donc pour eux 0,1 c'est marginal de même
que toi quand tu achètes des chaussures
ou un téléphone ou du pain tu acceptes
de payer la TVA et par contre ceux qui
gueulent ceux qui gueulent ce qui hurle
c'est ceux qui font du trading à haute
fréquence qui n'a aucune utilité
économique aucune utilité économique et
qui est même dangereux en période de
crise financière mais qui s'en foutent
plein les poches voilà j'ai vu sur le
site de BNP Paribas que le salaire d'un
trader c'est 28000 euros par mois 28000
euros sans les bonus donc peut-être que
cela je me fais le bruit
oui oui je sais que tu as le cœur tendre
donc c'est pauvre traders
mais oui on est là ils étaient à 28000
euros et peut-être qu'ils vont avoir
seulement 24000 et on va les aider
passer pas drôle de vivre avec seulement
24000 voilà non on va les aider on a des
humanistes donc blague à part on est
dans une situation de crise sociale
gravissime j'ai vu des chiffres là sur
la consommation alimentaire en un an
-9%. donc je faisais les courses pour ma
famille le week-end dernier la dame du
carrefour la caissière me dit qu'elle
est effarée par le nombre de gens qui
arrivent à la caisse et qui laissent
deux ou trois produits
ou qui sont obligés de voler donc on
n'est pas un moment de rigolade où ça
baigne pour tout le monde et donc et sur
l'urgence climatique on est au mois
d'avril on a déjà des départements en
France il y a trop de sécheresse la
semaine dernière on a battu une
continuité un abattu deux records le
record du CO2 dans l'atmosphère on n'a
jamais eu autant de CO2 en reparlera et
le record des marchés financiers donc on
a besoin d'argent pour éviter que les
boulangers fassent faillite à cause du
prix de l'énergie il y a des boulangers
qui mettent la clé sous la porte on a
besoin d'argent parce qu'il y a des
millions de familles qui n'arrivent plus
à vivre normalement et c'est la honte
pour le père ou la mère de famille qui
rentre à la maison et qui a pas de quoi
nourrir ses enfants ou son conjoint ou
sa copine voilà donc c'est juste une
honte que d'un pays aussi riche des gens
soient obligés de se serrer la ceinture
c'est juste une honte que quand Emmanuel
Macron nous dit depuis 6 ans ma priorité
c'est le climat ma priorité sur le
climat et quand les associations
demandent de mettre plus d'argent sur la
rénovation thermique on nous dit qu'il
n'y a pas d'argent alors que les marchés
financiers sont des niveaux jamais vu
donc le Parlement européen demande cet
axe et quand m'apporte la preuve qu'il y
a que la France qui bloque j'ai fait ma
grève de la fin tout ça pour expliquer
pourquoi tu parles d'une grève de la
femme et j'ai fait 18 jours de grève de
la fin et pour un Bombard comme bien
nourri comme moi il y avait pas de
risque mais les médecins du Parlement au
début du risque non mais à la fin je me
suis arrêté parce que le médecin chef
m'a dit le message du chef du Parlement
m'a fait une lettre assez claire en
disant écoutez vous avez perdu beaucoup
de muscles au début tu perds de la
graisse et content tu perds du bidon
mais après ça tu perds du muscle je
voyais tous les matins je prenais une
douche et je voyais mais elle me dit
votre cœur c'est aussi un muscle donc
elle m'a fait une lettre pour dire je
risquais des dégâts
irréparables pour mon organisme et elle
m'a dit si vous faites un malaise je
vous envoie aux urgences alors qu'à
l'époque il y avait le covid-19 et
j'avais promis que je n'allais pas
encombrer les urgences donc au bout de
18 jours j'ai arrêté mais la bonne
nouvelle c'est que là il y a deux mois
il y a deux mois le Parlement européen a
voté un nouveau texte qui demande qu'un
accord avant la fin juin 2023 c'est pour
ça je suis allé voir Bruno Le Maire il y
a trois semaines parce que l'ensemble du
Parlement dit maintenant on arrête le
blabla cette idée d'une taxe sur la
spéculation elle est sur la table depuis
2011 on sait qu'il y a qu'un seul pays
qui bloque et donc l'ensemble du
Parlement demande qu'il y a un accord
avant la fin juin 2023 je te coupe
il y a peut-être ces raisons pour
bloquer peut-être que ces
contre-productif pour la France non je
pense au conseil du diable mais on peut
se faire l'avocat de Ligue 1 mais encore
une fois j'essaye de retrouver le la
courbe qui monte ce que j'ai donné à
bueno Lemaire le jour à tous les députés
pour montrer qu'il y a aucun danger
voilà Bruno Le Maire disait qu'il y a 2
ans et demi il justifié qui ne voulait
aucune taxe en attendant que les
conclusions du brexit les retombées du
Brice soit stabilisés maintenant ça y
est les retombées du président et
d'ailleurs cocorico la place de Paris et
la première place sur le continent donc
OK et après ça Bruno Le Maire explique
peut-être une gnagnagna si on crée une
taxe ça va faire fuir les investisseurs
et donc j'ai retrouvé le graphique ce
sont les chiffres du ministère des
Finances parce que l'air de rien on
bosse quand la taxe qui existe en France
seulement sur 1% des volumes mais elle
existe elle a été créée officiellement à
01 mais en fait à 0,2 les lobbies
bancaires disaient c'est l'horreur si on
met une taxe ça va faire fuir mais pas
du tout quand on a mis en place ça
fonctionne et quand elle passe de 0,2 à
de nouveau les lobbies bancaires disent
mais c'est l'horreur vous allez détruire
nos investissements voilà et ben pas du
tout quand elle passe de 0,2 à 0,3 il y
a aucune fuite des investissements et au
contraire il y a un effet mécanique sur
ce que ça rapporte pour le budget de
l'État et l'an dernier les derniers
chiffres qu'on a c'est qu'elle a
rapporté 1,6 milliards d'euros pour la
France 1,6 donc je le répète il y a pas
besoin d'être un génie ou un prix Nobel
d'économie pour se dire que une petite
taxe qui ne qui ne concerne aujourd'hui
que 1% des échanges sur la Bourse de
Paris elle rapporte 1,6 milliards par an
si on avait une taxe sur toutes les
transactions financières sera porterait
beaucoup plus et honorer de l'argent
pour aider les boulangers qu'ils en
train de crever pour aider les familles
à cause de la flambée du prix de
l'énergie et pour agir pour le climat
qui souffre tu as tout à fait raison le
niveau de défaillance des entreprises là
ça devient compliqué
en plus les Américains c'est chez nous
que le prix de l'énergie a beaucoup
augmenté et les Américains ce qu'on
appelle l'intention de réduction d'acte
on met 360 milliards sur la table
l'autre jour j'ai vu des chercheurs qui
dit je m'essaie de la folie parce que
c'est en Europe qu'on a le plus de
brevets pour l'hydrogène vert c'est en
Europe qu'on a le plus de brevets pour
améliorer le photovoltaïque pour faire
photovoltaïque plus efficace et meilleur
pour la planète mais tout va partir aux
États-Unis toute la partie industrie va
partir aux États-Unis parce que les
américains ils vont comme des gros
ballots ils vont à la hache mais c'est
efficace si tu veux faire de l'hydrogène
un scientifique m'a montré les chiffres
l'hydrogène est-ce qu'ils t'ont parlé
aussi des platinoïdes qui sont
nécessaires pour cette technologie à
l'hydrogène non ils m'ont pas parlé des
patinoïdes ils t'ont pas parlé des
platinoïdes et le fait qu'on devrait
ouvrir X1000 en plus pour pouvoir avoir
accès à tout ça on va en parler de toute
façon la meilleure énergie enfin non
mais la meilleure énergie c'est sûr
qu'on ne consomme pas voilà et j'ai
passé une heure et demie avec la numéro
2 de RDC quand j'étais en Afrique et
démocratique du Congo où il y a des
énormes ressources donc je pense qu'il
faut qu'on ait un nouveau départ entre
l'Europe et l'Afrique pour gagner
ensemble la bataille du climat et que ce
soit pas la guerre après les métaux
rares mais de toute façon sur tes croire
à qui a une grosse voiture thermique tu
sais que j'aime pas du tout quand
j'essaie de parler que tu augmentes le
ton pouvoir c'est un réflexe de
politique et j'aime pas gentil c'est la
vérité
là je t'ai laissé terminé tu lances
plein de sujet on va parler direct
économique tout de suite donc tu parles
de les États-Unis qui mettent plus de
300 milliards sur la table qui propose
de financer énormément de choses pour
que des entreprises viennent s'installer
chez eux ils proposent aussi d'augmenter
leur production de gaz de chie de de gaz
liquéfier naturel GNL jusqu'à 70% pour
6000 chiffres sont bons 2028 ou 2027 ou
2030 genre très rapidement
qu'est-ce que tu penses de ça de cette
guerre économique qui est menée à
l'Europe alors il y a plusieurs choses
il y a avec la guerre en Ukraine d'abord
c'est l'horreur pour les Ukrainiens les
Ukrainiennes voilà ça fait 14 mois 15
mois bientôt que la guerre a commencé
c'est l'horreur pour tous les celles qui
se battent au quotidien tous ceux et
celles qui sont violées tous ceux qui
sait qui voient leur famille détruite à
cause de Poutine et de la guerre
déclenchée par Poutine donc la première
urgence c'est comment est-ce qu'on peut
aider l'Ukraine à gagner la guerre pour
qu'il y ait une victoire claire et que
ça dissuade la Chine travaille à Taïwan
pour plein plein de raisons il faut
aider les Ukrainiens les Ukrainiennes au
nom de la dignité humaine au nom de la
liberté d'un pays qui est libre et qui
en plus une des raisons pour lesquelles
la Russie est l'attaqué je sais pas si
vous voulez rejoindre l'Europe donc ça
veut dire aussi que malgré tous ces
défauts l'Europe prête un endroit qui
attire pour les gens qui veulent de la
liberté donc dans ce que tu as dit il y
a l'aspect GNL puisqu'on ne consomme
plus le gaz de Russie et tant qu'on n'a
pas fait des politiques pour faire
baisser notre consommation d'énergie on
peut avoir besoin pendant quelques temps
de plus de gaz voilà parce qu'on n'a
rien foutu je veux pas être on y
reviendra mais j'ai découvert on a foutu
rien foutu sur la rénovation thermique
en 2007 Grenelle de l'environnement il y
a un consensus il y a la photo avec
Nicolas Sarkozy Jean-Louis Borloo le
ministre du climat de l'époque et droite
et gauche on est d'accord pour dire
qu'il faut faire 400000 vraies
rénovations chaque année en 2007 tout le
monde est d'accord pour dire pour sortir
de notre dépendance aux énergies pour
faire baisser le améliorer le pouvoir
d'achat des plus précaires 400000 vraies
rénovations bravo un petit peu de
champagne monsieur le ministre
voilà voilà on avait promis il y a 15
ans donc si on a des commencé il y a 15
ans alors bien sûr il y a des problèmes
de formation ça se fait pas en trois
semaines mais si on sait qu'on a les
moyens qu'on a l'argent et que pendant
20 ans on veut effectivement faire
400000 vraies rénovations si on sait
qu'on a des aides en particulier que
c'est possible d'avoir des aides et bien
le secteur du bâtiment il va recruter
des gens il va les former et petit à
petit peut-être pas le premier trimestre
on va arriver sans rien de 400000 le
vrai rénovations et si on a été 400000
frères rénovations chaque année depuis
2007 on aurait en gros 6 millions
d'appartements qui seraient bien isolés
aujourd'hui et notre dépendance au gaz
extérieur elle serait beaucoup plus
faible donc dans ce que tu as dit les
Américains si l'Europe
pour nous la France était on est moins
indépendante du gaz russe mais je vois
des amis allemands depuis que je sois
Parlement européen je rencontre des
Allemands des gens il y en a un qui me
dit ok pierre moi je suis d'accord pour
vivre avec 15 degrés moi je suis en
pleine forme et je peux mettre un pull
ou de pull mais l'hôpital de ma ville il
est complètement chauffé au gaz les gens
qui sont malades tu vas pas leur
demander de d'être à 15 degrés
quand c'est mais si tu fais des
économies en schématisant
des maladies pulmonaires parce qu'il fut
mis de chez toi que ça fout en l'air les
bâtiments parce que c'était pas
scientifique mais c'est juste que
fallait pas dire que les Allemands sont
méchants quand les Allemands veulent du
gaz ok ils ont sans doute déconné on
sait que Gerard Schroeder était aux
mains que garchorder est allé faire de
l'argent avec les Russes de même qu'on
voit que François Fillon a été aussi au
conseil d'administration de deux
entreprises d'énergie russe voilà je
crois qu'il a jamais touché l'argent non
mais si c'est pas dans la question c'est
que nous est-ce que l'Europe on est
assez stupide pour ne pas faire pareil
donc si le Parlement européen demande
une taxe de transaction financière c'est
avec deux objectifs c'est répondre à la
flambée des prix pour les boulangers
pour les artisans pour les familles qui
n'ont plus de quoi manger normalement
c'est pour éviter les délocalisations
quand les Américains mettent des
subventions terribles quand volkswagen
annonce qu'il n'y aura plus
d'investissement en Allemagne quand fort
de l'autre jour elle a une des journaux
c'est Ford qui supprime 3800 postes en
Europe qui coupe 3800 postes et dans la
même phrase qui investit 3,5 milliards
aux États-Unis on est débile nous
l'Europe sur ne réagit pas Joe Biden il
a promulgué la loi cette loi au mois
d'août dernier on est en avril et en
Europe on est encore à tortillé pour
savoir dans l'idée c'est que
quand tu dis ils sont débiles on est
débile
au bout d'un certain temps c'est plus de
la débilité c'est soit de l'incompétence
soit ils se font graisser la pâte à
gaucho à droite pour pas voir les choses
qu'est-ce que c'est pour toi il y a pas
de service de renseignement en Europe
qui s'occupe de protéger les plans
qui a été voté le 16 février par le
Parlement européen dit pour répondre aux
Américains pour éviter des
délocalisations catastrophiques et en
même temps pour avoir de l'argent pour
le climat on veut cet axe transaction
financière voilà c'est pour ça qu'on
veut la que le Parlement demande qu'un
accord concret avant la fin juin et j'ai
réussi à remotiver au mois d'octobre
quand j'ai relancé le débat au sein du
Parlement je me suis dit pourquoi tu te
fatigues Pedro tu vas être ridicule dans
mais franchement et quand je vois que
même 80% des députés de droite et même
92% de la droite allemande ont voté
l'amendement c'est mon groupe c'est les
sociaux-démocrates qui ont déposé
l'amendement mais même 80% de la droite
et 92% de la droite allemande votée oui
il faut qu'on trouve des solutions et
simplement je vois bien qu'en corrière
je déjeunaise un commissaire européen
qui me dit qu'il est le seul en gros
dans la Commission à en parler parce que
tout le monde considère que Bruno Le
Maire et Macron vont bloquer la négo et
donc les gens ont peur d'être ridicule
en disant à quoi ça sert d'en reparler
si la France bloque et hélas en Europe
il y a en gros même s'il y a une
coopération renforcée il n'y a pas de
l'unanimité du point de vue juridique il
n'y a pas besoin d'uneanimité mais dans
la vraie politique c'est un des quatre
grands pays blocs les autres s'écrasent
parce qu'on ne veut pas aller au clash
avec un des quatre grands pays et donc
si la France bloque si tout le monde
pense que la France va continuer à
bloquer et bien on en parle pas oh comme
c'est la seule solution c'est la seule
solution pour trouver du fric dans les
mois qui viennent si la France continue
à bloquer on est foutu donc j'aimerais
m'adresser à ceux celles qui nous
écoutent vous pouvez nous aider parce
que y compris dans l'équipe de Macron il
y en a qui pensent ça va être une
catastrophe si la France ne bouge pas il
y en a qui ont réussi à faire bouger
Macron sur deux sujets importants depuis
quelques mois la France a annoncé
qu'elle sortait du traité sur la charte
de l'énergie beaucoup de gens pensaient
que ça ne se ferait jamais mais
l'énergie pour sucer un traité qui
empêchait les les politiques des
gouvernement de mettre en place des
politiques au Dacia sur les questions de
climat parce que du coup les entreprises
pétrolières ou autre pouvaient faire des
procès en disant je vais faire moins de
bénéfices de vous et donc c'était un
traité qui protégeait les entreprises
polluantes et la France a annoncé
qu'elle sortait du traité sur la charte
de l'énergie deuxième point sur lequel
tel ou tel a réussi à faire bouger
Macron et Bruno Le Maire c'est que la
France a annoncé qu'elle stoppait les
subventions aux exportations des
énergies carbonées beaucoup beaucoup
plus vite que prévu et donc il y en a
aussi dans les personnes chez Macron il
y en a que je ne supporte plus pour être
clair qu'on voit l'état du pays qu'on
voit ce qu'ils font sur les retraites il
y en a avec qui je n'ai plus aucune
envie de parler mais parmi ceux et
celles qui travaillent sur les questions
de climat dans cette mouvance chez
Macron chez au Quai d'Orsay il y en a
qui sont allés voir à la cop27 ont
compris l'urgence qui ont vu on a sorti
des appels avec des grands climatologues
avec plein de responsables des pays du
Sud on a sorti un appel au mois de
décembre qui dit c'est urgent de taxer
la spéculation ils ont vu que le
Parlement européen se mobilise et donc
je pense qu'il y a une peut-être une
fenêtre dans les deux mois qui viennent
et donc ceux et celles qui nous écoutent
si vous êtes d'accord pour taxer la
spéculation prenez deux minutes pour
aller sur le site taxon la
spéculation.com taxons la
spéculation.com il y a grand sommet sur
le climat le 22 et le 23 juin beaucoup
de gens ne le savent pas Emmanuel Macron
organise un grand sommet sur le
financement du climat le 22 et le 23
juin et on pense que il devrait sauf à
être complètement ridicule dans ce grand
sommet il annonce qu'il y a des chefs
d'État africains qui vont venir que Lula
le brésilien va venir mais si on fait un
grand sommet à Paris sur le financement
du climat et que c'est encore la France
qui bloque ça va être une catastrophe
diplomatique donc tous ceux celles qui
le veulent vous pouvez nous aider vous
pouvez rassurez-vous mettre votre
téléphone portable mettre vous dire que
vous signez l'appel et si vous voulez
vous engager pour qu'on va s'organiser
pour aller voir les députés pour faire
campagne on a deux mois pour gagner la
partie mettez votre téléphone portable
vous inquiétez pas on est juste trois
allez regarder vous aurez pas des
publicités débiles c'est juste pour
qu'on s'organise on a deux mois pour
gagner la partie taxons la
spéculation.com je reprends le crachoir
et revenons sur le gaz naturel liquéfie
américain c'est quoi le gaz naturel
liquidifier ce que quand on y a un
naturel dedans ça fait tout de suite
plus vert plus propre plus
mais c'est quoi c'est du gaz qui fait du
sel du gaz classique simplement c'est
classique
et simplement il est liquéfié parce que
pour traverser comme on veut pas faire
un pipeline sous l'océan on le comprime
et on le pour qu'il prenne moins de
volume donc on fait des gros bateaux
avec des énormes sphères parce qu'il est
comprimé liquéfié aux États-Unis on le
met dans ses énormes bateaux qui
traverse l'Atlantique et puis quand il
arrive en Europe il est trop transformé
en gaz voilà détendu il est détendu
voilà il retrouve il revient dans les
pipelines classiques pour arriver jusque
le SSL qui se font la cuisine ou qui se
chauffent au gaz alors tu parles de donc
juste il est quand même moi plus cher
pendant des années suffit trop long mais
il est quand même plus cher il est aussi
mauvais pour le pour le climat ou même
un peu pire pour le climat pour le CO2
qui les met pour le méthane qu'il aimait
quand il y a des fuites mais en plus il
est plus cher parce que le fait de le
comprimer de le mettre dans ses bateaux
puis de le re-décomprimer de le faire
arriver fait qu'il est beaucoup plus
cher donc de toute façon ça peut être
une solution d'urgence pendant la guerre
en Ukraine tant qu'on n'a pas fait les
politiques de rénovation thermique mais
de toute façon il faut accélérer les
politiques de rénovation thermique alors
tu parlais de Lula tu parlais de
pipeline l'Union européenne elle en est
où sur l'enquête de qui a fait péter
quoi de pipeline
qui a fait péter quoi une russe qui a
pété
je sais pas si c'est un
tout à fait alors je ne sais pas j'ai vu
les images je sais pas quel est-ce qu'il
y aura une enquête je pense que oui
pendant la je sors il y a des domaines
où j'ai travaillé où je crois avoir des
réponses mais là je sens mon joker parce
que comme tous les citoyens j'ai vu ces
images et je me dis que Poutine est un
grand malade et que on ne sait jamais ce
qui est pas là je prétends pas
comprendre la
stratégie totale de Poutine tu parles de
Lula est-ce que tu suis ce qui se passe
en ce moment avec les bricks est-ce que
tu suis ce qui se passe en termes
monétaire ce qu'ils veulent faire est-ce
qu'ils veulent faire une monnaie basée
sur des ressources naturelles est-ce que
tu vois aussi l'Afrique est-ce que tu te
vois toi par le mot européen dire et
l'Afrique bon écoutez on a un peu
déconné avec les ressources on a
consommé comme des dingues le
réchauffement climatique c'est un petit
peu précaire donc vous ferez plus vous
utilisez plus vos ressources est-ce
qu'il y a un plan pour essayer de leur
faire accepter le fait que
bah non le développement vous oubliez
est-ce qu'on va leur donner de l'argent
vous oubliez c'est juste impossible donc
d'abord est-ce qu'on va leur donner de
l'argent c'est le but alors
absolument fondamental donc l'été
dernier je fais partie des quatre
députés européens qui sont allés en
Ouganda parce que tu as entendu parler
total veut faire le plus gros pipeline
chauffer au monde ils veulent c'est
l'horreur franchement quand j'y suis
allé on a des députés d'autres groupes
et d'autres familles politiques pour
qu'on puisse après ça faire voter une
résolution par le Parlement donc c'est
le plus beau parc naturel d'Ouganda
Churchill était tombé amoureux en disant
que c'était la perte de l'Afrique tu
vois des girafes des éléphants on a fait
trois heures pour regarder la beauté du
site et c'est là que Total énergie
monsieur pouyanais et ses collègues
veulent faire des forages pour prendre
du pétrole et puis après ça un pipeline
de 1400 km un packagne chauffée à 50
degrés de 1440 km il y a pas une goutte
de ce pétrole pour le développement
local de l'Ouganda et la Tanzanie c'est
100% pour l'exportation voilà forcément
donner des royalties au pays du coup et
donc voilà et du coup donc d'abord quand
on est revenu de on a on a passé 9 jours
sur place monsieur pouyanais le patron
total considère qu'on raconte des
bêtises on a quand même passé 9 jours
sur place on est invité par des ONG mais
quand les on a su que on était sur place
la direction de Total a voulu nous
recevoir et dès le 4e jour on a passé 4h
avec les dirigeants de Total en Ouganda
puis le lendemain on est allé sur place
puis le surlendemain en est encore allé
sur place avec les dirigeants de total
donc voilà on a écouté tout le monde et
la conclusion c'est que ce packline
n'est absolument pas utile parce que
quand on demande aux dirigeants de Total
mais pourquoi vous faites ce pipeline il
nous explique avec la guerre en Ukraine
on a besoin de gaz
ce projet vous l'avez depuis 15 ans
c'est pas lié à la gare Ukraine et c'est
pas du gaz d'anticiper non mais oui bien
sûr ce sont des génies mais c'est juste
non mais il manque comme des cochons
c'est quand même gênant pour toi leur
argument n'est pas acceptable oui c'est
quand je dis oui c'est important c'est
important d'avoir je déteste le mensonge
ça fait 30 ans que je participe
juste on n'est pas dans le tête d'un
coup peut-être d'un que non on n'est pas
dans une discussion de café tu comprends
pourquoi je me fais l'avocat on peut
faire l'avocat mais moi je vais me faire
l'avocat de la dignité humaine de de la
viande de la planète voilà quand je
commence mes discussions à chaque fois
je monte le nombre d'événements
climatique extrême qui a triplé voilà et
comme explique que c'est un problème des
pays riches de dire il manque climatique
le premier jour on est arrivé en Ouganda
je l'ai pas apporté mais ça m'a frappé à
la une des journaux le lundi on a
commencé nos auditions en Ouganda la
grosse le titre c'est 900 personnes qui
sont mortes de faim dans le nord de
l'Ouganda à cause des sécheresses voilà
donc c'est pas un problème théorique en
Ouganda 900 personnes qui sont mortes de
fin à cause de connexion avec le
pipeline pas danser que le Packman qui
va faire 34 millions de tonnes de CO2
pendant que le dérèglement climatique
est en train de s'aggraver dans tous nos
pays quand on arrive en Ouganda elle a
une des journaux c'est 900 morts à cause
des sécheresses il y a deux ans au
contraire en Belgique en Allemagne
c'était des inondations je sais pas si
tu te souviens en juillet il y a deux
ans j'y pense parce que quand on va à la
direction générale de l'énergie à
Bruxelles la dame qui était assez de
l'énergie et bien est morte d'un camp
scout à cause des inondations je lui dis
ça parce que ça veut dire que ça peut
toucher tout le monde c'est le début de
l'été c'est le mois de juillet oui oui
non mais j'en parle avec émotion et à
chaque fois qu'on je vais au Berlaimont
là où il y a de la chambre j'y pense je
suis père de famille et je me dis
voyance de mes fils tombent par en
vacances avec ses copains et les copines
youplaboum on les laisse une semaine ils
vont être heureux entre entre jeunes et
puis il pleut il pleut il pleut il pleut
il pleut et c'est l'horreur et en
quelques heures il y a 200 morts en
Belgique en Allemagne dont la fille de
cette dame c'est pour dire que le
dérèglement climatique c'est pas un
problème théorique tous tous on peut
soigner rester soit en voilà et même si
on est en crève pas c'est que le début
donc c'est en train de s'aggraver voilà
et donc reconnecte-toi avec avec le
pipeline dans oui je me donc c'est juste
pour dire que quand les gens de chez
Total explique que ce pack Time est
utile on leur répond non
ils disent que c'est utile pour qui
pourquoi comment parce que on est ça
donne ça donne on va dire une autre
ceinture par rapport à la guerre en
Ukraine
je te fais le politique si tu veux
est-ce que ça donne plus de sécurité
énergétique est-ce que c'est pour éviter
d'avoir le couteau sous la gorge parce
que la Russie nous met le couteau sous
la gorge fait une guerre énergétique
c'est ils ont forcément des arguments la
Russie avec la Russie quels sont les
arguments que Total t'a donné j'y arrive
tout de suite donc juste avant de voir
quand on parle avec les gens total que
de même quand je vois les gens du
ministère de en Ouganda que ce soit
quand je les vois quand je suis
accompala soit quand on les voit à
Charmel check au sommet climat après je
vais passer plus d'une heure et demie
avec la ministre de l'Énergie je suis
pas le gars qui vote son rapport et qui
se casse de peur de la réaction on leur
montre l'évolution du nombre
d'événements climatique en train de
s'aggraver et en particulier en Afrique
on leur montre aussi ce rapport de
l'Agence internationale de l'énergie
c'est pas trois rigolo qui boivent une
bière qui se donne un petit et leur
opinion c'est la plus haute autorité au
niveau mondial sur les questions de
d'énergie et il y a deux ans elle a une
de tous les journaux c'est l'Agence
internationale de l'énergie qui dit que
pour éviter un avenir apocalyptique il
faut stopper tous les nouveaux forages
de pétrole et de gaz bien sûr c'est pas
des rigolos ils disent bien sûr on a
encore besoin de pétrole il y a encore
des voitures qui ont besoin d'essence il
y a besoin de gaz mais ce que dit
l'agence industrie bien sûr ils en
tiennent compte c'est quand même les
gens les plus sérieux au niveau mondial
il y a 15 ans tout le monde dit que
c'était le porte-parole du lobby du
pétrole c'est pour ça que quand ils ont
dit ça il y a 2 ans ça a frappé les
opinions ils disent on a encore besoin
de gaz et de pétrole bien sûr mais avec
tous les puits tous les forages qui sont
déjà en exploitation ça va ça va le
faire pour les 20 ans qui viennent et
dans les 20 ans qui viennent il faut en
même temps des politiques d'économie
d'énergie la rénovation thermique faire
des voitures moins lourdes avoir des
transports en commun et des voitures qui
roulent avec d'autres énergies et puis
et progressivement donc on va laisser
s'éteindre les forages actuels qui sont
déjà en train de cracher du pétrole et
du gaz mais déjà en train de s’étendre
tout seul mais tout doucement mais donc
c'est une transition voilà on a je fais
pas de faire croire que je suis un
expert mais quand l'Agence
internationale de l'énergie sort 300
pages avec des trucs qui font choc ils
savent très bien qu'ils vont se faire
critiquer ils ont être solide donc c'est
pas des utopies dans le mauvais sens du
terme ils disent on a encore besoin de
pétrole et de gaz avec les forages
existants ça va il n'y a pas besoin de
nouveau forage et donc et malgré ça
total énergie veut continuer à faire des
forages quels étaient leur argument pour
le nom le pape
au siège de Total énergie en ougandale
on a d'abord parlé des cas sociaux les
plus graves parce qu'on a vu des
familles de paysans je reviens sur la
question du climat dans une minute l'un
des problèmes de ce que fait total
l'énergie en Ouganda c'est que sur les
100 sur les 1400 km du pipeline tu as
plein de paysans qui vivaient de leur
terre de la culture de leur terre et
totale en gros confise que les terres en
disant les travaux vont bientôt
commencer mais ne les paye pas
ne les payent pas pendant pas le droit
ils n'ont pas le droit
de la souffrance les gens n'ont pas le
droit de cultiver leur terre ou
seulement ils ont gagné le droit de
faire des cultures courtes de trois mois
ou 4 mois mais pas les cultures qui font
beaucoup de rendement et souvent ils
n'ont pas été payés ils ont été payés
des sommes très faibles vous pouvez
aller sur mes réseaux et vous verrez
c'était vraiment poignant des gens qui
au début en plus des paysans que au
début croyaient à ce projet parce que le
Président de la République leur avait
dit que c'était bon pour le pays on y
reviendra oui parce que pas de coût
total leur a promis du fric oui c'est ça
mais donc au début ces gens-là pensaient
que le projet était bon pour leur pays
mais simplement j'ai vu un paysan qui
avait quasiment la larme à l'oeil en
disant total m'a volé ma terre on a la
caméra on est revenu avec des images
total m'a volé ma terre ils m'ont dit
que tu signes ou pas on te prendra ta
terre comme c'est une dictature c'était
pas content tu peux aller tu peux pas
aller voir la justice donc les gens de
chez Total l'ont dit que tu signes ou
pas on te prendra ta terre et donc le
gars ici il dit ils m'ont volé ma terre
ils m'ont mis 6 millions de shilling
alors que pour avoir la même surface je
viens tout de suite mais je suis aussi
je viens tout de suite évidemment c'est
ils m'ont dit ils m'ont mis 6 millions
de shilling pour avoir la même surface
il faut 12 millions de shilling donc on
fait la calculette c'est 2600 euros
donc l'autre jour j'ai dit au directeur
juridique j'ai eu 25 minutes le
directeur juridique au total je lui dis
d'écouter je ne vous juge pas vous
monsieur je ne vous connais pas mais
pour votre entreprise j'avais honte
j'avais honte une famille de paysans qui
crève on a vu un paysan qui est pas du
20 kg pardon toi et moi on est bien
nourri mais on a vu un paysan surtout
moi mais je reviens ça on a vu un paysan
entre les images il y a 4 ans et
aujourd'hui il a perdu 20 Kilos ses
enfants ne vont plus à l'école on a des
images de filles qui ont 18 ans ou 19
ans comme l'école est payante et ben
comme les parents n'ont plus de quoi
vivre les parents ne peuvent plus
cultiver l'état normalement et Total ne
les a pas payés ou pas assez donc les
enfants ne vont plus à l'école tu vois
c'est pas de la blague monsieur
pouyanais il dit qu'il est content parce
qu'il a fait Polytechnique mais lui
est-ce qu'il accepterait que ses enfants
soient privés d'école pendant quatre ans
mais si c'est très il est fier d'avoir
fait Polytechnique je comprends très
bien qu'il soit c'est simplement des
familles de paysans qui n'ont plus quoi
vivre c'est ce qu'on a le temps
combien de paysans est-ce qu'ils se sont
regroupés dans une façon européenne
il y en a beaucoup c'est combien ces 10
15 50 100 plusieurs milliers de paysans
ce sont plusieurs milliers de paysans y
compris malgré la représentation
policière on a vu un vieux monsieur yosh
c'est moi j'ai beaucoup travaillé avec
Stéphane Hessel et ce vieux monsieur ce
vieux paysan me faisait vraiment penser
personnellement à Stéphane Hessel en
noir mais la même volonté de se battre
pour la dignité la même façon de
claudiquer un peu mais même si tu es un
poème à la jambe tu continues et par ta
forte tu entraînes les autres à se
battre et bien ce monsieur yosh il a
fait deux mois de prison simplement
parce qu'il demandait à ce que les
paysans soient correctement rémunérés
donc j'ai dit au directeur juridique je
ne vous juge de Total je vous juge pas
vous mais une entreprise qui fait 20
milliards de bénéfices 20 milliards vous
pouvez pas trouver 2600 euros pour que
cette famille est assez d'argent pour
acheter les la même surface de terre
qu'elle continue à vivre donc il y a ce
terme problème donc quand on a rencontré
les dirigeants total en Ouganda on a
commencé par parler des familles qui
crèvent de faim ou qui ne crève pas mais
qui perdent les enfants ne vont plus à
l'école et les parents n'ont plus de
quoi manger c'est pas totalement
qui leur a dit qu'il ne pouvait plus
continuer les à exploiter les terres et
c'est total qui ne les paye pas monsieur
pouyanet nous dit maintenant qu'il va
que depuis quelques mois ils sont
accélérés franchement une entreprise qui
l'an dernier a fait 20 milliards de
bénéfices mais même l'année d'avant il
fait des milliards surtout que ces
vidéos moi j'ai découvert le sujet il y
a seulement un an ça fait seulement 15
mois que je suis actif là-dessus que
parce que des ONG sont venus nous voir
mais j'ai vu des vidéos le monsieur
quand je te dis que j'ai vu un paysan
qui a perdu 30 kilos voilà c'est pas ça
déjà il y a 4 ans il se plaignait comme
de pas perculter sa terre ça fait quand
la ville l'été dernier ça faisait 5 ans
que c'était qu'il ne pouvait plus
utiliser ces terres donc je n'ai
franchement j'en ai honte il y a deux
débats est-ce qu'il faut faire en 2023
est-ce qu'on a encore besoin d'un énorme
pipeline de pétrole qui va faire 34
millions de tonnes de CO2 dans
l'atmosphère tu vois ce qu'on compte
toujours pas donné mon total que tu as
pu le premier argument de total donc
quand on arrive au siège au total en
Ouganda pour leur montrer que on est
d'accord pour dialoguer on commence par
parler des familles qui souffrent leur
demander de trouver des solutions pour
les familles qui souffrent et puis dit
qu'on ne comprend pas l'utilité de ce
pipeline et je leur montre le graphique
sur les noms et le rapport de la IE et
là il nous disent premièrement avec la
guerre en Ukraine on a besoin d'énergie
on a besoin de gaz pour l'Europe ce qui
est pas fou ce qui est pas faux mais ça
bien sûr ça n'est pas faux je viens de
vous expliquer que c'est on peut avoir
[__] du GNL américain donc je ne suis
pas complètement stupide il y a 5
minutes en répondant à une de tes
questions je dis qu'on peut avoir besoin
tant que la guerre en Ukraine continue
du GNL américain mais ce projet de
pipeline ça n'est pas du gaz pour
l'Europe c'est du pétrole brut pour le
reste du monde voilà et qui a été et ce
projet date d'il y a plus de 10 ans donc
il nous disent pas qu'ils ont inventé ce
projet pour répondre à l'Ukraine et de
toute façon le pétrole sortira dans six
ans s'ils arrivent à faire ce projet ce
qu'on ne souhaite pas et bien d'annoncer
qu'ils ont des problèmes pour le
financement des tensions géopolitiques
autour de l'énergie
c'est le pétrole faire du pétrole lourd
oui mais alors on y reviendra parce que
les deux arguments donc il nous explique
que c'est utile pour le bien mais c'est
juste pas dans c'est juste que pour moi
le problème du climat c'est une il y a
vraiment des milliers de gens qui
crèvent pendant ce n’est pas un problème
théorique je suis plutôt naturel
blagueur tout à l'heure si on a le temps
d'aller voir une bière je suis prêt à te
raconter plein de choses rigolotes mais
le problème du climat n'est pas très
très rigolo et donc le l'argument de
total c'est si c'est pas nous donc ils
n'ont qu'un argument pour justifier
l'utilité de ce projet voilà qu'elle
nous explique que c'est pour toi pour
toi ils n'ont aucun argument pour moi
de l'énergie donc forcément donner
d'autres arguments première argument il
faut du gaz pour l'Europe deuxième
argument l'Agence internationale de
l'énergie dit que il faut stopper les
nouveaux forages mais qu'on peut faire
des exceptions pour l'Afrique pour du
gaz pour l'Afrique passer à beaucoup de
gens aujourd'hui qui font la cuisine en
Afrique avec du charbon de bois ils vont
couper des arbres dans la forêt et que
ce serait mieux s'ils avaient du gaz et
je dis on est d'accord parce que quand
on se promène dans les rues de la
capitale on voit que des gens qui font
la cuisine dehors avec des foyers ou 80%
d'énergie avec le vent 80% d'énergie
sert à rien du tout et effectivement
quand on se promène dans le il y a plein
de gens qui vont couper des forêts pour
faire du charbon de bois donc je leur ai
dit si vous vouliez faire du gaz pour
l'Ouganda ce serait peut-être d'accord
avec les tarifs le gaz on va reparlera
du tarif après mais du coup y compris un
député écolo parce qu'en fait il y a
deux projets je veux pas être long dans
Google il y a deux projets il y a le
projet d'une petite raffinerie qui
ferait du gaz pour l'Ouganda et pour le
niveau régional si tu veux et puis ce
gros projet de Paris une catastrophique
pour le reste du monde et donc y compris
mon copain député écolo allemand parce
qu'on était plusieurs députés de
plusieurs familles depuis un pays le
député écolo allemand dit je ne pensais
pas dire ça un jour dans ma vie mais il
a dit devant la numéro de du ministère
je suis d'accord je pense effectivement
qu'une petite raffinerie qui fait du gaz
pour que les gens puissent faire de la
cuisine correctement en Ouganda sans
faire de la déforestation c'est un bon
projet que l'Europe pourrait aider et
donc mais par contre on a tous les cas
tous les députés qui étaient là et tous
les députés qui ont voté après ça la
résolution qu'on est revenu à Strasbourg
est-ce qu'on peut être d'accord pour un
petit projet avec quelques forages qui
ne sont pas dans le parc naturel et qui
vont faire du gaz pour les gens fassent
la cuisine en Ouganda sans faire de la
déforestation mais par contre un énorme
pipeline chauffé qui va faire uniquement
du pétrole lourd pour le reste du monde
la réponse est non voilà et donc il y a
pas d'autre argument non
c'est pour et j'ai vu en fonctionnaire
qui m'a dit le vrai argument c'est pour
les dividendes de Monsieur pouyanet
quelles sont les arguments que Total t'a
donné mais non pas d'autres ils n'en ont
pas d'autres et qu'on a invité monsieur
pouyanet à venir donc on a fait voter
une résolution qu'on est revenu au
Parlement le 16 septembre on a fait
voter une résolution totale c'est
déchaîné c'était moi qui négociait pour
mon groupe mais le gars qui est négocié
pour la droite qui est ça fait 8 ans lui
qu'il est député il m'a dit j'ai jamais
vu autant de violence c'est
François-Xavier Bellamy c'est Arnaud
donjon qui ont argumenté la veille du
vôtre c'était mis d'accord sur un texte
de consensus pour stopper complètement
les forages dans le parc naturel et pour
stopper au moins pendant un an le
pipeline parce que ce pack time
je finis pardon je suis pour te dire ce
qui est de ce que le vote du Parlement
on disait qu'il fallait le mieux ce
serait de stopper complètement ce
packline et de faire des énergies
renouvelables parce que le même jour
comme monsieur pouyanais le premier
février il y a 14 mois est allé signé en
Ouganda la décision finale d'investir
pour le packline il a signé une grande
convention pour développer les énergies
renouvelables pour faire croire qu'on
m'a enlevé sur les deux jambes on
continue à faire un peu de pétrole mais
on fait des renouvelables aujourd'hui la
seule chose que fait total ou
l'essentiel de leur énergie de leur
intelligence c'est pour le pipeline et
les renouvelables ils n'en font pas on
se dit le Parlement européen ils en font
quand même non en Ouganda de façon très
marginale aujourd'hui la communication
de de ils ont changé leur logo le
conseiller politique de monsieur
pouyanet me dit Pierre arrête de parler
de ce projet c'est un projet qui date
d'il y a 15 ans arrête de parler de
Total maintenant on est totalement
énergie on va vers les renouvelables et
je lui dis mais écoute si tu me dis que
ce projet en Ouganda ne correspond pas à
votre stratégie parce qu'il a déjà 15
ans et bien stop ce projet et faites des
énergies renouvelables et je vous
applaudirai quand tu fais une entreprise
qui fait 20 milliards de bénéfices elle
peut investir effectivement dans les
renouvelables en Europe et en Afrique
par contre aujourd'hui 100% de leur
communication qui est sur les
renouvelables partout tu vois total qui
avec des vaches avec de l'hydrogène vert
avec
des abeilles voilà et je pense que c'est
15% de leurs investissements qui sont
vraiment dans les renouvelables parce
que dans les chiffres qui donnent mais
non tu peux pas dire que tu te
transformes et tu souris mais je trouve
ça je suis pas mais tu as le droit de
sourire on est en république
tout à fait mais pendant je veux il faut
pas que je parle trop vite en plus tu
m'as dit qu'on avait le temps il y a
aucune raison que je parle trop vite
mais pourquoi c'est grave c'est que le
problème est vraiment en train de
s'aggraver il y a des cercles vicieux
qui sont en train de s'aggraver les
climatologues avaient raison là il y a
deux ans certains au moins avec le covid
19 le CO2 qui vient des camions ça se
calme et c'est avec le CO2 qui vient des
camions se calmer mais les feux de forêt
les cercles vicieux c'est que le
réchauffement climatique fait qu'il y a
de plus en plus de feux de forêt les
feux de forêts font de plus en plus de
CO2 et là ça c'est les feux de forêts en
Californie c'est un graphique qui dit à
1 an
recensé tous les feux de forêt depuis
presque un siècle et on voit que l'année
2020 à elle seule les surfaces ont
cramées c'est un tiers de toutes les
surfaces depuis un siècle pour l'année
2020 donc il y a vraiment une
accélération du problème et donc tous
ceux qui disaient au moins avec le
covid-19 ça c'est ça c'est un peu calmé
j'ai apporté de la courbe du CO2 depuis
1958 parce qu'on mesure le CO2 depuis
1958 dans l'atmosphère ça veut dire
quand même que depuis 1958 on sait qu'un
problème et bien dans les années 60 et
70 ça a augmenté de 0,8 unités chaque
année 0,8 ppm et là on augmente trois
fois plus vite 2,4 ppm voilà donc il y a
vraiment les parties par million donc
c'est juste pour dire que depuis 1958
les scientifiques américains ont mis à
3000 à Mona LOA sur une montagne pour
être très loin de toutes les centres
industrielles de toutes les autoroutes
de toutes les pollutions donc déjà en
1958 pour aller faire un observatoire à
3000 mètres ça veut dire que c'est quand
même coûteux c'est cher c'est compliqué
c'est dangereux donc ça veut dire que
déjà en 1958 on savait qu'il y avait un
problème avec le CO2
il y a un tel sans doute pas loin là
quand je suis pas répondu oui sans doute
en fait je ne sais pas mais je sais pas
viens de dire 800 doutes si tu connais
pas la réponse
non mais je sais bien c'était une
mauvaise blague mais c'était quand même
une blague voilà mais donc c'est pour
dire que la semaine dernière j'ai quand
même préparé cette émission et puis
catastrophique record bilan
catastrophique c'est du jamais vu depuis
5 millions d'années on est à 422 partis
par million moi quand je suis né on
était à 319 parties par million donc le
problème est en train de s'aggraver et
c'est irréversible les cercles vicieux
sont et du coup j'ai retrouvé une vidéo
que j'ai trouvé il y a 5 ou 6 ans dans
une de ses émissions et là aussi elle
est sur taxon à la spéculation.com on
voit une discussion à Sciences Po il y a
6 ans ou monsieur pouyanais dit vous
savez que toute la communauté il y a eu
l'accord de Paris l'accord de Paris
c'est tous les pays du monde qui disent
il faut stopper le dérèglement avant
qu'on arrive à 1,5 degrés ou au moins au
pire au pire du pire à 2 degrés de
réchauffement tous les pays du monde
disent si on dépasse les deux degrés de
réchauffement ça va être la catastrophe
les feux de forêts les sécheresses et
les inondations voilà et bien on a une
vidéo monsieur pouillané est à Sciences
Po et il est très tranquillement notre
scénario je ne sais pas si on va le
diffuser c'est un réchauffement de 3 ou
3,5 degrés
de moyenne oui donc la communauté
internationale tous les chefs d'État
tous les climatologues dit purée il faut
tout faire pour limiter à 1,5 degrés là
aujourd'hui la planète est réchauffée de
1,1 degré aujourd'hui en 2023 par
rapport à l'air pré-industriel par
rapport à avant qu'on mette autant de
CO2 on a plus 1,1 degré et il y a déjà
l'an dernier trois canicules en France
il y a déjà des centaines de milliers de
gens qui meurent à travers la planète il
y a déjà vu les gens qui viennent du
Pakistan il y a eu 8 épisodes de
moussons l'été dernier évidemment quand
il y a toujours eu des moussons quand
toi et moi on était petit il y avait
déjà des moussons en moyenne surtout moi
il y avait toi tu as toujours été grand
il y avait trois en moyenne il y avait
trois épisodes de moussant chaque été je
crois de finir en moyenne d'habitude il
y avait trois épisodes là il y a eu 8
épisodes de moussons donc alors que le
réchauffement n'est que de 1,1 degré on
a déjà des catastrophes partout on a
déjà des villages en France où il n'y a
plus d'eau potable les gens ont en
France ont des bouteilles d'eau au mois
d'avril et Monsieur pouyanais alors
qu'on est seulement à plus 1,1 degré et
monsieur pouyanet nous explique
tranquillou que scénario c'est plus
trois ou plus 3,5 mais ça scénario qui
est catastrophique sauf pour les
actionnaires et les
de Monsieur pouyanais
je te remets sur la question je t'ai
posé les pays africains on va leur dire
quoi vous consommez pas vos ressources
que vous avez sous vos pieds quels le
Parlement européen il a quelle autorité
pour dire à l'Ouganda vous faites pas le
projet alors justement donc c'est la
discussion que j'ai eu donc et
paradoxalement je vous donnerai pas son
nom mais la solution est venue d'un
cadre dirigeant de Total complètement
schizophrène j'en ai vu quelques-uns
depuis que je m'intéresse à la question
tu peux pas dire complètement j'enlève
voilà c'est juste que on s'entend après
plusieurs heures de réunion on se
retrouve seul la seule avec un directeur
de un dirigeant total et je lui dis je
l'appelle par son prénom j'ai dit
écoutez faut qu'on arrête tes bêtises
vous êtes sans doute père de famille
comme moi nos enfants vont nous détester
si on continue les conneries voilà les
autres étaient partis les autres
officiels on était juste deux personnes
devant un ascenseur je dirais pas où
c'est voilà et ce aux dirigeant de Total
je le mets face voilà on parle en
conscience pendant je finis il me dit
Pierre moi aussi je m'intéresse à ces
questions de climat voilà
et il me dit vous devriez retrouver il
me retrouve vous devriez retrouver le
discours de Raphaël Correa en 2007
pendant je finis là-dessus
qui en 2007 le président de l'équateur
avait dit j'ai du pétrole dans le sol
sous un parc naturel il y a swuni et
Raphaël Correa pris dans l'équateur en
2007 avait dit je peux renoncer à mon
pétrole ça va me faire 9 milliards de
manques à gagner et je demande à la
communauté internationale de mettre la
moitié 4,5 milliards sur la table et
donc c'est quand même incroyable c'est
un dirigeant de Total qui me dit la
solution en Ouganda comme ailleurs c'est
de dire ok effectivement on n'a pas
besoin de ce pétrole mais il faut mettre
de l'argent et depuis j'ai vu j'ai passé
plus d'une heure et demie avec la
ministre ougandaise de l'énergie et
effectivement Patrick puyannet leur a
promis de l'argent quand le Parlement a
voté sa résolution le président ougandé
était furieux monsieur mousse et Vigny
était furieux il a dit c'est total qui
m'a convaincu de faire ce projet alors
jusque là l'histoire c'était que Total
était au service de la population
engandaise et là le camp le Parlement
demande qu'on stoppe ce projet le
président moussevini est furieux et il
dit c'est monsieur puyanet qui m'a
convaincu de faire ce projet et parce
qu'il leur a promis de l'argent la
source la source de ça c'est quoi c'est
les déclarations de la de Monsieur
Moussier béni je peux les retrouver sur
les réseaux sociaux et la déclaration du
président de problèmes le parlementaire
on peut je suis pas venu avec tous mes
documents déjà je suis le seul à venir
c'est important mais oui je déteste le
mensonge ça fait 30 ans que je participe
au débat public tu ne trouveras pas un
et tu le fais bien de préciser pendant
mais je déteste le mensonge je suis
allergique je m'énerve dès que quelqu'un
ment donc je vois pas pourquoi moi-même
c'est peut-être une interprétation ok
alors ça je suis jamais on n'est jamais
à l'abri mais quand je dis que après le
vote du Parlement le président musévini
a fait des déclarations on peut les
retrouver sur ses réseaux sociaux sur la
présidence de l'Ouganda et sur la
présidence de la l'Assemblée nationale
ougandaise qui était furieux et en
particulier leurs arguments c'était
c'est total qui nous a convaincu de
faire ce projet parce que Total leur a
promis d'avoir de en disant si vous nous
laissez faire ce projet le pétrole il
sera pas pour vous puisque 100% du
pétrole c'est pour l'exportation mais
ils ont promis de l'argent et qu'on n'a
pas besoin de ce pétrole pourquoi tu dis
ça non mais pardon je dis puisque le
pétrole ils vont [__] en l'air une
partie du Parc Naturel réalisateur qui
disent qu'ils vont minimiser mais quand
même les éléphants et les girafes quand
tu vas passer ils ont fait jusqu'à
maintenant par arriver au parc naturel
il fallait prendre un petit bateau
quelqu'un m'a raconté que c'était le Nil
c'est un endroit magnifique c'est le
début d'une île qui passe et les
machinsfold donc le Nil coule il y a des
chutes et puis jusque là pour arriver au
parc naturel pour aller voir les girafes
et les éléphants il y a 2 ans il fallait
prendre un petit bateau et tu arrives
sans faire de bruit et là tu as comme un
énorme pont d'autoroute tout ça est sur
nos sites on a rapporté des images un
énorme point d'autoroute il faut encore
des énormes pour faire passer les
machines qui vont faire les trous dans
le parc naturel voilà mais donc le
président musévini dit mon projet ça
n'était pas ce gros pipeline mon projet
c'était juste quelques forages pour
faire du gaz pour l'autonomie de
l'Ouganda et c'est total qui m'habille
dans la tête de faire c'est une énorme
exploitation et un énorme pipeline 100%
du pétrole va partir vers le reste du
monde mais totalement dit vous aurez de
l'argent et en ce que tu dis c'est
documenter à Sota et documentaire voilà
c'est sûr je suis sûr et je rêve que
monsieur pouyanet me fasse un procès
comme ça je pourrais répondre à tout
parce qu'il refuse le débat comme il a
dit que notre résolution était
exagérée on a proposé au patron total de
venir pendant une heure devant le
Parlement européen il a refusé si je
l'appelle je lui propose de venir tu
débat avec grand plaisir je ne demande
que ça même à charmalcia qu'il a encore
refusé le dialogue franchement je et
donc et or effectivement l'Ouganda a
besoin d'argent le Ganda est quand on en
parle avec les dirigeants en petits
comité qu'on en parle de façon sereine
ils nous disent que oui ils ont besoin
d'argent et ça se comprend parce que
aujourd'hui leur système d'éducation est
payant et comme il y a une énorme
démographie il y a à peu près quatre
enfants par famille mais de toute façon
dans tous nos pays l'accès à l'éducation
de qualité est gratuit c'est un sujet
dont tous nos pays donc l'Ouganda veut
de l'argent pour avoir un système
d'éducation de qualité et gratuit le
Ganda aura bientôt trop
d'hydroélectricité ils font des grands
barrages et ils veulent mettre en place
un système des d'électricité pour que
l'électricité arrive dans toutes les
villes et villages et ils ne veulent pas
le laisser au privé pour pas que ce soit
trop cher voilà et troisièmement ils
veulent de l'argent pour un système
d'irrigation donc on peut très très bien
comprendre et nous simplement ce qu'on
leur dit c'est que 6 acceptent de
laisser le pétrole dans le sol on peut
effectivement lui remettre de l'argent
sur la table comme le comme l'équateur
elle avait demandé donc s'il y avait
seulement stopper l'Ouganda si c'est 0,5
milliards chaque année qu'il faut
trouver on peut trouver 0,5 milliards
mais ce projet en Ouganda c'est
seulement une des 500 bombes climatiques
qu'il faut stopper donc c'est pour ça
que depuis le mois d'octobre je me suis
remis au boulot au Parlement pour dire
pour relancer le débat sur la taxe sur
la spéculation parce que s'il fallait
seulement stopper le projet à nos Ganda
et trouver 0,5 on peut peut-être trouver
dans les 160 milliards et encore ça
commence à gratter partout voilà mais
comme on a besoin d'argent pour aider
l'Ouganda on a besoin parce que Lula le
président brésilien veut stopper la
déforestation et Marina Silva sa
ministre un super boulot mais il vous
explique un paysan qui crève de faim on
peut pas demander un paysan qui crève de
faim qui sait pas nourrir sa famille de
stopper la déforestation donc Lula et
Marina Silva veulent qu'on les aide et
pour le moment ils vont draguer ils se
font draguer par les Chinois donc si on
veut avoir de l'argent pour aider
l'Ouganda pour stopper les 500 bornes
climatiques et pour chez nous faire des
politiques de rénovation thermique et
pour donner les 100 milliards le patron
de la SNCF veut investir dans les
transports du quotidien pour qu'on ait
plus besoin de sa voiture il faut des
sous et c'est pour ça qu'on a relancé le
débat au Parlement et c'est pour ça que
je suis très heureux que le Parlement
européen ait voter cette résolution qui
dit on veut une taxe sur la spéculation
dans les avant la fin du mois de juin je
trouve une parenthèse
notre économie thermo-industrielle
et sous perfusion d'énergie fossile on
est d'accord
oui
quand quelqu'un qui est sur son lit
d'hôpital parce que là actuellement
l'économie européenne elle est un peu
sur son lit d'hôpital entre la guerre
entre le sevrage énergétique entre
l'inflation entre le chômage et je t'en
passe et je t'en passe qu'est-ce qui se
passe si total arrête de nous fournir
des hydrocarbures on va dire je suis
bien large dans trois ans on arrête le
pétrole qu'est-ce qui se passe est-ce
que tu penses que les énergies
renouvelables vont pouvoir aider est-ce
que tu penses que le nucléaire va
pouvoir aider ou est-ce qu'il faut pas
faire de nucléaire du tout est-ce que tu
penses que les énergies renouvelables
qui sont intermittentes et qu'on n'a pas
de capacité de stockage correct pour
pouvoir fournir quand il faut comment ça
se passe alors personne ne pense
sérieusement qu'on peut stopper tout le
pétrole dans trois ans je le répète
l'agence internationale de il faut
stopper tous les nouveaux forages tous
les nouveaux forages mais avec les
forages de pétrole et de gaz qui
existent déjà on en a assez pour
continuer dans les 20 ans qui viennent
ce qu'on dit au niveau européen c'est
qu'il faut stopper les ventes de
voitures des ventes de nouvelles
voitures avec un moteur thermique en
2035 mais les gens qui auront encore une
vieille voiture pour continuer à rouler
simplement on veut avoir une
métamorphose à plus rapidement et ce que
j'ai pas dit quand même je reviendrai ta
question c'est pourquoi j'en veux
vraiment au pétrolier c'est parce que le
diagnostic sur les réchauffements
climatiques il est à peu près stable
depuis 1979 en 1979 il y a un rapport
qui est remis à la Maison Blanche c'est
le président des États-Unis qui a
demandé au plus grand scientifique tu es
un bouquin qui est passionnant c'est un
livre perdre la terre qui fait par un
grand journaliste de New York Times qui
a enquêté pendant 10 ans c'est pas du
tout du complotisme et c'est un bouquin
passionnant qui te raconte comment des
gens en 79 il y avait un diagnostic le
rapport qui est remis à la Maison
Blanche montre qui a réchauffement
climatique qui est dû à l'activité
humaine mais pas de panique on a 20 ans
pour sortir des énergies carbonées et
développer des alternatives et tout le
monde se dit ah oui il y a un problème
mais c'est pas la panique on va
transformer trois mois plus tard Ronald
Regan arrive à la Maison Blanche et avec
Ronald Reagan c'est le lobby du Texas
c'est le pétrole youplaboom il essaie de
dézinguer et puis de nouveau en 88 il y
a mon ami Jean Josel et Claude Lorius
qui ont fait des découvertes vraiment
fondamentales sur le lien entre CO2 et
le réchauffement climatique qui sont
allés au pôle Sud Claude russe qui vient
de mourir hélas a fait des carottes de
glace et puis on a montré comment le en
analysant le gaz qui est dans ses
carottes de glace on fait un lien entre
le CO2 et le réchauffement climatique et
les travaux de tu nous avais reçu une
fois avec Jean-Joseph ici donc Jean et
Claude dorius les travaux sont tellement
évidents sur le lien entre CO2 et climat
que même Ronald Reagan Margaret Thatcher
des conservateurs sont OK pour créer le
GIEC créer une structure avec que des
scientifiques pour nous faire donc ça
veut dire que le diagnostic Ronald
Reagan avait réussi à tuer le débat
quand il arrive en 80 mais en 88 il est
obligé d'accepter le GIEC le premier
rapport du GIEC en 90 et là les gens se
disent waouh il y a vraiment maintenant
il y a un consensus il faut faire bouger
les choses c'est qui les gens tous les y
compris les chefs d'État Michel Rocard
n'est plus là mais Michel Rocard m'avait
raconté comment à cause du réchauffement
climatique il avait fait stopper il y
avait un petit à la fin de sa vie Michel
Rocard était ambassadeur d'épaule et ça
passe moquer dur mais il ambassadeur des
pingouins mais en fait c'était pas
c'était un vrai sujet c'est parce que en
1989 mais il y avait un projet pour
exploiter les minerais en dessous du
Pôle Nord et c'est la Nouvelle-Zélande
qui poussait ça et Michel Rocard et le
Premier ministre australien avait réussi
à le stopper voilà c'est le premier
ministre australien qui avait dit à
Rocard mais ça va être une catastrophe
si on commence à l'exploiter les
ressources minières entre du pôle du
pôle nord et le Premier ministre
australien dit l'Australie est un pays
trop petit pour pouvoir peser il
faudrait que la France nous aide je te
raconte ce qui est ce que Michel Rocard
avait raconté est-ce que j'ai pu
vérifier par d'autres moyens et donc
Michel Rocard obtient un Mitterrand s'en
fout mais Michel Rocard obtient que la
France bloque ce traité trois semaines
plus tard c'est pour te montrer comment
la politique d'un sens ou dans l'autre
peut faire bouger les choses trois
semaines plus tard Michel Rocard à
l'époque était premier ministre apprend
que le numéro 2 américain est furieux
parce que les États-Unis avaient déjà
signé ce traité pour l'exploitation des
ressources minières et donc James Baker
vient à Paris et il contourne Michel
Rocard et Rocard apprend par une fuite
qui a une réunion au Quai d'Orsay le
ministère doit faire étrangère ou le
numéro de américain vient voir du mal le
ministre français pour voir si on peut
court-circuiter Rocard et que la France
accepte l'exploitation et c'est
documenté ce que tu dis là c'est Michel
Rocard qui m'a raconté et des témoins
non non la conclusion c'est que la
France a obtenu l'annulation de ce
traité pendant ce qui est historique
c'est que donc Michel Rocard me raconte
qu'il apprend par la bande qui a cette
réunion qui prend une voiture qui quitte
patinant là où il y a le premier
ministre qui va au Quai d'Orsay il me
dit tu n'imagines pas je me suis fait
engueuler comme un petit garçon et James
par James Baker dans par James Baker le
numéro 2 américain qui explique à Rocard
mais Michel vous êtes fou il y aura
bientôt 9 milliards d'êtres humains il
faut réaliser toutes les ressources de
la planète et regard lui répondent James
il y aura bientôt 9 milliards d'êtres
humains il faut protéger la planète et
regard fait comprendre que il ne bougera
pas et Mitterrand n'a rien à [__] et
laisse Rocard et donc regarde la France
stop le projet de traiter pour
l'exploitation des ressources minières
et un an plus tard obtient le traité
totalement inverse un traité qui protège
l'épaule et qui en fait un lieu pour la
recherche et pour la paix et c'est pour
ça qu'à la fin de sa vie Michel Rocard
était ambassadeur d'épaule c'est parce
que dans les années 80-90 il y a des
protéger l'épaule j'en reviens au poids
des lobbys
tu parles d'une année bien lointaine
avec Rocard les américains ils étaient
déjà au courant qu'on était sur une
courbe exponentielle en terme de
population qu'on allait 9 milliards oui
on est d'accord oui parce que les
Américains malgré tout ce qu'on peut
leur dire ou leur reprocher
identifient vachement de trucs ils sont
quand même positionnés sur vachement de
trucs ils ont leur façon de gérer les
choses peut-être que tous les problèmes
pour eux ressemblent à des clous ou
peut-être qu'ils n'ont que des marteaux
mais mais ils anticipent beaucoup
tu parles de ressources de territoire
protégés
comment tu vois le nucléaire est-ce que
le nucléaire c'est un amortisseur à la
décroissance est-ce que c'est un gage de
souveraineté parce que pour faire le
malin devant les Américains il faut
quand même avoir un système énergétique
vachement costaud parce que là on est
plus sous la coupe des Russes mais
l'Europe mais on est sous la coupe des
Amériques même si les fournisseurs de
d'énergie américaine disent
méfiez-vous quand même il y aura
peut-être pas de plantes sauvetage
sous-entendu l'hiver 2023 faites gaffe
qu'est-ce qu'on fait en termes de
décroissance ou de croissance le
nucléaire qu’est-ce que tu en penses
justement tout ça c'est des questions
fondamentales Michel Rocard disait qu'à
deux sujets d'en n'arrivent pas à parler
en France sans s'engueuler et sans
monter en température c'est la question
du temps de travail et la question du
nucléaire et donc c'est bien si on
arrive à en parler sur elle-même
c'est le Mont Saint-Michel c'est encore
plus compliqué et là j'ai mis aucune
compétence je passe mon tour sur le Mont
Saint-Michel
la question est de savoir encore une
fois il y a aucune énergie qui est
propre et aucune énergie qui est facile
il y a aucune énergie qui n'a aucun
bilan carbone aucune qui n'a pas besoin
de ressources là est-ce qu'on est
capable de développer les énergies
renouvelables je le redis la France
pendant c'est pour te dire qu'il faut un
mix équilibré pendant c'est pour on est
le seul pays où tout le débat est pro
nucléaire ou anti-nucléaire l'un les
autres pays ils ont un mix plus
équilibré et ils font des politiques de
d'économie d'énergie les autres pays
d'Europe voilà ça là tu vois pendant ça
c'est les 27 pays je sais pas si la
technique peut faire un zoom c'est les
chiffres de pour les 27 pays d'Europe
qui c'est qui a dépassé qui a atteint
ses objectifs en matière de
renouvelables c'est la France seul pays
d'Europe à ne pas avoir atteint ses
objectifs d'énergie renouvelables la
France est le pays qui est là voilà la
France mais voilà mais sous prétexte
qu'on a du nucléaire on a des objectifs
pas très élevés et même ces objectifs
pas très élevés on ne les a pas atteints
et du coup quand on a plus le gaz russe
on se rend compte et que qu'on a
vraiment des problèmes donc est-ce qu'on
est capable d'avoir une vision un peu
équilibrée en disant que tous les autres
pays d'Europe ont investi beaucoup plus
dans les énergies renouvelables il y a
des pays qui ont juste atteint leurs
objectifs il y en a qui ont fait 5 % de
plus 10% de plus 15 % de plus y compris
des pays dans le Nord où il y a pas plus
de soleil que chez nous où ils ont fait
du photovoltaïque l'autre jour j'étais
en Bretagne avec des élus locaux chez
inauguré une centrale photovoltaïque
près de Rennes et aujourd'hui le
kilowattheure photovoltaïque est moins
cher que le kilowattheure nucléaire
pourtant on est en Bretagne c'est pas
les chiffres
le média water français il est le client
il est à combien pardon j'ai pas pris
les chiffres par coeur c'est juste que
les élus locaux qui étaient là pendant
je quand je connais les chiffres on me
reproche souvent d'avoir trop de
chiffres là d'avoir trop de graphique
c'est juste que les élus étaient là
disait qu'ils étaient tous contents
parce que même sans subvention le
l'électricité qui sortait de cette zone
photovoltaïque près de Rennes il faisait
des blagues pour dire on n'est pas
encore soit on n'est pas en Tunisie en
matière d'ensoleillement mais même en
Bretagne aujourd'hui le photovoltaïque
et combien de temps sur quelle période
je ne sais pas là je sors pas dans je
sors mon joker j'ai juste répété le fait
que c'était tout à fait rentable et donc
si je vais creuser la question et dans
une semaine il y aura la réponse sur mes
réseaux sur quoi sur juillet
c'est un investissement il y a un
co-financement des des collectivités
locales et des entreprises privées il y
avait là des entreprises privées et des
élus locaux et les entreprises privées
n'auraient pas mis des sous si c'était
pas effectivement rentable ça date de
quand ton petit tableau il y a 2 ans et
il a l'Allemagne elle en est où là
l'Allemagne a fait sa part des
renouvelables et par combien je ne sais
pas plus
plus 2% plus par rapport aux objectifs
mais il faudrait pour répondre vraiment
à ta question chaque pays avait négocié
des objectifs
la France a les objectifs faibles en
matière d'investissement dans les
renouvelables parce que la France dit
ont avec le nucléaire on a déjà une
électricité propre donc le nucléaire et
puis comme tu parles de l'Allemagne et
que je t'aide un peu à parler de
l'Allemagne est-ce que tu as entendu
notre ami Olaf scholls chez Volkswagen
annoncé son plan de transition
énergétique jusqu'en 2030
on a calculé alors tu vas peut-être se
faire facter ou pas on a calculé c'était
plus de 40 terrains de football de
panneaux solaires plus des stations
éoliennes offshore et une Shore 28 et 30
tous les jours
fallait construire ça jusqu'en 2030
écoute comme tu me demandes mes sources
je vais te demander tes sources mais je
pense qu'en fait mais je te fais
totalement confiance et je pense qu'en
vrai il y a un vrai débat de fond et je
redeviens tout à fait sérieux est-ce
qu'on fait croire aux gens que tous ceux
qui ont une grosse voiture thermique
aujourd'hui les SUV thermique ils auront
tous une grosse voiture électrique voilà
et je crains que certains sont encore y
compris chez Volkswagen dans l'idée que
le besoin de se transformer
ok mais donc je crains je crains que
chez nos dirigeants il y en a qui n'est
pas compris le besoin d'une vraie
métamorphose une vraie transformation de
même que aujourd'hui quand il y a 30 ans
on parlait d'avoir des vélos en
libre-service en disant c'est pas bien
que chacun est son vélo soit
propriétaire de son vélo on peut avoir
des vélos en libre-service certains
disaient c'est pas possible ça ne marche
qu'à La Rochelle parce que à La Rochelle
il y avait déjà des vélos en
libre-service mais c'est passé une
station de balnéaire mais ce qui
proposait que dans les à Paris ou
ailleurs il y a des vélos où tu prends
ton vélo puis tu le déposes tu es pas
chacun n'a pas son vélo mais peut
utiliser du vélo et on les prenait pour
des farfelus il y a 30 ans et maintenant
dans la plupart des grandes villes ou
des villes moyennes en Europe tu as des
systèmes où tu postes ton vélo et tu
n'as plus besoin de la voiture n'est-ce
pas en commun et donc je pense que sur
la question de la voiture bien sûr je
dis pas qu'on aura 0 voiture je pense
sur encore des moments on a besoin d'une
voiture parce qu'il y a des zones où il
y a pas de transport en commun ou le
vélo c'est pas facile ou on a besoin de
transporter quelque chose ou une
personne qui a du mal à bouger donc je
ne pense pas qu'on aille vers le zéro
voiture mais je ne pense pas non plus
qu'on puisse faire croire que tout le
monde aura sa grosse voiture électrique
qui dort dans son garage et qui est
utilisé 2% du temps il faudrait qu'on
ait des systèmes de où on partage des
voitures et donc je dis ça parce que je
pense que peut-être que la folle je ne
sais pas je n'ai pas vu voilà je le
texte très bien mais peut-être que
certains sont encore dans l'idée que
aller encore quelques dizaines d'années
monsieur le bourreau on peut continuer
encore à faire croire que tout le monde
aura sa grosse voiture et qui a rien à
changer à nos pratiques j'en reviens du
coup ça me fait une très très bonne
liaison pour le poids des lobbys parce
que donc je dis que en 88 il y a la
création du GIEC en 90 il y a le premier
rapport du GIEC et donc je commande
Michel roccaredo se disent qu'il faut
protéger la planète et au niveau
européen il y avait deux grands projets
en 91 j'ai découvert comment les lobbys
ont tué le lobby du pétrole et en
particulier ELF et Total ont tué deux
grands projets qui étaient au niveau
européen premièrement une écotaxe à
l'époque c'était avant le sommet de Rio
le Sommet de Rio était en juin 1992 et
le commissaire européen qui s'occupait
du climat voulait arriver avec deux
projets pour montrer que l'Europe
faisait le job une petite écotaxe on est
en 1991 donc on ne peut y aller
tranquillou mais on va transformer les
comportements avec une petite écotaxe et
puis un projet de ville sans voiture
j'ai imprimé que les 10 premières pages
mais c'est un truc 300 pages passionnant
ce gars-là était un visionnaire et en 91
il dit il s'agit pas de faire du Zéro
voiture absolument mais il faut investir
pour des transports en commun efficace
pour des vélos pour avoir d'autres modes
voilà et en 91 ce Monsieur le
Commissaire européen veut qu'on aille
qu'on arrive effectivement à aller vers
le une baisse très forte des émissions
de CO2 et les lobbies vont ne le
dézinguer et on a les Christophe
Bonneuil qui est directeur de recherche
au CNRS a montré comment il a retrouvé
dans les documents internes à elle fait
à Total d'abord il a retrouvé des
documents qui montrent que déjà en 71
total était au courant du réchauffement
climatique dans le journal interne de
total il est question du réchauffement
climatique et des conséquences que l'on
imagine catastrophique pas que non il y
a pas que mais non non effectivement aux
États-Unis le savait avant mais donc les
gens de chez Action étaient au courant
avant mais on voit comment en 71 je
crois que c'est le directeur ou un des
trois principaux dirigeants de Total
signent un édito dans le journal de
total pour parler du réchauffement
climatique on est en 71 et en 91 quand
le commissaire européen veut mettre en
place une petite ecotaxe et veut aller
progressivement vers une ville sans
voiture et bien on voit comment le
numéro de de Elf dit on a fait du bon
boulot on a stoppé ces projets avec la
gouvernement français et le commissaire
européen les travaux de crypto bonheur
je vais aussi tout mettre sur mon site
comme ça c'est celle qui vous écoute
je lui ai parlé
je déteste le mensonge vous avez raison
tu as raison je déteste la diffamation
et je déteste à diffamation aussi donc
ce et je déteste tout ce qui est forme
de toute forme de complotisme voilà donc
au début quand mes filles que le poids
du lobby au début je me dis mais non
tous les mois je suis un humaniste et
donc je pense que tous les hommes et
toutes les femmes veulent agir pour le
bien commun moi je suis un bonnet gâteau
de gauche éduqué par des gâteaux de
gauche et je pense que chacun et chacune
veut travailler pour le bien commun et
je me rends compte que ça ça se saurait
si tout le monde voulait travailler pour
le bien commun c'est toujours qui a tout
je fais ce que je peux
j'essaye j'essaye d'avoir une vie
imaginaire non je sais pas c'est un ami
imaginaire ce sera encore le prochain
débat donc juste pour te dire que hier
j'étais à Strasbourg dans un débat sur
le poids des lobbies du tabac pour te
dire que le poids des lobbies encore une
fois je déteste toutes les formes de
complotisme mais hier à Strasbourg avec
une amie écolo et une amie du groupe de
Mélenchon on était trois familles
politiques pour dire encore en 2023 le
poids des lobbies du tapas est
scandaleux on voit qu'il y a encore
plein de gens qui veulent ralentir des
directives pour limiter le tabac en
Europe et sur la caisse du climat j'y
reviens en 91 le commissaire européen
veut mettre en place une petite écotaxe
et un projet d'aller dans une ville sans
voiture et le numéro 2 de Elf explique
on a fait du bon boulot avec le
gouvernement français le gouvernement
français c'est Edith Cresson et
Dominique Strauss-Kahn et le commissaire
européen va démissionner deux semaines à
au lieu d'aller au sommet de Rio et de
faire du blabla c'est un mec qui était
qui essayait d'être cohérent il est mort
depuis j'ai pas pu le rencontrer il est
mort il y a un an mais il démissionne en
disant puisque les lobbies ont tué mon
projet d'écotax quand tu es bon projet
d'une ville sans voiture je vais pas
faire semblant je démissionne le
commissaire européen Charles du climat
démissionne en disant les lobbies ont
gagné si on avait 130 il y a 30 ans si
on avait en 92 soit on avait commencé à
mettre en place une écotaxe à faire une
ville sans voiture aujourd'hui on aurait
beaucoup moins de problèmes de
dérèglement climatique tu parles des
lobbies et comment ça se passe au
Parlement européen l'encadrement des
lobbys l'encadrement des influences
extérieures l'encadrement du graissage
de pâtes comment ça se passe là
récemment on a vu quelqu'un
qui travaillait au Parlement européen
c'est ça on a retrouvé combien des
centaines de milliers
de la presse
je ne connaissais pas cette dame je
pense que si je l'avais croisé trois
jours avant que c'est ça qui est
terrible c'est qu'elle est elle était
vice-présidente du Parlement ça pose
beaucoup de questions cette dame était
vice-présente du Parlement et
franchement c'était pas une des députés
les plus actives tu vois dans tous les
groupes on voit les députés qui
participent aux réunions qui ont des
combats qui s'engagent sur on sait que
celui-là son combat c'est ça elles sont
combattait ça nous on est un peu plus de
140 dans le groupe social-démocrate
donc la vice-présidente du Parlement
européen
se fait stopper avec des valises de
billets c'est ça oui je crois que j'ai
vu dans la presse belge dans la presse
française qu'il est question de un
million d'euros c'est incroyable c'est
super
qui ont été voilà c'est les chiffres
c'est qu'en gros elle et son conjoint
qui est en vie aussi au Parlement aurait
reçu mais je crois qu'elle est encore en
prison ça fait 4 mois déjà que la faire
éclater et je pense que la justice belge
a quand même des preuves de choses très
très graves puisque elle et son
compagnon sont toujours en prison et
donc c'est du juste du Grand Guignol on
se demande si c'est vraiment le cathare
qui l'a payé ou si c'est un coup à trois
bandes de l'Arabie Saoudite pour
diminuer l'influence du patri en 2022 se
promener avec une valise de billets
c'est son père qui se fait choper dans
le jardin près du Parlement c'est juste
c'est fait choper pourquoi est-ce qu'il
était sous surveillance apparemment elle
aurait prévenu je connais pas alors
autant il y a des fois tu me demandes
des sources là j'ai lu en diagonale
c'était tellement écœurant j'ai lu en
diagonale les articles de la presse qui
racontait ça mais donc apparemment elle
aurait prévenu je crois qu'il y a une je
crois que la police a débarqué
non je crois qu'elle a prévenu son père
en disant fais gaffe les policiers sont
en train de venir à chez moi dans
l'appartement mais là je suis pas sûr de
moi et que du coup son père était il y a
un hôtel qui est assez connu à Bruxelles
où là je l'ai chef d'État qui est quand
il y a un Conseil européen quand il y a
les 27 chefs d'État un hôtel qui est pas
très loin des centres de pouvoir le
conseil et la commune et le Parlement et
je crois que son père s'est fait choper
avec une valise de billets et contre
parce quitter l'hôtel si j'ai bien
compris et quand l'argent qui était dans
la valise et l'argent qu'on a retrouvé
chez cette dame au total il y avait un
million d'euros tu avais l'impression
d'une partie de Monopoly tu as vu il y
avait des photos dans la presse belge
j'avais l'impression que c'est une des
des à la fin du Monopoly quand tu fais
des tas de fou la justice a donc mis la
main sur 1,5 millions d'euros selon nos
confrères du Soir
également par le parquet
comment ça se passe au Parlement
européen c'est on table sur la probité
des élus pour éviter de se faire
graisser pour éviter alors de recevoir
des cadeaux paraît-il qu'il y a une
caverne d'Alibaba des des cadeaux reçus
et que certains élus remettent dans la
caverne Alibaba pour pas éviter de se
faire pour éviter éviter tout ça est-ce
que il y a la police vous protège de ça
est-ce que les lobbyistes sont en cartés
est-ce que tout le monde est affilié
voilà les lobbystes ils sont comme si
ils vont rentrer telle date parce que
j'ai une mauvaise expérience du
Parlement européen
un jour je me suis amusé à les faire du
renseignement économique là-bas à titre
personnel tu sais comment on fait du
renseignement économique au Parlement
européen non tu attends que ça sorte ils
vont tous se beurrer la gueule en face
tu sais là où il y a tous les bars
là c'est c'est fantastique tu laisserais
alors à l'époque il y a plus de 15 ans
tu arrives tu laisses traîner tes
oreilles tu payes des coups à tout le
monde tu fais semblant de te marrer et
là ça parle beaucoup ça a peut-être
changé donc là et là cette affaire
montre qu'il y a encore il y a des
règles du jeu donc en principe les
lobbies
en gros 700 députés et elle n'a
peut-être il y en a trois qui ont fait
des trucs absolument scandaleux
apparemment d'après ce que ce qu'on va
dans la presse il y en a trois qui ont
fait des trucs absolument scandaleux et
j'espère qu'ils vont vraiment faire de
la prison j'ai 3 qui ont été chopés
évidemment ils ont droit à un procès
équitable évidemment ils ont droit à des
avocats évidemment mais j'espère qu'ils
vont si effectivement les faits sont
avérés qui vont faire de la vraie prison
et non pas de la prison avec sursis ou
de la prison où tu restes chez toi et tu
as un petit bracelet mais tu restes
quand même chez toi très cool et tu vas
au resto comme on le voit en France
parfois donc je pense que on nous a pas
obligé d'être députés on a demandé au
peuple de nous faire confiance et quand
tu es député tu dois être absolument
irréprochable donc je pense que aussi
effectivement les faits sont avérés il
faut qu'il fasse de la prison et je
pense qu'il faut conduire si les règles
parce que y compris la Réunion où
j'étais hier sur les lobbys du tabac il
y a avant-hier la médiatrice européenne
donc c'est pas du blabla c'est pas des
rumeurs c'est pas trois complotistes qui
inventé des problèmes la médiatrice a
sorti un rapport pour demander à la
Commission européenne de respecter les
règles en disant il y a une directive il
y a deux directives sur le tabac qui
devaient sortir en décembre 2022 on en
avril 2023 ils sont toujours pas sortis
il y a 42 il y a des ONG qui ont fait le
travail qui est à 42 lobbies ceux du
tabac qui sont accrédités or apparemment
quand et en principe quand tu rencontres
un ou une lobbyiste tu dois le déclarer
tu as un registre tu dois déclarer les
gens que tu que tu rencontres quel que
soit que soit voilà juste pour être
transparent et apparemment la médiatrice
donc c'est une autorité importante en
Europe a sorti un rapport vitriol mardi
pour dire que elle demande à la
Commission européenne d'être beaucoup
plus transparente sur les rencontres
entre les gens de la Direction générale
de la santé et les lobbies du tabac tu
peux tu parles de questions de
transparence
pour tu sais qu'on a traversé les coïtes
on l'a pas encore fini d'ailleurs ça il
y a encore le virus qui traîne
d'ailleurs tu parles de transparence
il y a eu beaucoup de milliards
européens qui ont été utilisés pour
acheter des vaccins
comment ça se fait que les SMS d'Ursula
Vander Layenne n'est pas été remis sur
la table pour dire voilà les contrats
s'étend on est passé comme ça
anormal je trouve ça que ça on doit être
transparent doit pas avoir peur d'être
transparent encore une fois on est dans
un moment de grande défiance 4 la
plupart des politiques sont complètement
honnêtes la plupart des commissaires des
députés des maires non mais la plupart
des mères euro sont quasiment bénévoles
il y a plein de villages qui tiennent
uniquement passer à un ou une retraité
qui accepte pour une indemnité de 600
euros par mois et les écoriables et
serviables 6 jours par semaine voilà et
et on montre toujours les trois voyous
pour être poli qui se sont foutus plein
de poche donc je redis que si les faits
sont avérés les trois députés qui ont
accepté qu'ils ont compromis doivent
aller en prison les sanctions navette
forte mais qu'après ça il faut qu'on
améliore les règles du jeu qu'on les
fasse respecter et qu'on doit avoir la
plus grande transparence bien que dans
une urgence il y a en négocie un peu
vite mais après ça des contrats sur les
vaccins raconte un peu ça s'est fait par
SMS alors est-ce que c'était un
téléphone sécurisé pas sécurisé
on a tous comme 24 heures par jour donc
moi les domaines où je travaille
beaucoup c'est des questions de climat
c'est les questions de justice sociale
c'est permettre à tout le monde d'avoir
un boulot et un logement pas trop cher
et trouver de l'argent pour tout ça et
donc mais par ailleurs j'ai des
collègues qui me disent que sur les
questions de santé il y a quand même un
trouble donc hier je te dis j'ai passé
deux heures avec des collègues qui eux
sont eux et elles sont spécialisés quels
sont de santé et qui m'ont demandé de
venir pour montrer qu'on faisait un
combat commun contre les lobbies du
pétrole et contre les lobbies du tabac
mais sur la question des contrats pour
le pour les vaccin je ne prétends pas
être un spécialiste donc je déteste
inventer des réponses alors juste ton
téléphone portable a été audité par une
autorité compétente pour savoir pour
savoir si tu as pas un Pegasus
trois fois et l'ordinateur à échoué que
l'ordinateur l'ordinateur le Parlement
européen nous propose parce
qu'effectivement il y a des députés qui
étaient sur écoute il y a un député de
mon Rocky je sais plus sinon je le
savais je te dirai et du coup comme moi
j'ai parfois des bruits bizarres et que
je génère les gens de chez Total ou
ailleurs j'ai pas en train de
sous-entendre que total pour être mes
souris non je ne t'entends rien je suis
sûr que je ne dirai je n'en sais rien je
sais je les énerve beaucoup je sais que
le texte a été voté par le Parlement
total ça montre quand même qu'on peut
faire bouger les lignes totales avec
promis que son plan de financement pour
ce pipeline serait fini au mois de mars
2023 il vient d'annoncer que ce sera
fini pour le mois de décembre donc je
pense que le vote de la résolution du
Parlement et le travail d'argumentaire
qu'on fait et puis il y a toutes les ONG
il y a déjà 25 banques les ONG moi ça
fait seulement un an que je suis sur le
ce sujet il y a des ONG qui travaillent
depuis très longtemps et au risque de la
vie de certains et certaines en Afrique
donc il y a déjà 25 banques qui ont dit
non pour financer ce projet donc voilà
donc je sais pas mais les gens de chez
Total me détestent parce que le fait
qu'un député rapporteur général du
budget s'engage dans ce combat ça les
énervait quand c'était des paysans en
Ouganda on les foutu en prison quand
c'est des députés c'est un peu plus
compliqué donc
j'ai demandé trois fois à ce que je suis
allé porter on est dans de très bonne
condition de travail au Parlement
européen on a aucune excuse pour ne pas
bosser en particulier on a un service
informatique dès qu'on a un problème les
services informatiques te répartent ton
ordi ou te des bugs et j'ai demandé
trois fois qu'on nous dit mon téléphone
et leur système est pas arrivé donc je
vais bientôt recommencer c'est une
blague non c'est pas une blague je sais
pas ils ont ça je sais pas tu as quoi
comme téléphone
d'avoir un téléphone chiffré
écoute je sais pas en même temps je ne
pense pas que je sois que ce peut-être
qui travaille sur les questions
internationale un jour on a reçu un
général ici et genre pas n'importe qui
genre du costaud et on lui parlait de
guerre économique et on lui parlait de
tout ça et il nous a dit ça me fait
penser un peu un
épisode de Jurassic Park tu sais le
tyrannosaure rex qui attrape une petite
bestiole et qui la mange entièrement la
secouant dans tous les sens on a
l'impression que le Parlement européen
c'est une passoire
on a vu quelques reportages de députés
qui venaient pointer juste pour avoir
leur petit chèque d'indemnités puis
repartait on voit que les contrats de
transparence entre le peuple et le
Parlement bon c'est respecté on peut
normalement en termes de guerre
économique tu me dis que toi tu as
demandé trois fois que ton téléphone
technique faut pas pardon
je fais confiance aux gens du service
informatique ils ont lancé trois fois et
puis il y a eu un pet et il était 19h le
soir il devait finir leur journée mais
il y a peut-être quelques députés qui
foutent rien mais la plupart des députés
quand même on est à 8h30 au boulot le
matin et on finit souvent à 23h et on
bosse et on bosse et on cherche des
solutions donc je pense que il y en a
plein qui au contraire on se réveille la
nuit dans mais est-ce que je fais le
maximum est-ce que je fais le maximum
pour stopper la guerre en Ukraine est-ce
que je fais le maximum l'autre jour moi
j'y pense en permanence quand je pense à
l'agriculture il y a une paysanne qui
s'est suicidée dans les Côtes d'Armor
dans sa salle de trade parce qu'elle
arrivait plus à vivre donc moi je me
mets très régulièrement que je suis une
famille à des agriculteurs j'ai fait la
gros donc pour moi quand je parle de
politique agricole c'est pas un truc
théorique je pense en même temps qu'il
faut et je me dis cette femme elle s'est
suicidée parce qu'elle n'en pouvait plus
elle était elle travaille 80 heures par
semaine elle arrivait pas à gagner sa
vie et j'imagine vraiment que son mari
et ses enfants parce que la vie continue
il y a toujours un troupeau donc il
rentre dans la salle de traite il se dit
c'est là que maman c'est difficile c'est
là que ma femme se suicidé et je donc
pour moi c'est un combat fondamental
d'avoir une politique agricole qui
protège le revenu des paysans et qui en
même temps protège la planète donc la
plupart des paysans la plupart des
députés essayent de faire leur job donc
il y en a peut-être quelques-uns qui
font l'aller-retour pour signer pour
dire qu'ils sont là et ils ont le
salaire à la fin du mois mais il y en a
aussi qui font plutôt des heures sup et
on se plaint pas parce que autant je
trouve scandaleux la réforme des
retraites qui fait que dans les métiers
où on est cassé physiquement demande aux
gens de travailler plus longtemps on a
un boulot qui est quand même passionnant
et en plus moi j'ai la chance avec mes
combats qui a tous les jours des gens
qui m'encouragent ça fait du bien de
l'entendre comme qui a pas que des
corrompus oui non il y a pas de raison
de plus pour que ceux et celles qu'ils
ont corrompu voilà ils ont on va pas
leur couper la tête je suis contre la
peine de mort mais qu'il fasse trois ans
de prison ferme ça fera réfléchir les
prochains et trois ans de prison ferme
ça te fous pas tu as vu en l'air mais tu
réfléchis à ce que tu fais de ta vie et
pourquoi tu as déconner et du coup les
prochains qui ont proposera une petite
valise ils se diront je risque trois ans
une petite valise une petite montre
même pas un pot de Nutella
des petites hirondelles non mais
peut-être que un gars qui fait 18 jours
de grève de la femme pour taxer la
spéculation je suis peut-être pas le
plus facile à corrompre mais je vois
comment effectivement quand même il y en
a qui viennent quand on allait voté le
texte pour dire qu'il fallait stopper
les ventes des nouvelles voitures et des
moteurs thermiques en 2035 j'ai eu un
coup de fil d'un ami député qui me dit
Pierre lundi est-ce que tu as Bruxelles
parce qu'il y a le patron de toute
l'automobile allemande il serait très
content de dîner avec toi je dis écoute
non vraiment lundi je suis déjà pris je
suis à Bruxelles mais je suis déjà pris
je suis vraiment désolé mais tu le
remercie pour l'invitation une autre
fois
une heure après il m'appelle en tant
pire il est encore là le lendemain à 11h
je vais dire cet ancien député j'écoute
tu le remercie mais non je ne peux pas
voilà et puis le lendemain le mardi il
vient frapper cet ancien député viens
frapper à mon bureau en deuxième étage
il me dit Pierre tu sais que pour moi
c'est vraiment important l'emploi
industriel dans ma dans ma région c'est
vraiment et je lui explique écoute je
sais très bien pourquoi tu veux que je
vois le patron de l'industrie de
l'industrie automobile allemande je sais
très bien
je suppute mais que quand tu vas bientôt
voter une un texte qui demande qu'on
stoppe les ventes de nouveaux moteurs
thermiques en 2035 voilà et je lui dis
écoute on peut se parler là cette
semaine j'ai pas le temps et je voterai
voilà mais dis-lui que pour moi il n'y a
pas de problème de destruction d'emploi
parce que les gens ok si on fait une si
on fait il y aura besoin de moins de
travail si tout le monde n'a pas sa
grosse voiture et si on a des voitures
électriques il y aura besoin de moins de
travail mais ça ne veut pas dire des
suppressions d'emploi je veux dire
rappelle-toi en 93 93 comment dire à
Bruxelles Volkswagen avait annoncé qu'il
y avait 30000 personnes entre autres
Volkswagen avait dit ça va être une
catastrophe 30.000 licenciements et les
politiques a dit on dit vous faites
comme vous voulez mais ce sera zéro
licenciement zéro pendant excusez-moi
j'ai fini zéro licenciement et du coup
Volkswagen ils sont tous à 28 heures ils
sont tous passés c'est pour dire que
expliquer que à cause du climat on va
licencier des gens maintenant quand 93
quand il y avait 30000 personnes en trop
chez Volkswagen les politiques ont agi
avec force en disant nous ne sommes pas
responsables du personnel on sait pas
comment on fait concrètement mais ce
sera 0 licenciement et il y a un mois
après il y avait un accord pour dire on
passe tout le monde à 28 heures par
semaine et il y a aucun licenciement et
Volkswagen à continuer à fonctionner
très bien donc ce qui nous disent au nom
on aimerait vous rencontrer parce que
bien sûr il faut sauver le climat mais
nous laissez-nous polluer encore pendant
15 ans de plus au nom de l'emploi pas au
nom de nos dividendes au nom de l'emploi
je leur ai dit non je n'ai pas le temps
de rencontrer ton patron je sais très
bien pourquoi il veut me voir de le
patron de pâtes en patron mais le patron
de l'industrie je parle vite tu me
reposes déjà trop long donc je lui dis
que ton reste amis je comprends très
bien que tu veuilles que je rencontre ce
haut des dirigeant allemand je comprends
très bien son inquiétude mais dis-lui
bien qu'on peut très bien en même temps
accélérer la transformation écologique
et ne supprimer aucun emploi et que s'il
y a besoin de moins de travail pour les
voitures il y aura peut-être besoin de
plus de de travail pour faire des
tramways ou d'autres moyens de
transports en commun et même si on passe
à la semaine de 28 heures c'est pas une
catastrophe oui ok donc là vous venez de
voter l'interdiction des moteurs
thermiques pour quelle année 2035 les
nouvelles voitures mais ceux qui ont
ceux qui ont acheté deux mois avant de
continueront et
la Chine a été contente non un peu comme
le plan de transition écologique
allemand c'est à dire que
la Chine qui produit les batteries qui
produit la chaîne totale du véhicule
électrique nous en Europe on est un peu
en short avec nos industries notre
business notre business et pas prêt on
détient aucunement la chaîne totale de
production c'est-à-dire du minerai
jusque au cuir synthétique de la voiture
électrique comment ça se passe en termes
d'emploi de développement industriel
alors que on n'a pas la ressource
énergétique énergétique pour
réindustrialiser rien industrialisée et
on a un trou d'air d'une quinzaine
d'années les chinois ils se frottent les
mains de votre décision là non pardon
peut-être la main mais nous en même
temps on essaie d'avoir une vision
globale est-ce que dit le Parlement
c'est que justement on veut aussi
pouvoir développer l'industrie sur ces
sur ces secteurs d'activités
mais quand les Américains
je répète prenant une comparaison on a
tous des téléphones avec Internet et les
écrans tactiles ce qu'on oublie c'est
que c'est l'Europe qui a inventé
Internet et les écrans tactiles ce sont
les chercheurs et les chercheurs du
cernes il faut pas l'oublier on a mis
des milliards dans la recherche non mais
il y a plein de gens qui ne le savent
pas toi peut-être que tu le sais mais
c'est pour montrer qu'à chaque fois on
est les couillons utiles c'est l'Europe
qui développe les idées mais voilà mais
si on est d'accord yupaboom donc c'est
juste pour dire que est-ce qu'on est
obligé de faire trois fois la même
erreur donc moi je le savais pas quand
il y a 30 ans je le savais pas mais ce
sont des chercheurs et des chercheuses
européennes qui cherchaient le boson de
X une particularité et on aura ils ont
tenu ça veut dire que la recherche
fondamentale ça peut être utile
avant je vais regarder beaucoup plus
régulièrement donc on leur a dit ils
nous ont dit qu'il avait besoin de
quelques milliards pour faire un énorme
accélérateur pour trouver le bon temps
de X et les politiques de l'époque on
n'est pas seulement dans le court terme
on dit ok bon on va vous donner quelques
milliards et chemin faisant en faisant
un truc qui était pas utile
immédiatement pour le grand public
chercher le boson chemin faisant comme
ils avaient besoin d'échanger beaucoup
d'informations ils ont inventé internet
ils ont inventé les écrans tactiles donc
c'est à chaque fois que nous on est sur
nos téléphones pour faire bouger des
trucs on clique sur une vidéo ce sont
des Européens des européennes qui ont
inventé Internet et les écrans tactiles
mais après ça comme des imbéciles on a
laissé les Américains tout aspirer donc
c'est chez nous qu'on a payé la
recherche fondamentale c'est des
cerveaux européens européennes en
dialogue avec d'autres qui ont inventé
ça et c'est tout est parti aux
Etats-Unis sur le photovoltaïque on a
laissé tout partir en Chine et là de
nouveau j'ai vu déjà Charles audio qui
avait le moral à zéro en disant sur
l'hydrogène vert c'est en Europe qu'on
dépose le plus de brevets il s'agit pas
dire que les autres sont des imbéciles
mais factuellement c'est en Europe qu'on
fait le plus de brevets sur l'hydrogène
vert le CEA a débordé pour faire du
photovoltaïque plus efficace avec des
meilleurs rendements et un
photovoltaïque qui est plus recyclable
et qui est fait avec moins de le bilan
carbone est meilleur et donc on pourrait
faire du photovoltaïque en Europe avec
un meilleur rendement une meilleure
efficacité une valeur et les Américains
et c'est à ce moment-là que les
Américains votent
360 milliards sur la table avec des
subventions si vous venez chez moi c'est
75% de subventions pour l'hydrogène on
te fait un cadeau qui représente 75% du
code production c'est automatique et ça
dure pendant 10 ans et en Europe on est
encore en train de tortiller pour dire
oui peut-être qu'on pourrait avoir des
aides mais il faut pas plus de 3 ans et
donc nous on se bat au Parlement
européen et encore hier je te dis je
parle avec un commissaire qui est
d'accord avec nous pour dire mais [__]
on arrête les blagues on arrête les
demi-mesures pardon
en Béarn ce n'est pas mauvais le guerre
je coupe voilà donc non mais c'est quand
quand ford annonce qu'on coupe 3800
postes en Europe et qu'en met 3,5
milliards d'investissements des
États-Unis on est stupide si on laisse
une démorragie de nouveau de notre
industrie c'est chez nous qui a des
chercheurs à des chercheuses qui ont des
qui font les brevets donc je me bats
mais je ne suis que un député par 1700
mais je fais l'aller-retour je suis
camionnette deux fois l'Assemblée
nationale pour bousculer Bruno Le Maire
puis je le répète la solution c'est de
trouver du fric et que ce soit pour le
climat ou pour lutter contre les
délocalisations la meilleure solution
qui aujourd'hui sur la table c'est la
taxe sur la spéculation
peut-être qu'on peut regarder mines
encore une fois pendant de toute façon
je le répète le but n'est pas que tous
ceux qui ont ceux et celles qui ont une
grosse voiture thermique et une grosse
voiture électrique pas sinon là on aura
besoin de terrain avec un volume
catastrophique je te coupe tu sais qu'au
départ la bagnole qui consommait
tranquille aux États-Unis il y avait
très peu de personnes qui avaient mis à
part la Ford T il y avait très peu de
personnes qui voulaient avec une banane
qui voulait à 30 litres bon après la
voiture s'est démocratisée tout le monde
a pris une petite bagnole mais résultat
des courses la pression sur les
ressources a quand même augmenté
c'est-à-dire que là on commence on a
tous des grosses bagnoles du monde les
riches ont des grosses bagnoles à 100000
balles électriques il a même si il
baisse son prix en ce moment
le prix minimum c'est quoi c'est 35000
40000 euros donc la question revenons
sur les mines la question n'est que je
ne pense pas que chacun et chacune aura
sa voiture électrique de même que si on
a tous notre petite bagnole qui fait 55
kg avec une toute petite batterie qui va
fonctionner super longtemps ainsi de
suite tu as compris mon raisonnement je
répète on n'aura pas tous je pense pas
que ce soit souhaitable prenez tous une
voiture on en a pas besoin de tous les
jours d'avoir une voiture ok c'est plus
facile de quand j'ai besoin une petite
voiture d'habitude je prends des
transports en commun d'habitude je
prends mon vélo d'habitude je marche à
pied et que quand j'aurai besoin d'une
voiture un jour ce sera une toute petite
passer juste pour déplacer quelqu'un une
fois que ce sera une voiture plus grosse
pour transporter quelque chose
électrique
en Europe est-ce qu'on réouvre des mines
ou pas j'ai pas bien réfléchir la
question pardon c'est pas pour botter en
tout je sais pas pour j'ai pas peur
c'est que j'ai pas beaucoup à réfléchi
peut-être qu'il faudrait l'ouvrir et
peut-être qu'il faut faire un
partenariat avec d'autres pays où il y a
beaucoup je te dis la RDC la République
démocratique du Congo j'ai passé une
heure et demie avec la ministre ils ont
découvert des mines considérables et ça
aurait de la gueule que l'Europe et
l'Afrique de quoi des mines sur les
terres rares on a besoin justement pour
les batteries et donc elle dit tiens
aussi non on est bien on a besoin de
plus ils ont des
ils ont des ressources importantes et
est-ce qu'on est fondamentalement une
phrase que j'ai répété une phrase sans
doute une phase une répéter plusieurs
fois dans mes là j'ai fait trois
déplacements en Afrique moi je prends
jamais l'avion mais sur les questions de
climat il y a plein de choses qui
bougent en Afrique et donc une phrase
que j'ai souvent répétée parce que je
voyais bien que certaines blancs qui
viennent je citer la phrase de Martin
Luther King il faut apprendre à vivre
comme des frères et des sœurs ou se
préparer à mourir comme des imbéciles et
la question du climat nous rappelle
vraiment à ce principe vraiment de
responsabilité oui et je c'est l'Europe
qui depuis je leur ai dit à chaque fois
devant des milices devant des c'est pas
pour ce flageller mais l'Europe depuis
deux siècles et avec les États-Unis a
fait le plus de CO2 donc oui l'Europe
est parmi les deux premiers responsables
du CO2 donc le dérèglement climatique et
c'est en Europe que pour le moment on
est plutôt protégé du règlement
climatique et son Afrique qui a le plus
événement climatique catastrophique donc
on a besoin non pas de s'engueuler on
peut soit ressasser toutes les
déceptions soit on est capable d'un
nouveau partenariat mais ça suppose de
mettre du fric les pays d'Afrique n'en
peuvent plus du blabla et s'il y a pas
de l'argent frais sur soit on est
capable à l'occasion du climat d'avoir
un nouveau départ dans les relations
entre l'Europe et l'Afrique soit on
continue la déception il y a plein de
pays d'Afrique qui n'en peuvent plus
l'Europe et qui vont se tourner vers la
Russie ou vers la Chine et là ça va être
le chaos
si on se tourne vers la Russie ou la
Chine c'est le cas où si c'est dingue de
compétition si ça en perm sur on ne sort
pas d'une logique de compétition si on
ne prend pas si on continue à vouloir la
croissance économique la croissance
économique ça va être compliqué
si on n'a pas de souveraineté européenne
je pense qu'il faut avoir une
souveraineté mais que c'était illusoire
de croire qu'on a aucune souveraineté à
100% le dérèglement climatique ou bien
on arrive à changer à sauver la planète
ou bien il y aura pas de souveraineté si
on continue à avoir le dérèglement
climatique et il s'accélère et bien qui
que tu sois ou que tu sois que tu sois
riche ou pauvre tu peux te faire avoir
par le Diagon climatique en Europe en
même temps oui il faut c'est pas dans je
sais pas si je vais dire il faut en même
temps oui reconquérir une souveraineté
en matière industrielle et on peut pas
continuer à avoir les Américains nous
ont piqué internet alors que c'est nous
qui est voilà et les chinois ils ont
piqué les photosvoltaïques donc oui
c'est important légitime urgent de
regagner une souveraineté industrielle
mais croire qu'on ait une souveraineté
une autonomie je regarde mon nombril et
le reste du monde peut s'effondrer c'est
faux on est interdépendant on l'a vu
avec le virus mais le dérèglement
climatique nous le rappelle aussi
[Musique]
tu parles de construire la pêche je suis
désolé pardon il y a des politiques qui
parlent de tout moi je préfère que tu me
dis ça moi j'essaye et ben par contre
quand je vois des sujets et après ça je
bouille la chemise voilà et quand je sur
le climat je vais Bruno Le Maire me
déteste parce que je ne lâche pas j'ai
les deux fois là tu penses qu'il te
détestent en fait pas me le dire mais
non je pense pas assez vite pour dire
qu'il y a des il y a des tout est
respectable il y a des politiques en les
écoutant on a l'impression qu'ils ont
réponse à tout mais quand ils sont au
pouvoir ils règlent aucun problème et
moi je me centre sur un nombre limité de
sujets mais sur les questions sociales
peut-être on parlera la semaine de 4
jours tout à l'heure sur les questions
de climat je crois que parce que j'ai
écouté beaucoup de gens je crois que
j'ai des choses solides et que derrière
je fais le service après-vente alors je
vais essayer de faire bouger les choses
je vais te poser deux trois questions
sur le climat là en ce moment en Asie en
Thaïlande il fait des chaleurs de dingue
avec un taux d'humidité de dingue donc
tu sais quand tu associe chaleur de
dingue avec taux d'humidité dedans donc
c'est une étude et dont tu meurs et donc
tu clams oui d'accord
les migrations climatiques
ça touche des zones qui sont
ultra dans ces monts peuplés
envisage la suite
mais tout à l'heure je parlais des
climatologues du GIEC ils ont eu le prix
Nobel de la paix ils n'ont pas eu le
prix Nobel de physique ou de chimie
c'est des physiciens des chimistes et
d'analyses du gaz ils vont voir de
l'océan voilà
fait autant de guerre
[Musique]
si on laisse le réchauffement climatique
continuer on peut avoir des catastrophes
il y a quelques années il y a eu de
telles inondations à Paris et dans la
région que la récolte de blettes a du
30%. donc on peut avoir des impacts mais
on peut avoir des conflits majeurs quand
la Banque mondiale annonce 150 millions
de réfugiés climatiques parce que dans
20 ans les gens auront le choix entre
crever sur place ou essayer de bouger et
bien je ne sais pas si on saura cueillir
quand on dit que c'est 90 millions
d'années de femmes qui devront quitter
le pays en Afrique que l'Afrique sera le
pays le plus touché par les migrations
d'après les prévisions on peut se
tromper mais en gros les prévisions de
la FAO que j'ai vu c'est que si on ne
fait rien si on continue le blabla sur
le climat mais si on n'agit pas tu as
beaucoup de zones d'Afrique ou les
récoltes vont être divisés par deux
alors que la population va doubler donc
il y a pas besoin d'avoir d'être un
génie pour comprendre le problème si la
récolte de céréales la récolte de
nourriture est divisée par deux alors
que la population double on va faire des
souffrances terribles et les gens auront
le choix entre crever sur place ou
essayer de bouger essayer de bouger
c'est d'abord aller dans la grande ville
proche et puis après ça c'est traverser
la Méditerranée parce que c'est le plus
proche et donc quand tu vois comment on
a du mal déjà aujourd'hui accueillir des
réfugiés de façon fraternelle si on en a
90 millions à accueillir dans 20 ans ça
va être la guerre donc la meilleure
façon c'est d'arriver à lutter vraiment
contre le dérèglement climatique d'avoir
aussi de l'argent pour les politiques
d'adaptation parce qu'on va pas stopper
le dérèglement climatique du jour
non non c'est déjà 90 millions c'est je
crois c'est les tuer de la Banque
mondiale qui dit qu'il y aura 150
millions de réfugiés climatiques je
parle de mémoire 150 millions de
réfugiés climatiques en 2050 voilà et
qui dit que l'Afrique sera le pays le
plus touché mais le but c'est pas de se
faire peur le but c'est d'agir je répète
les lobbies nous ont fait perdre 30 ans
mais ce qu'on est capable d'agir nous
l'Europe et la France en baissant le CO2
et eux aussi l'Afrique mais aussi ils
demandent de l'argent pour les
politiques d'adaptation tu dis que les
lobbies nous ont fait perdre 30 ans et
moi je suis pas d'accord avec toi c'est
que les politiques qui étaient en face
soit été mal conseillé
souhaitait mal informé
[Musique]
d'accord c'est pour ça tout à l'heure
que j'ai montré j'ai montré en même
temps comment les lobbys ont planté le
projet au niveau européen des contacts
de ville sans voiture et comment le
numéro 2 de Elf dit avec le gouvernement
français on a fait en 91 92 le 7e c'est
tout à fait documenté c'est le
commissaire européen démissionne c'était
quand même cataclysme à l'époque tu as
un commissaire européen qui au lieu
d'aller au sommet de Rio pour y aller la
planète brûle et démissionne en dedans
je n'ai pas envie de mentir les lobbies
ont tué mes deux projets je n'y vais pas
et le numéro 2 de elle dit on a fait du
bon boulot les gens c'est total c'était
avant que elle fait total fusionne les
gens étaient total étaient mieux
organisés mais on a fait du bon boulot
avec les contacts avec le ministère en
France les miliciens c'est Dominique
Strauss-Kahn donc c'est aussi pour ça
que j'ai parlé de Michel Rocard c'est
pour montrer que dans la même famille
politique tu avais des gens comme Rocard
qui ont tenu bon quand il se fait
engueuler par James Baker parce que et
Michel roccart tient bon et il fait
capoter un traité
parce qu'il refuse qu'on exploite les
ressources minières sous le Pôle Nord
mais après ça regarde chez Edith
création qui arrive et Dominique
Strauss-Kahn et c'est l'industrie de
l'industrie de l'industrie et
l'industrie au nom de l'industrie c'est
les socialistes français qui se font les
portes-parles du lobby pétrolier tu as
raison c'est pas les lobbies qui
s'étaient dans la salle de négociation
c'est Dominique Strauss-Kahn c'est
Roland Dumas et après ça on découvrira
d'ailleurs que la secrétaire de mon
compte tout ça a été documenté et c'est
d'ailleurs on découvrira quelques temps
plus tard que après la traversée du
désert en 1993 qu'en Dominique
Strauss-Kahn perd les élections sa
secrétaire sera parmi les gens qui sont
payés par Elf en Suisse voilà
la justice est sourcé tout ça est sourcé
tout ça a été il y a eu des procès
là-dessus il y a eu des t’inquiète pas
oui tout à fait sinon je me répète pas
et j'en suis triste mais c'est aussi
pour montrer que tous les politiques
sont parcours rompu Rocard et Brice
Lalande faisait le maximum pour la
planète et après ça regarde et pris sa
langue sont foutus dehors et c'est la
même famille politique mais c'est édite
création et Dominique Strauss-Kahn et
ils se font le porte-parole de
l'industrie alors que on pouvait en même
temps sauver l'industrie alors qu'on
pourrait en même temps je le répète
transformer l'industrie le projet
n'était pas de tuer l'industrie le
projet était de se donner le moyen de
transformer l'industrie et hélas les
pétroliers et les grands industriels ne
voulaient pas de cette transformation
le Parlement européen il est un peu
informé concernant la sécurité
alimentaire est-ce qu'on a des stocks de
beurre congelés quelque part est-ce que
on a des silos à grains pour notre
sécurité alimentaire s'il y a une
mauvaise récolte un réchauffement
climatique qui ou une guerre
comment ça se passe la sécurité
alimentaire parce que là là on voit
l'Ukraine qui peut plus exporter son blé
en Pologne ainsi de suite alors qu'ils
sont en guerre et que c'est compliqué
quand même avec moi parlant
les Polonais qui disent bon on veut on
veut pas que votre vos cadres
la
transit par chez eux mais que ça
intéresse pas sur le marché pour
protéger leur prix du blessé de voir que
chez nous le prix de l'alimentation
flambe et donc ça montre quand même
qu'il faut qu'on mette beaucoup de
lumière sur comment se font les prix
parce que en février là en février 2022
les derniers chiffres qu'on a c'est que
le prix la consommation d'alimentation
en France baisser de façon
menstrueuse par rapport à il y a un an
parce que les prix en flambé les prix de
la nourriture alors que le prix des
céréales baisse et que les paysans
polonais des Google
récoltes en Ukraine et que du coup ce
dont tu parles c'est qu'on Pologne en
gris les paysans disent les céréales
arrivent mais comme il y a un problème
de train il y a un problème de
logistique pour les exporter c'est au
niveau local que le prix s'effondre
voilà mais ça c'est lié à l'échelle du
Parlement européen c'est c'est un doux
rêve ça il y a des gens qui
réfléchissent ou on va se retrouver
comme avec le covid genre il y a pas de
masque il y a pas de cacheton il y a
rien du tout il y a plus de lit dans les
hôpitaux il y a plus de ça je vais
partir des gens qui se battent mais je
suis un peu honte je ne sais pas bien
répondre à ta question aujourd'hui sur
les stocks existants alors c'est une
vraie question et tout à l'heure quand
je parlais de la femme qui s'est suicidé
dans les Côtes d'Armor dans sa dans sa
salle de traite et pour moi c'est lié
aux questions européennes parce que
pendant 30 ans l'Europe a protégé le
revenu des paysans si on s'est ce qu'on
appelait les quotas laitiers commencer
depuis très longtemps on s'est depuis
très longtemps que les marchés agricoles
ont besoin d'être régulés que le
libéralisme la main visible de marché ça
ne marche pas du tout sur les marchés
agricoles et donc je ne sais pas si tu
allais au caté quand tu étais petit ou
pas mais moi je me souviens j'ai pas
séché j'étais pas très régulier mais
dans la Bible il y a l'histoire de
Pharaon qui devient le conseiller du le
l'histoire de Joseph qui devient le
conseil de pharaon était une histoire
vraie parce que c'est arrêté la
multiplication des petits pains
en gros 2000 ou 3000 ans mais c'est
juste pour dire que en matière de
politique agricole on sait depuis
l'époque des pharaons qui a besoin des
stocks me demandais est-ce qu'il y a des
stocks de céréales donc allez tout le
monde a entendu parler des années de
vache gras et de vache maigre et donc
c'est raconté dans la Bible que le
pharaon a très mal dormi il a fait un
cauchemar il ne sait pas comment
l'interpréter il a vu des grosses vaches
des vaches très bien nourris très très
jolie qui sortait du Nil et après ça il
a vu des vaches toutes maigres qui
crevaient de faim il ne sait pas comment
l'interpréter il en parle autour de lui
et il y a certains Joseph qui explique
que en fait ça veut dire que le pharaon
doit réguler les marchés agricoles parce
que s'il y a une année où il y a des
très très bon récolte le prix des
céréales va s'effondrer et les paysans
seront ruinés et que par contre après ça
s'il y a des années avec des mauvaises
récoltes le prix des céréales va flamber
et le peuple ne pourra plus manger il y
aura des famines et donc Joseph qu'on va
pharaon qu'il faut stocker que le rôle
de l'État c'est de réguler et les années
où il y a des très très bonnes récoltes
on va remplir les greniers et comme ça
on fait des stocks et le prix ne
s'effondre pas et donc les paysans
peuvent vivre correctement et puis deux
ans plus tard quatre ans plus tard s'il
y a une mauvaise récolte il y aura pas
de famine parce qu'on va déstocker on va
vider les greniers et le peuple pourra
manger parce que les prix vont rester
corrects donc déjà il y a 3000 ans on
savait qu'il fallait réguler moins de
1000 euros c'est Pierre Mendès France
comme Pierre Mendès France était
président du conseil il allait voir des
paysans avec des petits graphiques une
fois la femme de Mendès France m'a dit
mais lui aussi il avait des pieds
graphiques en expliquant quand le prix
du lait diminue chaque paysan
spontanément veut faire encore plus de
lait pour le reste à famille mais si on
fait encore plus de lait le prix du lait
va s'effondrer et donc dans les années
90 il y avait eu des quotas laitiers qui
avaient été mis en place par Michel
Rocard malgré les anglais en disant au
lieu de laisser les marchés et avec des
crises sur le prix du lait à chaque fois
il y a des paysans qui se suicident on
va faire ce qu'on appelait les quotas
laitiers on va juste se mettre autour de
la table et voir chaque année le volume
de lait le volume de beurre de poudre de
lait combien on a besoin pour la
consommation des jambes pour le pour les
pâtissiers qui ont besoin de beurre on
se répartit le volume de l'hédon a
besoin et ce qu'on appelle les quotas
chaque paysan a un certain volume de
production et pendant 30 ans pendant 30
ans les paysans vivaient correctement le
prix du lait était correct il n'y avait
pas besoin de subvention le but d'un
paysan n'est pas d'avoir de subventions
de Bruxelles le but d'un paysan est de
faire un métier qu'il aime sur une un
territoire qu'il aime et de vivre de son
travail donc pendant 30 ans quand il y
avait ces quotas laitiers sauf dans les
zones de montagne mais sinon il y avait
pas un euro ou un franc de subvention et
les gens vivaient correctement et le
prix du lait était stable et puis un
certain Bruno Le Maire arrivent pour une
donc c'est pas l'Europe ce sont des
hommes et des femmes qui portent des
idées libérales en 2005 Bruno Le Maire
et d'autres explique que ces histoires
de quota laitiers c'est stupide qu'on va
supprimer les quotas certains disent le
ministre si on fait ça les prix vont
s'effondrer il y aura de l'instabilité
c'est pas pour rien si on a mis en place
les quotas les pieds il y a 30 ans et
Bruno Le Maire explique que faut pas
s'inquiéter les prix du lait vont
s'effondrer mais on pourra produire plus
et exporter vers la Chine voilà donc
certains vous disent que c'est l'Europe
le Front national ou d'autres disent que
c'est l'Europe qui protège qui ne
protège pas le revenu des paysans mais
il n'y a pas de fatalité pendant 30 ans
l'Europe a protégé le revenu des paysans
et c'est des libéraux dans les années
2005 2007 qui ont foutu en l'air les
soutien de régulation mais et donc moi
je me bats avec beaucoup d'autres
députés pour qu'on change la politique
agricole et qu'on a une politique
agricole qui protège le revenu des
paysans et qui les aident à se
transformer pour protéger les sols pour
protéger les ressources en eau pour
protéger la planète
ce que veut dire c'est que l'Europe
c'est pas une idée éthérée il y a pas
une seule Europe il y a une Europe qui
est pendant 30 ans à protéger le revenu
des gens et une Europe ou pendant 30 ans
et nous on se bat on a obtenu qui a un
salaire minimum donc il y a des visions
différentes on peut dire qu'on ait très
nombreux à penser qu'il faut une Europe
que si on est juste des petits pays on a
plus aucune souveraineté mais dans le
même projet européen il y en a il y a
une courbe que j'ai pas encore montré
que j'aimerais montrer c'est le dumping
fiscal européen il y a des pays qui
continuent voilà
illustriellement quand j'étais petit
l'impôt sur les sociétés était à 50% non
mais c'est très très concret là on a
besoin pour les hôpitaux pour je m'en
fous moi de la fiscalité quand j'étais
assurance pour je m'en foutais parce que
pour moi la fiscalité c'était théorique
mais aujourd'hui je comprends que
l'hôpital s'effondre je comprends qu'il
y a des juges qui n'en peuvent plus qui
sont burn out parce qu'il y a pas assez
de moyens pour la justice qui a des
policiers qui n'en peuvent plus voilà
donc il y a besoin de sous donc la
fiscalité c'est pas un sujet théorique
donc quand j'étais petit l'impôt sur les
sociétés tu es à 50% en moyenne en
Europe et puis les Anglais les libéraux
l'ont obtenu qu'on le diminue qu'on le
diminue on est tombé à 19%, 19%. alors
que aux États-Unis je suis qui s'appelle
nouvelle donne c'est une référence au
New Deal de Roosevelt quand Roosevelt
arrive au pouvoir il y avait le même
problème le texte à se baisser son impôt
puis la Floride baissait son impôts et
les entreprises faisaient du tourisme
fiscal et Roosevelt dit on peut pas
continuer comme ça il fait un impôts
fédéral en disant que vous soyez au
Texas soit en Floride vous paierez ceux
qui font des bénéfices vous paierez
l'impôt les entreprises gueulent en
disant que Roosevelt est un communiste
mais Roosevelt un impôt fédéral et donc
aux États-Unis jusqu'à l'arrivée de
Trump l'impôt sur les sociétés n'était
jamais tombées en tout de 38%. donc
c'est quand même le monde à l'envers de
se dire que nous l'Europe on est tombé à
19% en moyenne l'impôt sur les sociétés
donc les États-Unis étaient à 38 donc je
fais partie des gens qui se battent pour
dire on comprend que les actionnaires
aient besoin d'un retour sur
investissement
de certaines boîtes pour faire tourner
leur trésorerie il faut aussi pour
éviter pour éviter de payer l'impôt sur
les sociétés il faut poser le délire oui
oui pardon effectivement
encore une fois pardon
de petits millionnaire ils connaissent
ils connaissent bien le levier pour
éviter l'impôt sur les sociétés parce
que quand tu payes 19% sur ta sur
l'impôt sur les sociétés c'est parce que
tu veux bien il y a tous les outils pour
faire tourner ta réseau non si c'est
complètement d'accord et en France
depuis Sarkozy on a supprimé des
milliers d'emplois chez ceux qui sont
chargés de lutter contre l'évasion
fiscale donc on pourrait y passer la
soirée parce que en même temps c'est
très mauvais signe si le taux moyen
impose sur les sociétés diminue mais en
plus tu as des entreprises qui ne payent
même pas ce taux de 19%, je suis
complètement d'accord juste c'est
l'occasion de faire un petit zoom là
dessus sur
donc là on vient de parler un peu la
sécurité alimentaire que l'Europe est-ce
qu'on continue de se dumping où est-ce
qu'on est capable au contraire se dire
qu'on fait un impôt européen sur les
bénéfices non pas les petits entreprises
mais que les entreprises est-ce que on
continue la concurrence fiscale et en
est tombé à 19% et on va continuer ou
être on est capable au niveau européen
de mettre en place un impôt sur les
bénéfices qui donneraient plus d'argent
pour les services publics pour le climat
pour la justice sociale voilà donc il y
a deux visions de l'Europe qui vont y
compris dans un an il y a des élections
européennes et Thomas vous dire l'Europe
l'Europe l'Europe mais on n'a pas la
même vision avec les libéraux Bruno Le
Maire Macron vont dire l'Europe l'Europe
mais pour une le maire fait partie des
gens qui ont foutu en l'air les outils
de régulation qui protégeaient le revenu
des paysans
donc on va parler de la sécurité
alimentaire on l'a effleuré la sécurité
je vais dire médicale comment ça se
passe est-ce que l'Europe est consciente
que bah on peut avoir des pénuries de
doliprane de des tensions sur les
pilules avorties pour dire pas pénurie
on dit des tensions
il y a d'autres tensions sur les sondes
pour faire des biopsites prostate ou des
choses comme ça comment ça se passe
parce que là on a on a l'impression
quand même qu'on découvre des problèmes
mais pardon
un mélange de naïveté de cynisme c'est
aussi pour ça que c'est scandaleux de
voir comment ce qu'on appelle les portes
tournantes quelqu'un qui était à la
Commission européenne et qui va après ça
monsieur Barroso qui était Président de
la Commission et puis après ça va chez
Goldman Sachs
vraiment fait le maximum pour lutter
contre l'évasion fiscale et pour réguler
les banques je crois que je crois que
oui mais que le délai est beaucoup trop
court au niveau du Parlement européen je
demande à être vérifié pour la
communauté que il faut attendre au
minimum 6 mois c'est beaucoup trop court
c'est ridicule c'est scandaleux si moi
c'est ridicule c'est juste dire tu as eu
un boulot épuisant tu es tu seras très
bien payé tu prends 6 mois de vacances
c'est juste honteux et encore hier dans
on a vu dans l'industrie du tabac des
gens que la médiatrice donc c'est pas
des rumeurs c'est très fac la médiatrice
dit qu'il y avait 100 sujets de gens qui
voulaient partir dans des entreprises
liées à l'industrie du tabac il y en a
que deux qui ont été refusés voilà et
donc la médiatrice dit est-ce que on
peut faire respecter beaucoup mieux les
règles pour interdire ou limiter le
pantouflage parce qu'effectivement
constituer un ou une responsable de la
Commission européenne Charlie je
rappelle quand même que le tabac fait
750 000 morts chaque année en Europe
750000 morts
ça peut être des mois de souffrance
voilà et c'est sur le système de santé
qui pèse accessoirement en plus de la
sur le système de santé mais moi mon
beau-père est mort d'un cancer du poumon
il a j'ai un copain qui ne fume pas qui
est en train de se battre contre un
cancer du poumon parce qu'il y a tout
fait le charbon il y a tout fait celle
qui fume non mais après ça il y a pas
que le tabac il y a aussi la pollution
des voitures il y a aussi les particules
fines voilà mais c'est juste pour dire
que quand on parle des lobbies c'est pas
un problème théorique chaque année en
Europe il y a 750 000 personnes qui
meurent du tabac et on se rend compte
j'étais scotché j'étais vraiment déçu
quand j'ai appris ça cette semaine
comment la médiatrice dit on ne respecte
pas les règles de base il y a des gens
de la Commission ont des réunions avec
des gens de l'industrie du tabac et ne
le manque mettre pas dans le registre de
on devrait déclarer ce genre de
rencontre et après ça il y a des gens
qui vont pas touffer donc pantoufler ça
veut dire que pendant quelques années
pendant 5 ans 6 ans 7 ans 8 ans tu es du
côté de je devrais faire les règles qui
devraient faire des règles très très
sévères et puis au bout d'un moment tu
vas tu prends 6 mois de repos et puis tu
vas et tu es très très bien payé dans
une entreprise qui est liée aux
industries du tabac et du coup on se
demande
industries il y a pas que l'industrie
tu sais comment les contourner et puis
tu peux te demander si pendant 7 ans
quand tu étais en poste à la commission
est-ce que tu as fait le maximum pour
protéger la santé et pour limiter les
ventes de tabac et on a un petit doute
si tu vas être six mois après avoir
quitté la commission ou un an ou deux
ans tu vas être très très bien payé dans
une boîte Clio tabac de même et pas dans
on revient total mais celui qui
m'appelle le conseiller de Monsieur
pouyanet c'est l'ancien conseiller de
Jean-Yves Le Drian voilà c'est très
quand on écrit avec Jean Josel il y a un
an avec le mon copain qui est le grand
climatologue on écrit à Monsieur
pouyanet pour dire qu'on serait content
de le rencontrer dès le lendemain j'ai
un coup de fil c'est celui qui s'occupe
des relations politiques et des
relations intitulaires de Monsieur
pouyanet et on avait nos téléphones de
l'époque il était au cabinet de
Jean-Yves Le Drian c'est bien de bien
conseiller oui mais du coup tu te
demandes est-ce que pendant qu'il était
le conseiller politique de Le Drian qui
s'occupait en particulier de des
relations de la France et l'Afrique mais
non mais c'est juste que ce mélange des
genres il faut trouver le bon équilibre
c'est bien d'avoir des compétences moi
j'ai été pendant 11 ans
économie française quand même mais moi
il y a 30 ans il y a 30 ans
il y a 30 ans on peut être fier de Total
moi dans mon coin des Pyrénées il y
avait elfe il y avait du gaz à lac quand
j'étais petit quand j'ai mon grand oncle
paysan on voyait les flammes qui sortent
il y a 50 ans j'étais petit à 50 ans on
voyait les flammes voilà il y a 50 ans
on peut être fier de Total mais
aujourd'hui je le répète il s'agit pas
de couper la tête ou de désigner les
gens personnellement mais collectivement
une entreprise qui sait depuis 1971 qui
a un problème avec le CO2 une entreprise
quand monsieur pouillané devant des
étudiants à Sciences Po dit notre
scénario je ne sais pas surval publier
c'est réchauffement de plus trois ou
plus 3,5 degrés ce monsieur a tout à
fait conscience qu'on va vers la
catastrophe
il est pas stupide il a fait des études
d'ingénieur à Polytechnique il est pas
stupide il a rencontré des climatologues
il sait que par sa pratique ok il a 20
milliards il augmente les dividendes ces
Stockholm il sera riche jusqu'à la fin
de sa vie il sera pas quoi faire de son
fric c'était un rapport à l'argent qui
est un peu bizarre mais il sait il le
dit lui-même notre scénario c'est plus
trois ou plus 3,5 degrés c'est un truc
climatique
c'est normal qu'il parle pas non oui le
fait qu'il parle voilà pardon mais le
fait c'est juste il y a l'hypocrisie
qu'en 100% de la commission ils ont
changé le nom comme ils sont constipé
politique c'est Pierre arrête de dire
total mais non on s'appelle total
l'énergie on se transforme on va vers
les renouvelables ok mais aujourd'hui là
en 2020 mais ils ont droit de changer
non mais ça c'est très bien mais mon
problème c'est qu'il ne change pas la
réalité
leurs investissements aujourd'hui ils
continuent à investir massivement il
continue à investir massivement dans le
pétrole et le gaz beaucoup plus que ce
qui est nécessaire et je répète que le
premier février tu trouves que selon des
organismes comment tu dis ça
internationale de l'énergie qui a deux
ans c'est pas moi et quelques
climatologues non mais c'est si j'ai une
question un peu un peu taquin pour toi
si tu devais choisir entre le nucléaire
et le charbon c'est pas très compliqué
le charbon tue des dizaines de milliers
de gens parlaient parce qu'on respire
par les gens qui crèvent on n'a pas de
mine de charbon en France mais il y a
des coups de Griso il y a aucun doute
que le charbon est beaucoup plus
dangereux pour le dérèglement climatique
et pour les gens qui les hommes et les
femmes qui meurent dans les coups de
grises donc le charbon il faudrait
fermer immédiatement toutes les
centrales à charbon le plus vite
possible il y a aucun doute est-ce qu'il
faudrait interdire à l'Allemagne de
taper dans son charbon à gogo là je
comprends pas très bien je sais qu'en
Allemagne je pense que le nucléaire
n'est pas en France c'est pénible parce
que c'est toi le nucléaire est génial
soit le nucléaire est la catastrophe des
catastrophes et ce serait bien qu'on
arrive à avoir un dialogue un peu plus
équilibré sur le nucléaire je pense par
exemple que je vais peut-être choquer
des amis que le nucléaire en France est
moins dangereux qu'au Japon on a une
autorité de sûreté en France qui est
beaucoup plus sérieuse qui est beaucoup
plus autonome et qui impose à EDF on n'a
qu'à on a vu l'an dernier toutes les
génération que l'Autorité de sûreté a
dit il y a des problèmes de corrosion
donc vous arrêtez vos centrales au Japon
l'accident catastrophique a lieu au
Japon on me dit qu'en France il ne
pouvait pas avoir lieu parce qu'il y a
des choses pour limiter la surpression
et que l'Autorité de sûreté au Japon est
marquée c'est pas du tout indépendantes
elle est maquée avec les producteurs
d'énergie nucléaires voilà donc je pense
qu'il faut pas noircir le tableau la
situation est assez compliquée pour
essayer de ne pas mentir et je crois que
le nucléaire en France est moins
dangereux qu'au Japon parce que on a
cette autorité d'ailleurs il y a deux
autorités vous avez vu que Macron boulet
d'en faire qu'une et qui est une
résistance et que les députés ont voté
contre la vie de Macron pour garder ces
deux autorités qui font un équilibre
pour contrôler le nucléaires donc je
pense que le nucléaire chez nous est
moins dangereux mais qu'il est quand
même de plus en plus cher et que tous
ceux qui pensent que youplaboul le
nucléaire est toute la solution quand on
voit le coup d'un EPR qu'on va le retard
que soit le père qui était mis en place
enfin Landes ou le père qui est il y a
eu 12 ans de retard quand même quand
nous explique que le père le nucléaire
va être la solution je suis désolé mais
j'ai rien contre mon papa a fait tout sa
carrière EDF et papa était en plus de
celle-ci garçons il était le papa de
Golfech et de Cattenom donc il y a deux
centrales nucléaires qui sont clairement
papa était chef de projet donc je suis
pas un anti-nucléaire forçonné mais je
vois qu'aujourd'hui le prix du nucléaire
est de plus en plus élevé et qu'on ne
sait pas quoi faire des déchets et je
vois un autre problème pour ceux qui
nous disent que le nucléaire le projet
les réacteurs rapides ok je ne sais pas
en tout cas aujourd'hui dans l'état
actuel de on ne sait pas et dernier
point le nucléaire n'est pas du tout une
solution généralisable je le redis le
nucléaire en France parce que la plupart
échelle mondiale oui c'est ça l'échelle
mondiale quand les pays du Sud de
certaines nous disent on est d'accord
pour avoir du nucléaire et bien il y a
un silence gêné parce qu'on ne sait pas
s'ils auront une autorité parlons
franchement est-ce qu'on a envie que
l'ensemble des pays de la planète en
gros certains disent en France pas
besoin de politique de sobriété on fait
quasiment rien sur la rénovation
thermique encore le gouvernement quand
il a fait passer le 49-3 il y a il y a
quelques mois alors que des députés de
sa majorité voulait mettre plus d'argent
sur la rénovation thermique et pour les
transports en commun au moment du 49-3
Macron et borne disent non on ne met pas
d'argent sur la rénovation thermique on
ne met pas d'argent sur les transports
en commun voilà donc le nucléaire va
sauver le monde Emmanuel Macron nous
annonce qu'il va en faire entre 6 ou
14pr on sait pas qui en a débattu mais
il y a une décision du roi on va faire
le Pr quel est le coût quel est le
calendrier qu'est-ce qu'on fait des
déchets et après ça est-ce qu'on prétend
que c'est une solution généralisable en
gros nous on n'a pas besoin de faire de
politique d'efficacité d'une sobriété on
fait croire que chacun aura sa grosse
voiture électrique et qu'on aura une
électricité verte avec le nucléaire
c'est le mythe qu'on entretient mais
est-ce qu'on pense que c'est
généralisable l'ensemble des pays de la
planète est-ce qu'on pense que chaque
pays aura ces trois ou quatre centrales
nucléaires avec quelle autorité de
sûreté pour vérifier qu'il y a pas
d'explosion
quelles ressources et comment vérifier
qu'il n'y a pas des bombes salles et
donc on en parle franchement
non on n'a pas envie que tous les pays
et du nucléaire parce qu'on n'a pas
envie qu'il y a des bombes salles et
qu'il y a des petites explosions partout
donc si ce qu'on propose pour la France
nous coûte très très cher
vais tourner le combusti pour faire des
saloperies
personne ne propose de même que personne
ne propose de sortir du pétrole dans
trois ans je crois que la personne qui
propose sortir du pétrole en trois ans
personne ne propose de sortir du
nucléaire dans 5 ans donc on a un parc
il faut l'entretenir il faut peut-être
moins de voir comment on peut le
prolonger mais oui bon sang qu'en 2007
il y avait un accord sur le Grenelle
pour dire qu'on fait 400000 frères
rénovations chaque année est-ce qu'on se
donne les moyens et la flambée du prix
d'énergie qu'on a en ce moment devrait
être l'occasion de mettre encore plus
d'argent c'est pour ça que j'avais rien
contre Macron il y a 6 ans moi quand il
est arrivé j'avais vraiment pas fait sa
campagne j'avais refusé d'être député
dans sa majorité mais je pensais que sur
le climat et sur l'Europe il allait
faire des choses il a aussi vous
retrouver les images du One Planet
sommet en 2017 Emmanuel Macron fait le
One Planet sommet et devant 80 chefs
d'État et 3000 personnes il dit on est
en train de perdre la bataille on le
sait il dit autrefois les dirigeants il
y a 30 ans avaient de la chance ils
avaient une excuse il ne savait pas nous
n'avons aucune Assieu nous savons je lui
envoie un message dans un bravo pour ton
discours ça change du blabla [__] oui
voilà quelques mois plus tard il crée le
Haut Conseil pour le climat et il me
fait il me fait venir je suis à des neuf
sages du Haut Conseil devant tout le
monde il me tutoie même Bruno Le Maire
me tutoie c'était une journée redoutable
et donc il m'a expliqué Emmanuel Macron
qui veut se au conseil pour le climat
pour aiguillonner le gouvernement parce
qu'il veut que le gouvernement fasse le
maximum sur le climat puis à la
Convention citoyenne pour le climat il y
a 150 citoyens qui travaillent
travaillent pour faire et il a promis
qu'il aurait peut-être trois jokers mais
qu'à part ces trois jokers il allait
reprendre toutes les propositions de la
convention citoyenne pour le climat et
en fait il en a repris 10% et même le
Conseil d'État donne des sanctions
gouvernement dont vous faites pas ce
qu'il faut donc c'est vraiment scandale
il y a pas je ne comprends pas
pourquoi il a repris que dit mais non
c'est pas vol pardon excuse-moi il n'est
pas volontaire quand je moi je suis un
mec un peu basique un peu berner un peu
concret quand sa majorité dit on va
mettre quelques milliards de plus sur la
rénovation thermique et on va mettre
quelques milliards de plus sur la sur
les transports en commun quand tous les
présidents de région même Laurent
Wauquiez tout le patron de la SNCF a
raison il faut mettre 100 milliards et
que donc il y a des députés de la
majorité d'Emmanuel Macron qui ont voté
des amendements en disant on met de
l'argent sur la rénovation thermique on
met de l'argent sur les transports en
commun et bien au moment du 49-3
Elizabeth borne on peut penser que
Emmanuel Macron a donné quelques
consignes dit non non mais attends me
fait pas croire que tu penses que Madame
borne décide tout seul de voilà
peut-être que oui on s'en fiche en tout
cas ce gouvernement en tout cas ce
gouvernement a décidé de couper au
moment du 49-3 a décidé de supprimer les
amendements votés par sa majorité pour
mettre de l'argent sur la rénovation
thermique et les transports en commun
donc on ne me dise pas que le climat et
leur priorité tu pues de beaucoup ce
soir mon petit Pierre c'est la fatigue
c'est pas une excuse
si un jour total t'appelle en disant
voilà ok pierre on sait que tu as on
sait que tu bosses taquet depuis des
années on a besoin d'être conseillé on a
besoin des challenger on t’engage
c'est voilà et il y a un moment on m'a
dit écoute tu as tout ce qu'il faut pour
devenir un des patrons du cabinet au
niveau mondial mais tu dois t'engager
par écrit à ne plus parler de la semaine
de quatre jours tu as jusque là les
patrons du cabinet au niveau français me
protégeait je veux dire qu'ils étaient
assez cool ils étaient contents d'avoir
un consultant qui fait dans le social il
y en a qui m'a dit tu sais on nous dit
que chaque sondieu il y en a 6 ans qui
supprime des emplois on est content de
dire qu'il y en a un qui crée des
emplois donc tant que j'étais au niveau
français les patrons du cabinet me
protégeaient mais ils m'ont dit si tu
veux être un des patrons au niveau
mondial tu as tout ce qu'il faut pour
être un des chefs au niveau du bord
mondial tu dois t'engager par écrit à ne
plus parler du temps de travail et j'y
réfléchi je me suis dit que en
conscience mon but n'était pas d'être
milliardaire ou millionnaire et donc
j'étais licencié oui enfin oui enfin
j'ai eu la lettre de licenciement pour
des accords c'est pour te dire que tu
dois t'engager par écrit tu as des
problèmes
ici je parlais pas non mais c'est comme
tu me parles est-ce que Total veut
m'embaucher voilà j'ai plein de défauts
je parle trop vite je suis
difficile je suis difficile à corrompre
je sais pas s'ils veulent faire un truc
je te parle d'être de conseiller et que
je sais pas si demande à des jeux de
même quand Emmanuel Macron me fait
rentrer au conseil pour le climat j'y
vais en pensant que le conseil pour le
climat va être utile et aujourd'hui il y
a beaucoup de gens je juge pas du tout
les gens qui sont au Conseil qui font le
maximum mais il y a beaucoup de gens qui
se demandent si effectivement Emmanuel
Macron a envie d'avoir une instance qui
le pousse à aller plus loin
je vais te poser une question on a fait
une blague sur la multitude du moins
j'ai fait une blague sur la
multiplication des petits pains je me
suis arrêté là non moi je me suis pas
arrêté là avant qui était schisme
t'as pas l'impression que l'Union
européenne la Banque centrale européenne
la banque centrale américaine il faut un
petit peu la multiplication des petits
pains là avec la monnaie depuis très
longtemps genre ça relève de la magie
pratiquement et
ça crée quand même de l'inflation un
jour ou l'autre de la multiplication
de liquidité autrefois qu'on était pied
on appelait ça la planche à billets
parce que c'était physiquement des
planches y compris en France était à
Clermont-Ferrand je crois qu'on faisait
les billets maintenant c'est
effectivement qu'il y a eu quand il y a
eu la crise financière on a mis 1000
milliards en quelques jours pour sauver
les banques européennes tu te souviens
et y compris des gens du ministère des
Finances on fait trois nuits blanches
pour régler tous les problèmes
juridiques parce qu'en principe l'argent
de la banque centrale ne doit pas aller
dans la Société Générale et donc en
trois jours ils ont inventé les
structures pour pour tout régler donc
c'était qu'on a lancé notre initiative
avec Jean Josette c'est un autre
argument en disant pour sauver les
banques en 2008 ou en 2007 on a mis 1000
milliards milliards pour sauver le
climat et certains nous aimons c'est pas
possible la BCE il a fait une fois parce
qu'il y avait une situation dramatique
jamais il recommencerons et puis en 2014
en novembre 2014 c'est ma mémoire est
bonne Mario Draghi c'était la une de
tous les journaux dans le petit bouquin
qu'on a fait avec les photocopies on a
Mario Draghi qui annonce qui va mettre
1000 milliards sur la table pour sauver
la croissance voilà donc il va faire
tous les mois 70 milliards pour nourrir
l'économie et certains pensaient que les
Allemands se furieux mais comme
l'Allemagne était en train de retomber
en récession en 2014 l'Allemagne accepte
donc il y avait 1000 milliards en 2008
et puis là c'est de la création
monétaire du quantitative easing on met
des mots chic et on met des mots
compliqués pour que les gens se disent
[__] j'y comprends rien quand il est
attiles vaut mieux pas que je m'en mêle
ça a l'air compliqué si je m'en mêle je
veux voir les radios donc tout est fait
tout est fait pour que les citoyens
normaux se disent sur que tu appelles ça
planche à billets tout de suite ça fait
moins manquer mais honnêtement je pense
qu'il y a la volonté se dire que si les
gens savaient qu'il y a autant de
centaines c'est pas du tout du
complotisme mais y compris une fois on a
fait un débat du journal Le Soir à
Bruxelles une très belle salle de 800
personnes et il y avait la luminosité
finance Jean-Luc cruck qui dit j'ai lu
le livre de Pierre larouture en une nuit
René l'étranger parce que il voyait que
ses enfants ou les voisins allaient dans
les manifs pour le climat donc c'est les
jeunes c'est les jeunes Adélaïde Hanouna
tous les jeunes qui étaient dans la rue
pour le climat qui font que ce ministre
se dit faut quand même que je
réfléchisse à la question du climat et
que quelqu'un doit être conseiller le
petit bouquin qu'on avait fait avec Jean
Jaurès et donc il dit j'ai lu ce bouquin
en une nuit et je pensais que tous les
chiffres étaient faux parce que je vous
allez la route jusqu'à eu des centaines
de milliards de crédits donc même le
ministre des Finances pensaient et puis
dit j'ai donné à mes services le bouquin
ils m'ont dit mais non c'est tout à fait
vrai donc au total quand Mario dragué
dit qu'il va créer 1000 milliards il a
créé 2400 2400 milliards et simplement
il y en a seulement 11% qui sont allés
dans l'économie réelle et presque 90%
qu'ils ont allé sur les marchés
financiers c'est une raison voilà et
donc nous ce qu'on dit avec Jean-Joseph
et beaucoup d'autres c'est que l'argent
de la banque centrale au lieu d'aller
n'importe où et essentiellement au
marché financier parce que c'est très
rentable si tu fais du + 20 % par an
faire la rénovation thermique c'est très
bon pour le climat mais tu vas te
rapporter peut-être du 2% par an par
contre aller sur les marchés financiers
ça te fait plus du 20% bon si tu dis aux
banques tenez je vous donne ça je vous
fais confiance évidemment on va sur les
marchés financiers jusqu'à la prochaine
crise financière qui peut être dans un
mois ou dans deux ans et qui peut être
plus grave que 2008 donc cet été ça
risque d'être compliqué mais écoute là
je vais pas trop lent mais il y a une
fois tu m'avais invité où j'allais
sortir mes graphiques sur le niveau de
la dette il y a des journaux qui disent
que j'étais un des cinq économiste qui
avait annoncé la première crise
financière parce que j'avais fait une
conférence de presse en 2005 et
Dominique Strauss-Kahn déjà se foutait
de ma gueule en expliquant une fois que
j'en ai d'été du PS j'avais montré
devant 400 personnes en août 2005 la
dette totale aux États-Unis qui montait
comme ça et le taux d'épargne qui est
devenu négatif et donc j'avais expliqué
on va vers une crise financière majeure
et la gauche devrait l'expliquer que le
capitalisme nous amène à la catastrophe
et prendre la gauche les socialistes
devraient proposer des mesures pour nous
protéger et Dominique schwarzkahn
c'était foutu de ma gueule la route
rouge s'inquiète pour rien il y a aucun
risque de crise aux États-Unis et DJ moi
plus tard tu
[Rires]
coup c'est des pansements sur des jambes
de bois oui on est en plein l'image
qu'on veut mais on n'a rien réglé et de
nouveau les marchés financiers sont d'un
niveau jamais vu et même avant le
covid-19 on avait des niveaux de dettes
voilà et là j'aimerais me tromper mais
de même que la crise de 1929 la grande
crise financière c'était la deuxième
crise il y avait une première crise
financière en 1920 21 on a émis quelques
rustines et puis on avait recommencé à
bourser côté comme des cochons et qu'on
a deuxième crise éclate elle provoque
une catastrophe sociale et en Europe
elle arrive elle est les nazis arrivent
au pouvoir il y a eu la guerre et il y a
eu la guerre et par contre aux
États-Unis ce qui a fait Roosevelt je
répète une partie de nouvelles donne qui
en référence au New Deal quand Roosevelt
arrive il fait passer 15 réformes les
banquiers sont furieux les les
actionnaires sont furieux mais Roosevelt
fait la séparation des banques Roosevelt
fait un impôt fédéral pour avoir de
l'argent pour aider les paysans pour
créer des emplois alors qu'il est
paralysé lui-même il n'arrive pas à
bouger à se mettre debout tout seul ni
fait remet le pays en mouvement il fait
passer 15 réformes en trois mois c'est
impressionnant de voir que Roosevelt est
juste une question est-ce que tu as
l'air de très bien cette Roosevelt c'est
pas lui qui a engagé un Kennedy pour
faire de la régulation bancaire ou de
régulation des marchés financiers
peut-être qu'il a embauché quelqu'un qui
s'y connaissait mais pour la régulation
un banquier qui comprend le fait qu'il y
a besoin de régulation je suis pas pour
tuer les banquiers mais ils ont fait la
séparation des banques et du coup tout à
fait le glacis Gold et pendant 60 ans ça
a tenu bon et les banques où on met
notre argent ne pouvait pas spéculer sur
les marchés financiers avec l'argent de
chez madame tout le monde et du coup ce
devait se tourner vers les PME vers le
logement vers l'investissement
utile pour le bien commun c'est
difficile de te faire perdre ton fil
j'essaie de faire passer du Quick à
l'âne depuis
je t'ai fait une blague sur le
renseignement économique dans les bars
du parle en face du parlement européen
est-ce que les parlementaires européens
reçoivent une formation pour éviter de
se faire tamponner par des services
extérieurs pour éviter de discuter un
peu n'importe comment dans les taxis
discuter un peu n'importe comment quand
je dis discuter un peu l'implant
c'est-à-dire
potentiellement écoutable
dans les taxes sinon dans les bars
olé olé ou s'ils sont approchés par des
petites hirondelles est-ce qu'ils
reçoivent non attends ce type de
formation et est-ce que ils sont
contrôlés pour des questions à ce qu'ils
sont alcooliques dépendants
au jeu parce que quand tu as des quant à
des lois à passer très importantes que
tu peux avoir des pressions extérieures
parce que bon bah tu comprends ce que je
veux dire est-ce que vous recevez
d'entraînement ou vous toi tu débarques
de tomber un alors je sais que le Béarn
quand même le climat est rude donc ça
fait ça fait quoi ça forge
des souvenirs sont c'est le pays de gens
la salle en plus oui ça forme sa forme
du costaud c'est un mélange de base que
de Béarnais de breton
du climat on s'est dit qu'il faudrait
former les députés sur les questions de
climat sur l'urgence climatique mais
pendant mais c'est pas le seul sujet
pendant que tu peux lever mais je pense
qu'il y a besoin les gens qui ont fait
la fresque du climat c'est 2h ou 3h ils
en sortent en comprenant mieux l'urgence
maintenant mais je pense que lutter
contre la corruption tu postes vrais
questions et écoute la corruption lutter
contre le renseignement extérieur lutter
contre les influences est-ce que vous
avez reçu un truc non je pense qu'on a
une un document qui est disponible
quelque part mais que peu de gens l'ont
lu ah il y a un document je n'en sais
rien j'imagine qu'il y a des gens
intelligents qui ont dû nous préparer
là-dessus et je pense que non non mais
pendant on pensait qu'il y avait des
gens intelligents puis on a eu des
affiches à 4 dans les années dans les
dans les aéroports internationaux oui
oui non mais encore une fois je prétends
pas savoir ce Parlement est une grande
maison j'y suis depuis 4 ans mais c'est
seulement 4 ans je prétends pas je
découvre encore des choses est-ce que ça
recommence à est-ce que ça commence à
ressembler à la grande maison du Parti
communiste de l'ex Union de l'ex-Union
soviétique genre avec une administration
ultra lourde des fonctionnaires partout
non il y a une lourdeur c'est en même
temps un côté vraiment passionnant du
Parlement européen en même temps une des
limites c'est le fait que tu dois en
permanence dialoguer avec d'autres
groupes tu vois en France jusqu'à il y a
un an il y avait à l'Assemblée nationale
un groupe qui avait la majorité et tout
le monde obéissait au chef on était dans
le système pyramidal et en gros en
France depuis le début de la cinquième
République le groupe majoritaire à
l'assemblée fait voter tout ce qui veut
au Parlement européen il y a aucun
groupe qui a la majorité tu dois au
moins avoir trois groupes quand tu
négocies le budget tu dois aller voir
les uns les autres les unes et les
autres écouter les gens de la commission
agriculture et la commission emploi la
commission droit des femmes mais aussi
des gens de tous les passements de ta
famille politique de tout le monde parce
que si tu as juste ton groupe je suis un
groupe la démocrate on est le deuxième
groupe on est 143 ou 144 députés mais si
on n'a pas aussi le groupe de la droite
classique et à notre groupe on ne pourra
pas voter faire voter nos textes donc on
doit dialoguer en permanence avec les
autres et donc ça on la prend qu'on
arrive au Parlement ça c'est vraiment
intéressant et en même temps c'est une
des lourdeurs quand tu demandais à ce
que c'est pas une maison trop lourde il
y a une lenteur qui vient du fait que il
faut négocier avec ces autres groupes et
puis surtout le fait que le Parlement
n'est pas le lieu du pouvoir le plus
important que ceux et celles qui gardent
le plus de pouvoir ce sont les chefs
d'État le Parlement celui-là il a quand
même vachement de pouvoir je trouve le
vendeur la commission un pouvoir
d'initiative mais il y a des domaines où
on est co-responsable par Le Mans et les
chefs d'État
négocie des contrats pour l'Union
européenne je comprends pas bien là
alors en période de crise la Commission
a eu plus de pouvoir mais sinon en temps
normal en supposant qu'on est dans des
temps normaux ceux qui ont le pouvoir
d'apparition la réponse aux Américains
qui ont mis 360 milliards de subventions
au mois d'août dernier et bien c'est le
conseil le Parlement fait des
propositions
la commission madame andalaya a fait des
propositions mais ceux et celles qui
peuvent décider ce sont les 27 chefs
d'État et donc c'est aussi pour ça qu'il
faudrait de même qu'il faut en France
changer complètement nos institutions on
va en crever le niveau de violence qu'on
a en ce moment en France moi qui faut
absolument aller 26e République plus
social et plus démocratique mais aussi
au niveau européen ce système
institutionnel est très très lourd très
lent et laisse la place au lobby
ça pose un problème ou pas
je ne sais pas
tu parles de dialogue
on a vu Hugo Clémence se faire
rabrouiller parce qu'il a été tchatche
chez valeur actuelle qui a été un média
vilipendé parce qu'ils ont fait
n'importe quoi avec des caricatures
dégueulasses ils ont été condamnés pour
X Y chose c'est du passé le fait que
Clément aille discuter la base que c'est
un problème ou pas je vais pas bien
compris pourquoi il y allait pas je
pense qu'on peut je pense il y a 41% de
Front national en France mais c'est pas
en allant dans une soirée où il y a que
des très très durs et des gens qui
payent 30 euros ou 35 euros la place
qu'on va faire bouger moi je ne refuse
aucun dialogue je vais y compris dans
des milieux qu'on dit conservateurs il y
a cinq ans le Medef je vais dialoguer
des gens du Medef j'ai réussi à ce que
400 entreprises passent à quatre jours
j'ai quand même lancer l'idée de la
semaine de 4 jours et j'ai obtenu que
400 entreprises passent à quatre jours
32 heures sans baisse de salaire le
patron de Brioche Pasquier c'était un
mec de droite le patron de Fleury Michon
c'est très sympa tout à fait mais en
fait il une droite humaniste mais le
patron un vieux ou le fondateur non non
le fondateur oui c'était Louis-Marie un
des deux frères Pasquier vous pouvez
retrouver sur le site alors là c'est
semaine de 4 jours.fr ce qu'ils veulent
avancer vers la semaine de 4 jours parce
qu'il y a déjà en 93 on avait lancé le
débat sur la semaine de 4 jours et en 85
Jacques Chirac le 13 juillet 95 va chez
brioche Pasquet tu sais les petites
brioches où tout le monde était passé à
4 jours les ouvriers les ouvriers les
commerciaux les y compris les territoire
général donc je suis un homme je suis un
homme de dialogue j'ai réussi à
convaincre le patron de Ferrari et donc
mais donc je pense qu'il faut dialoguer
mais aller dans un lieu comme ça pour le
la soirée valeur à une valeur actuelle
c'est un torchon c'est on peut être de
droite c'est c'est ton jugement
pendant la dernière fois je l'ai vu
j'avais honte pendant je suis désolé
mais on est la République c'est la
liberté d'égalité et la fraternité je
pense que ce journal ne correspond pas
aux valeurs de la République je suis
désolé il y a des terres que j'ai vu je
le lis pas tous des semaines mais qui
est franchement il y a un niveau de
racisme et un niveau de de haine par
rapport à de l'autre et a priori
qui était étonné la droite classique 80%
ils ont voté cet amendement par contre
le le groupe libéral donc les amis de
Macron il y en a que 40%, et les Front
national ils ont tous voté contre donc
monsieur Bardella et Madame Le Pen nous
disent pas qui veulent plus de justice
sociale ou plus de justice fiscale là on
a un exemple concret comment trouver du
fric on a entendu les gilets jaunes
c'est pas ceux et celles qui gagnent
1000 ou 2000 par mois qui doivent être
taxés le Parlement veut une petite taxe
sur les traders ceux qui sont à 28000
par mois ou les grands marchés
financiers et le Front National a voté
contre donc pendant donc je ne vais pas
avoir les dirigeants du Front national
je pense qu'on peut aller je suis allé
dans des quartiers difficiles ou
beaucoup de gens ne votent plus ou votre
front national je comprends très bien
leur colère toi et moi on a une vie
confortable moi je suis assimile par
mois j'ai un boulot passionnant il y a
des gens qui j'ai une amie qui qui vit
avec le RSA et qui me dit que à chaque
fois qu'il y a quelqu'un qui sonne elle
a peur que ce soit un huissier qui va la
[__] dehors parce qu'elle a toujours
une facture en retard donc ces gens-là
qui sont englués dans une vie très très
compliquée qui cherche un étudiante bien
sûr des gens des étudiants qui vont la
soupe populaire et voilà qui est Macron
refuse moi je me battais j'aurais aimé
que la gauche se rassemble avec la
gauche soit capable de gagner j'en veux
quand même aussi à ceux qui ont laissé
Macron on a tout fait pour qu'un
rassemblement et son avait été j'espère
que dans 5 ans dans 4 ans j’espère quand
même qu'on va pas recommencer les mêmes
erreurs dans 4 ans parce que on a un
deuxième tour d'armana Le Pen ça va être
l'horreur voilà donc on a vraiment fait
une erreur Édouard Philippe Le Pen ce
sera pas beaucoup mieux en terme de
politique économique et sociales non
mais parlons franchement pendant je j'ai
rien compris Édouard Philippe ou quoi
mais je pense qu'en matière quand il
veut la retraite à 67 ans je suis désolé
mais moi les écologistes aux élections
les écologistes 4,5
au présidentielle mais pardon mais par
contre ce que je veux dire c'est qu'il y
a plein de gens qui ont compris
l'urgence climatique aujourd'hui ce qui
me rend optimiste c'est que le peuple
s'est réveillé là Emmanuel Macron a
voulu braquer a voulu passer en force
sur les retraites mais depuis deux ans
avec le covid on était tous un peu
chacun et chacune chez soi et là on a
retrouvé face à un danger le fait le
plaisir d'être ensemble et ce qui me
m'impressionne
est-ce que tu as vu une finale de Coupe
du monde sur les Champs-Élysées mais je
pose pas les deux là sur les questions
sociales
dans la rue il y a du monde y compris
dans des villes où on avait prévu de
manifs depuis 20 ans pendant quand je
vois dans Ouest-France quand je vois
dans Sud-Ouest dans le Dauphiné Libéré
des villes où on a plus fait aucune
manifestation depuis 20 ans et où les
gens vont dans la rue et ce qui me rend
timide aussi c'est que c'est pas des
manifs égoïstes c'est je vois y compris
je me souviens d'un journaliste une fois
on a fini une interview et puis à la fin
il me dit que franchement cette réforme
ça le scandalisme parce qu'il me dit
évidemment vous et moi on travaillera
jusqu'à 67 ans et ça nous gêne pas on a
un boulot intéressant et on n'est pas
naviguer mais il me dit je vois en
Bretagne les gens qui travaillent dans
les abattoirs déjà à 50 ans ou 55 ans
ils ont des problèmes articulaires donc
je me suis dit tout à fait mais je me
suis dit cette les gens qui voilà je me
suis dit je sais pas si ce journaliste
va à gauche ou à droite mais il était
vraiment très très remonté contre la
réforme de Macron et non pas pour lui il
m'a dit deux fois vous et moi on a des
boulots qui sont passionnants et qui ne
sont pas fatigants on ira jusqu'à 67 ans
et cette réforme de toute façon avant ou
après la réforme mais par contre il
était scandalisé pour et moi je vois mon
beau-père était chauffeur de camions il
a pas pu aller jusqu'au bout parce qu'il
avait des problèmes il a eu que 6 ans
avant de mourir ma belle-mère était
femme de ménage je vois ce que c'est
elle a eu que très peu d'années pour
profiter de ça ça retraite parce qu'elle
a des gros problèmes donc c'est très
donc moi je suis si je suis en bonne
forme j'espère avoir un boulot jusqu'à
67 ans mais je trouve que un des trucs
positifs où il y a aussi non ce flingue
mais quand même un des éléments positifs
en France aujourd'hui c'est que beaucoup
de gens ont retrouvé le plaisir d'aller
dans la rue et de parler avec d'autres
gens qu'on a compris qu'on avait une
capacité même si Macron passe en force
on a une capacité de reprendre en votre
avenir et qu'il y a une volonté de
solidarité et que les gens sont allés
dans la rue des gens ont fait grève y
compris en disant cette réforme elle me
concerne pas moi de toute façon je suis
bac + 5 je continuerai à travailler mais
que mais je ne veux pas qu'on demande à
des gens qui ont déjà des métiers très
fatigants de travailler 2 ans de plus
voilà donc je pense que et sur la
question du climat sont très très mal
payés et qui souvent sont les mal payés
ont des boulots précaires on des
bouleaux fatigants des problèmes de
temps de transport on ne rentrerait très
faible une espérance de vie c'est pas
pour rien si je parlais de mon beau-père
qui n'a eu que 6 ans entre le moment où
il s'est mis il a pas pu aller jusqu'au
bout de ses années parce qu'il avait des
problèmes de santé et s'ils ont après il
était mort donc je pense qu'il y a alors
que un cadre sup qui a un boulot moins
fatigant à une espérance de vie à la
retraite de 20 ou 30 ans voilà donc
c'est une inégalité scandaleuse et
peut-être que c'est bien qu'on parle de
nos vies de nos corps et jusqu'à
maintenant c'était le problème théorique
c'était le problème de thermostat les
milliards d'équilibres et là on a parlé
partout sur les plateaux de télé mais
aussi dans les manifs des hommes et des
femmes qui se lèvent le matin qui se
cassent le dos parce qu'il il transporte
des choses lourdes le transportent des
personnes malades le film de François
Ruffin était magnifique là-dessus soit
les gens qui donnent leur vie pour
s'occuper d'une petite vieille aller de
tenir compagnie lui donner à manger la
nettoyer puis la déplacer et puis ils
ont un quart d'heure pour aller voir la
suivante et ces gens-là donnent leur vie
pour au service pour un salaire ridicule
et sont complètement cassés et il n'est
pas possible leur demander de travailler
jusqu'à 64 ans surtout qu'il y a des
alternatives on va peut-être parler de
la semaine de 4 jours si on passe tous à
4 jours on peut créer un million 600 000
emplois et si on crée un million 600 000
emplois ça fait un million 600 000
personnes qui vont cotiser pour les
caisses de retraite alors avant de
parler de la semaine de 4 jours je
voudrais qu'on parle de la taxe carbone
le texte carbone c'est combien par
tonnes en euros par personne et par an
c'est encore flou
c'est encore flou parce que surtout que
avec la flambée du prix l'énergie qui
est en ce moment en Europe on espère que
la guerre en Ukraine va s'arrêter vite
et que l'Ukraine va gagner mais on ne
sait pas et donc on ne sait pas pendant
quoi gagner mais c'est que les Russes
laissent les Ukrainiens vivre en liberté
et que les Russes repartent dans leur
pays et que le l'Ukraine jusqu'à les
boutiques de Crimée je pense que ce
serait le mieux mais qu'en tout cas que
le l'Ukraine garde l'essentiel de son
territoire et ils vivent libre et que
les Russes reculent que les Russes
disent on a fini la guerre voilà
l'histoire de l'humanité on sait qu'à un
moment on signe une armistice c'est fini
voilà c'est fini et le but n'est pas
d'humilier celui qui a perdu on sait que
si on humilie ce que lui qui a perdu ça
donne pas de bons résultats mais il faut
que la guerre soit finie avec les
ukrainiens et gagne voilà et que
l'Europe doit vendre toutes les semaines
est-ce qu'on fait le maximum là-dessus
mais pour revenir sur la question du
prix l'énergie donc là il y a une
flambée du prix de l'énergie à cause de
la guerre en Ukraine on sait pas combien
ça va durer et le prix du CO2 on est à
dans un nombre à dire on a vu les
philosophes faut arrêter de penser que
c'est la seule solution pour financer la
tension c'est ça donc il faut en même
temps je pense un être humain qui
travaille qui est obligé d'aller bosser
avec son diesel ou sa vieille caisse
il fait 50 bornes minimum par jour
il est à combien de tonnes par an il est
à 8,9 tonnes 9 tonnes 10 tonnes si je
parle vite je pense que tu as entendu ce
que j'ai dit il y a une demi-heure sur
le fait que dans mon coin des Pyrénées
il y avait plein de gilets jaunes et que
je vais les comprenais très très bien
parce qu'il y a aucun transport en
commun et je répète ce que j'ai dit il y
a une demi-heure tout c'est celle qui
ont un boulot il y en a qui ont pas de
boulot mais c'est celle qui a un boulot
ils prennent leur voiture le souverain
une vieille voiture pas très épanou
voiture de riche et voilà et ils vont à
Argelès soit Pierrefitte oui parce
qu'ils ont pas le choix voilà il y a
aucun transport en commun il y a un bus
le matin et un bus le soir et si tu l'as
tonnes c'est 45 euros en 2027
ça dépend du prix de l'énergie et c'est
surtout ces questions on sait que au
dernier moment on doit souvent changer
les règles du jeu parce qu'on se rend
compte que ça n'est pas tenable et donc
c'est pour ça que le Parlement européen
la cette semaine on a voté un texte pour
dire qu'il fallait mettre en place un
prix du carbone mais ça n'est que un des
éléments d'une politique plus globale et
ce dont j'ai parlé 15 fois depuis le
début de notre dialogue c'est la taxe
sur la spéculation voilà c'est pour te
dire que non mais tous ceux qui disent
tu me parles pas de ma gueule en disant
il m'appelait monsieur pardon parce que
passe mon temps à s'excuser quoi
histoire de continuer à monopoliser
je vois que tu veux prendre la parole et
je veux juste t'expliquer que c'est une
erreur on connaît l'histoire de
l'ivrogne qui qui est près d'un
réverbère et il cherche ses clés on dit
même peut-être sûr que vos clés sont ici
non non les clés sont là-bas mais ici il
y a de la lumière voilà et depuis 30 ans
il y a des économies que pour sauver la
planète comme il faut baisser les
émissions de CO2 on va augmenter le prix
du CO2 et ça va tout régler et dans les
ordinateurs du CNRS c'est génial et ça
fonctionne très très bien on a vu avec
les gilets jaunes qui a un tout petit
problème de calendrier que augmenter le
prix du carbone si on n'a pas mis en
place des transports en commun ou et de
la rénovation thermique pour c'est juste
inacceptable socialement et donc voilà
pourquoi parmi les députés français on
était nombreux à dire attention les amis
ça marche très bien dans les livres
d'économie mais en vrai ça n'est pas du
tout la seule solution pour il y a
besoin de trouver de l'argent pour le
climat et le prix du carbone n'est pas
du tout la seule solution et faites
gaffe parce que votre calendrier on y
croit pas donc moi je pense qu'il faut
donner un prix au carbone c'est aussi ce
qu'ils explique externe qui ferait même
mettre le fait qu'on prévient 30 ans à
l'avance que le prix du carbone va
augmenter et qu'en particulier les
industriels comprennent que c'est pour
de vrai qui change leur comportement
mais que pour monsieur et madame tout le
monde faut pas se tromper dans le
calendrier il faut d'abord des aides il
faut d'abord des aides il faut d'abord
des transports en commun il faut d'abord
de la rénovation thermique et qu’après
ça on peut augmenter le prix du carbone
et ce que je voulais dire quand même
quand je parlais des conservateurs et
quand tu m'as parlé de la soirée valeurs
actuelles c'est qu'au temps je ne
comprends pas qu'on aille parler avec
des chefs
néophytes ou de droite dure xénophobe
autant moi je dis alors Zemmour ici
on aurait pas dû je sais pas
je te fais confiance peut-être tu es
assez tu n'es pas du je pense que tu
l'as admis j'ai pas vous regardez
l'émission donc excuse-moi je pense que
tu l'as mis face à ces retranchements
mes émotions
nous on commence à être chaud à partir
d'une heure et demie et il est peut-être
pas le temps non plus est-ce que c'est
important de discuter avec tout le monde
avec tous les citoyens oui parce
qu'encore une fois moi quelqu'un qui
vote Front national je peux très bien
comprendre qu'ils soient en colère il a
l'impression qu'il y en a qui se gonfle
qui a des qui sont au service juste de
leur nombril et des banquiers Le Pen à
Jordan Bardella Éric Zemmour mais ils
sont pas arrivés ici comme une lettre à
la poste ah mais je vous souhaite la
déception parce que beaucoup de gens il
y a eu la politique de barrage pendant
des années des années dans Diguer le
Front national endiguier endigué
résultat des courses on est en 2023
41% pour l'extrême droite ça a pas
marché oui mais c'est parce que les
politiques ont trahi pendant moi je suis
isolé mais les cinq années de François
Hollande mon adversaire c'est la finance
et bien non mais pardon
ok tu as raison pardon de dire pardon
non mais pardon donc j'arrête de dire
pardon la politique quand la gauche est
au pouvoir elle a vraiment trahi donc je
comprendrais bien les gens les qui
étaient en a une situation de grande
précarité qui ont en principe aurait dû
se tourner vers la gauche qui en
principe devrait avoir des solutions
contre la précarité pour permettre à
tout le monde d'avoir un appartement
avec un loyer qui n'est pas trop pas
trop énorme qui devrait aider les
étudiants il y a des pays où il y a une
allocation d'autonomie ou les étudiants
et les étudiants peuvent étudier sans
avoir besoin d'accumuler les petits
boulots
[Musique]
dans les familles riches et les enfants
vont dans les bonnes universités ou dans
les classes préparées papa et maman sont
là pour financer les études tandis que
dans les familles plus précaires dans
les familles plus précaires tu dois en
même temps faire un boulot et donc tu
finis à 23h 20 minutes le lendemain tu
es crevé quand tu vas à la fac du sport
d'être pauvre comme disait les autres
oui oui mais donc c'est trouver la bonne
promotion au secondaire
moi c'est une des raisons pour
lesquelles je poussais à ce qu'on se
rassemble pour que la gauche se
rassemble pour avoir une chance
peut-être une petite chance de gagner la
présidentielle parmi les raisons je
mettais les allocations il y a des pays
où il y a une allocation d'autonomie au
Danemark où tous les jeunes reçoivent
800 euros par mois pour vivre et ben si
tu as 800 euros par mois pour vivre
c'est pas obligé de faire des petits
boulots et de et tu as du temps pour tes
études je voulais aussi que la gauche
gagne pour faire comme en Espagne des
lois contre les féminicides et qu'on se
donne les moyens de lutter vraiment
contre les féminicides il y a pas un
pays où tout baigne mais si on prend ce
qu'il y a de mieux au Danemark il y a de
mieux sur notre sujet en Espagne qui
aime mieux il y a des pays où il y a
quasiment pas de SDF parce qu'on fait le
hocing First on considère que les seins
énormes ou une femme dans la rue c'est
indigne et que même point du financier
c'est moins cher de lui permettre
d'avoir un petit appartement où il peut
être en confiance et du coup être en
capacité de chercher du boulot donc si
on prend ce qu'il y a de mieux dans
d'autres pays d'Europe on aurait tout
pour vivre un pays tout à fait équilibré
on a tout pour vivre on n'a jamais été
aussi riche on pourrait vivre dans un
pays de cocagne et donc j'en veux à tous
les dirigeants de la gauche qui parce
que chacun voulait avoir sa photo on
fait on a été ridicule on a laissé le
pouvoir à Macron et donc là dans 4 ans
est-ce qu'on continue les conneries ou
est-ce qu'on se donne les moyens d'avoir
une équipe il y en a aucun qui peut dire
je sais tout et qu'on est une équipe et
qui se donne les moyens de d'avoir des
propositions concrètes comme la semaine
de 4 jours ou d'autres et qui permet de
redonner de l'espoir et derrière de ne
pas le trahir avant avant de parce que
je te sens emmener sur ton sujet de la
semaine de 4 jours
tu es un filou quand même et
il faut il faut interdire les yachts les
bateaux les les jets privés il faut
interdire le sport qui consomme trop
d'énergie la formule en avion oui je
pense que oui franchement est-ce qu'il
faut interdire tout ça le le sport
mécaniques est-ce qu'il faut
se mettre en mode rationnement
parce que là tel que je t'entends je
vois tes chiffres je voulais les
rapports du GIEC je vois l'anticipation
totale sur un scénario à 3.5 je me dis
notre vaisseau parce que la terre c'est
un peu notre vaisseau spatial
bon bah il prend l'eau il trouve dans la
colle on est en train de se faire
empoisonner par la climatisation
ça a commencé à devenir difficile de
d'éviter de se prendre des fuites ou des
des grandes sécheresses est-ce qu'il
faut vraiment passer en mode guerre mais
pas nous sommes en guerre
il faut déclarer la guerre au
réchauffement climatique
mais est-ce que tu penses pas que si on
déclare la guerre au réchauffement
climatique notre industrie le trou d'air
économique sociale que ça va créer avant
de faire l'interview tu me dis voilà la
question c'est est-ce qu'on va se
prendre le mur à 30 km/h ou est-ce qu'on
va se prendre la Mure à 250 km/h oui
c'est pas la on va se prendre le mur on
a mais est-ce qu'on est à 30 km/h à
répéter
on va avoir des moments difficiles mais
c'est pas la même chose je sais pas si
c'est la bonne image mais ce qui est sûr
c'est que on a perdu tellement de temps
depuis 40 ans on a tellement fait du
blabla on a tellement pas fait que oui
on voit bien que le diagan qui est en
train de s'aggraver les problèmes de
sécheresse qu'on a en ce moment en
France on va se prendre le mur oui mais
c'est pas la même chose de prendre le
mur quand tu as 30 km/h et que tu as une
ceinture de sécurité ou quand tu as le
sentiment à l'heure et que tu as pas de
ceinture c'est quoi une belle ceinture
adaptation c'est déjà est-ce qu'on se
donne les moyens de encore une fois si
j'ai fait une grève de la fin il y a
deux ans pour avoir plus de fric pour le
climat c'est que je fais partie comme
beaucoup beaucoup de gens il y a des
gens qui risquent leur vie dans des ONG
ou dans des pays du Sud donc je vais pas
me mettre comme un tour
ah ça j'avoue que je ne veux certaines
occasions de dissaut vas-y
pardon qu'est-ce que tu es là
pour résumer trivialement ces mots qu'il
a dit sur quotidien et pas la virgule
près donc vous m'excuserez il a dit
voilà il y a des gens qui proposent de
changement de système mais entre le
changement de système et et maintenant
ça risque de d'emmener des grosses
turbulences
en gros notre société de
termo-industrielle alors ça c'est pas du
tout qu'il a dit note tu proposes un
changement une politique d'adaptation
est-ce que c'est pas trop tard pour
s'adapter
donc
il faut déclarer la guerre au
réchauffement climatique ça veut dire
est-ce qu'il faut des cartes de
rationnement comme pendant la guerre
c'est une vraie question sur le bilan
carbone de chacun il y a des gens qui
proposent qu'on ait un fou interdire la
maison individuelle non les maisons
elles exercent mais maintenant il faut
arrêter de maintenant il faut arrêter de
vas-y continue
est-ce qu'on va passer
en politique de guerre a dû rationnement
à se serrer la ceinture et que c'est il
y a eu trop de gaji il y a eu trop de
bamboches et là il faut payer l'addition
sinon les générations futures vont nous
trucider je pense que si on continue
comme ça nos enfants vont nous détester
il y a une fois ils étaient dans une
réunion avec tous les leaders de la
gauche c'était huit mois avant les
présidentielles et j'ai expliqué nos
enfants vont nous détester nos enfants
vont jeter des cailloux si on continue
les conneries on aura Macron encore
pendant 5 ans qui va rien faire et nos
enfants vont nous détester oui il y a
aucun doute et ils seront de bonnes
raisons de nous détester si on continue
comme ça mais quand tu parles de
rationnement ça fait peur le
moralonnement voilà ça fait peur guerre
contre le
pardon est-ce que je peux développer
deux minutes à ce que je peux répondre 2
minutes tu développes beaucoup là donc
là tu dis de guerre il faut déclarer la
guerre au réchauffement climatique
appelons un chat oui on peut interdire
les jets privés
on peut complètement interdire les jet
privé on peut avoir à aller en train ou
faire des réunions par zoom par contre
quand tu demandes s'il faut interdire
toutes les maisons individuelles il
s'agit pas on va pas raser toutes les
maisons individuelles il faut les
rénover et pas chez les pouces c'est
déjà lequel c'est déjà le cas pour les
peaux les plus pauvres choisir de se
chauffer ou de sauter un repas est-ce
que j'ai dit tout à l'heure et mon
intervention d'hier au Parlement
européenne si tu veux retrouver ce que
j'ai dit hier que j'en avais honte qu'on
était en 2023 que les gens doivent
choisir entre manger normalement et se
chauffer
très pénible humainement voilà donc le
but est ce qu'on contraire est-ce qu'on
peut avoir une forme de sobriété qui est
efficace qui est joyeuse si tu peux
quand même vivre correctement si ta
maison est isolée tu dépendras une fois
j'ai vu un monsieur il y a quelques
années son hlm c'était près de Grenoble
sont HLM était isolé et spontanément il
m'a dit c'est beaucoup mieux j'ai moins
chaud l'été j'ai moins froid l'hiver et
je gagne 800 euros chaque année sur mes
dépenses de chauffage
tu vois qu'est-ce que ça veut dire se
serrer la ceinture ça le gars il a pas
l'impression de souffrir spontanément il
te dit vraiment ça y est on a fini les
trois immeubles de la petite le petit
logement HLM et il te dit c'est beaucoup
plus agréable pour la famille on a moins
chaud l'été moins froid l'hiver et on
gagne 800 euros et le maire 18 juste ben
voilà avec je fais ce que je veux mais
j'aimerais que Pierre tu obtiennes les
financements européens dont tu parles
c'est avant choix député Jean-Joseph et
toi vous expliquer comment on pourrait
multiplier par 10 ou par 20 le nombre de
rénovations chaque année donc ça c'est
pas un sacrifice le ce monsieur continue
à avoir une appartement de croisière
peut-être que oui les plus gros je sais
pas je vais pas réfléchir des chantiers
navals en France mais ils feront des
transports en commun quelqu'un ce que
j'ai expliqué pendant le confinement
j'étais rapporteur général du budget
donc avec mon équipe on a une réunion
avec légendaire bus à l'époque on avait
peur que de ce poisson d'emploi
catastrophique chez Airbus et chez les
sous-traitants et pendant une heure on a
vu comment éviter des milliers de
licenciements comment on fait et à la
fin je leur ai dit écouté il faudrait
qu'on se reparle je dois vous dire je ne
prends jamais l'avion dans ma vie privée
quand il y a un sommet sur le climat en
Afrique pertinent dans ma vie privée je
ne prends jamais jamais l'avion et je
pense que ça n'est pas sérieux que vos
prévisions de vente Airbus pour les 30
ans qui viennent ne sont pas sérieuses
sinon on va les nos enfants vont nous
détester on va même catastrophe donc
j'ai dit je serai reconnaît une nouvelle
réunion parce que les salariés de chez
vous ils sont un métier dans les mains
ils sont souvent très doués ils savent
il y en a qui savent travailler le
plastique doit c'est l'électronique donc
c'est le métal de ces métaux les métaux
rares et donc on continuera à faire
quelques avions peut-être pour certaines
conditions extrêmes mais ou pour les
services de santé mais les salariés qui
sont chez vous le but est pas de les
mettre de les licencier ils pourront
avec leur savoir-faire et pour
construire des transports en commun ils
pourront construire de faire du
plastique et au pire s'il y a besoin de
moins de travail je leur ai dit chez
Volkswagen il y avait 30000 personnes en
trop ils sont tous restés ils ont eu
aucun licenciement ils sont passés à 28
heures donc j'ai dit aux gens d'Airbus
est-ce qu'on peut se revoir en disant
comment on transforme Airbus vous ferez
quelques avions mais de moins en moins
vous ferez des transports en commun vous
ferez et d'autres donc je crois qu'on
peut mais est-ce qu'on se donne les
moyens de piloter cette quand tu dis
qu'Olivier du sceau explique que ça va
compliqué ça va être compliqué si on est
compliqué le ceux qui proposent un
changement c'est plus en retard plus ça
va être compliqué voilà quand il y aura
des paniques
la panique je fais pas quand mais quand
on verra qu'il y a des sécheresse à
répétition et qui a plus assez d'eau là
on est en avril on est le 20 avril il y
a des villages où on apporte des
bouteilles d'eau aux gens
si dans 10 ans il y a plus assez d'eau
avec les gens comprennent que c'est
foutu ça va être le chacun pour soi il y
a un moment où ça va donc est-ce qu'on
est capable quand on peut encore faire
bouger les choses là on est dans ce
manque critique et passionnant où les
gens la plupart des gens comprennent que
c'est grave mais c'est pas encore foutu
et je le dis donc l'exemple que je
voulais donner quand tu me parlais de
valeur actuelle autant je ne serai pas
aller dans la soirée à l'heure actuelle
autant je pense tout à fait utile
d'aller voir des milieux conservateurs
qui soient la question du climat soit en
train de bouger il y a 5 ans j'étais
invité pour l'événement de rentrer des
jeunes agriculteurs je parle pas de la
Confédération paysanne mais la branche
jeune de la FNSEA cette terre de gym à
fougère en Bretagne des milliers
d'agriculteurs le concours national de
la bourre la messe avec Monseigneur
d'Ornella c'est un milieu qui est resté
bien catho et
et donc le jeune un des chefs du
syndicat qui lançait le débat en disant
ce débat le sujet était que peut faire
l'Europe pour gagner la bataille du
climat dans l'événement de rentrée des
jeunes de tous les Jeunes Agriculteurs
de France et le celui qui lançait le
débat disait ce débat était inimaginable
il y a 10 ans il y a 10 ans on était
tous climatosceptiques Claude Allègre
était notre héros et les écolos nous
cassaient les bottes il disait
aujourd'hui il n'y a plus aucun
climato-sceptique chez les paysans il y
a quelques années à cause des
inondations on a perdu 30% de la récolte
de blé et cette année on a des copains
qui vont tuer une partie du troupeau
parce qu'il n'y a plus de foin quant à 3
2 canicules de suite tu donnes du foie à
partir du mois d'août parce qu'il y a
plus d'herbe dans les prés et bien à la
fin de l'année tu sais que tu as pu
assez de fois tu tues une partie du
troupeau donc il dit il y a plus aucun
climato-sceptique chez les paysans la
question est à savoir comment est-ce
qu'on nous aide et c'est pour ça qu'on a
demandé à Monsieur la route ou de venir
nous expliquer son plan pour pour
financer le
la transformation de l'agriculture donc
il y a 6 ans ou 7 ans déjà le premier
syndicat des jeunes agriculteurs était
prêt pour le changement et donc j'en
veux beaucoup Emmanuel Macron qui aurait
dû s'appuyer là-dessus pour
effectivement proposer des aides
proposées qu'on la convention citoyenne
pour le climat avait fait des
propositions sur l'agriculture et
l'alimentation Emmanuel Macron n'a pas
voulu les reprendre
la pollution de l'eau du robinet t'as
suivi un peu là
et je pense qu'on se protège pas assez
je pense qu'on a des autorités qui sont
parfois naïves et qu'on devrait se
protéger beaucoup mieux de ces
substances qui vont rester pendant très
très longtemps dans l'eau et qu'on a
comment on commence à avoir des
problèmes de maladie de d'infertilité de
manque de fertilité oui on joue au con
et tout ça est documenté hélas
tu parles de fertilité est-ce que
pousser à l'extrême façon réchauffement
climatique il faut encadrer les
naissances
comme en Chine fut un temps
c'est un je pense effectivement que la
démographie aujourd'hui n'est pas le
premier sujet parce que c'est en Europe
et aux États-Unis où il y a peu
d'enfants par famille qui ont polluent
le plus qu'on fait le plus de CO2 et
qu'on arrive de vivre voilà mais que
effectivement il y a une fois que
j'étais
au Mali et pour parler du climat et je
leur ai dit écouté c'est un tabou mais
je crois qu'il faut aussi qu'on parle de
démographie moi j'adore les bébés je
suis une famille de 6 mois on a décidé
de n'avoir que deux enfants pourtant
j'adore les billets à maman je me suis
dit c'est voulait être instituteur
surtout c'est génial de voir un enfant
qui grandit d'allumer son intelligence
mais avec ma femme on a décidé de
n'avoir que deux enfants parce qu'on se
dit que en plus à Paris avec les loyers
c'est plus raisonnable et donc je pense
est un des sujets c'est pas l'urgence ça
n'est pas le sujet numéro un mais
effectivement quand je vois en Ouganda 4
enfants par femme je me dis que c'est
compliqué que c'est pas la cause
principale aujourd'hui du dérèglement
climatique mais effectivement c'est si
on mettait en place une meilleure
éducation pour les femmes et un meilleur
accès à la santé au droit producteurs se
mettent en place une sécurité sociale
qui fait que les gens savent qu'ils
auront une retraite et que c'est pas
leurs enfants qui paieront leur retraite
on devrait pouvoir diminuer le ralentir
la démographie
je saute du coq à l'âne tu as vu là en
Île-de-France il faut plus consommer les
œufs des poulailler domestiques parce
qu'il y a tu as vu ça
il y a une pollution
elle a dioxine dans de large proportions
comment ça se fait peut-être un petit
idée je n'ai pas lu le l'étude
la semaine des quatre jours ça veut dire
quand même qu'il faut se remettre en
cause que soit on décide d'aller vers le
suicide je vais te demander non mais
une association à chaque fois que tu dis
pardon on nous a appris à l'école qu'on
a été des sapiens sapiens on nous a dit
qu'on était la branche la plus évoluée
des primates et parfois on demande si on
est vraiment des Homo sapiens sapiens ou
des débiles débiles parce que quand on
voit les problèmes de pollution dont tu
viens de parler quand on voit le
problème du climat on est au courant
depuis 40 ans on nous dit qu'il y a pas
d'argent pour le climat et la justice
sociale mais les marchés financiers sont
un niveau jamais vu mais [__] il y a
de quoi dans 10 ans dans 20 ans nos
enfants nous diront mais vous étiez
débiles vous étiez pas des sapiens
sapiens si vous étiez débile vous étiez
aveugle donc c'est quand même un vrai
problème spirituel un problème
anthropologique l'humanité c'est qu'elle
va vers un suicide par tous les
pesticides qui sont dans l'eau partout
les produits chimiques on ne peut même
plus manger les œufs d'une poule qui se
promène dans le jardin en Île-de-France
les les moi j'ai créé le club apiculture
quand j'étais à la grotte un
effondrement de de des abeilles j'ai été
contacté par l'Union des apiculteurs la
semaine dernière quand j'étais petit on
allait dans les Pyrénées il fallait non
moi j'ai vraiment clavier
quand j'étais petit on allait on était
toute la famille dans la voiture pour
aller dans les Pyrénées régulièrement il
fallait nettoyer le le
la vitre devant la voiture pendant le
pare-brise je suis fatigué le pare-brise
parce qu'il y avait plein de petits
moucherons
non mais il y avait plein de petits
moucherons là tu peux faire pendant un
an quasiment ou pendant 6 mois sans
aller enfin moi j'utilise pas beaucoup
la voiture parce que des métros je suis
du vélo mais voilà les fondament de la
biodiversité il est énorme il est il
s'accélère et le lien entre avec le
réchauffement climatique est évident le
jour je voyais un forestier c'était
poignant un forestier qui faisait la
tournée des mares en disant il y a pas
d'eau du tout avec la sécheresse de
l'été dernier les mars sont pas
reconstituées donc les batraciens
peuvent pas se reproduire moi quand
j'étais petit le grand jeu avec les
cousins à Pâques c'est en allait
chercher les œufs le jour de Pâques les
ordres chocolat et sinon on allait
chercher des têtards parce que partout
il y avait des mares avec plein de
têtards
tu les élevés tu lui as rouges
par les parents mais à l'époque c'était
pas grave
de manière pas de libération il y a
quelques semaines et on citer un de ses
amis de son coin de paysans qui disaient
je comprends pas bien les choix de
Benoît voilà et Benoît était très ému
quand il m'en a parlé l'autre jour en
disant c'est un collègue paysan
paix à son âme depuis deux ans il se
posait des grandes questions sur la
place de l'agriculture dans la société
et toutes les critiques on entend est-ce
qu'on est capable de transformer le
système et là en même temps qu'il y
avait l'écran de manif pour les pour
stopper les grosses bassines ce monsieur
c'est à donner ses données la mort voilà
donc je pense qu'il y a une souffrance y
compris chez l'agriculteur ils sont ils
voient bien le nombre de cancers ils
sont pas débiles le nombre de cancers
chez les agriculteurs il voit bien que
leurs femmes leur mari leur conjoint
leurs enfants disent mais [__] tu as
une vie de con tu travailles le nom mais
là de maladie professionnelle oui donc
la question est d'abord au lieu de au
lieu de montrer du doigt est-ce qu'on
est capable de se dire c'est une
responsabilité commune je répète que des
Martin Luther King nous devons il faut
apprendre à vivre comme des frères et
soeurs ou se préparer à mourir comme des
imbéciles donc on est capable de se
transformer y compris d'aider
financièrement les agriculteurs pour
transformer leur pratique et mettre
beaucoup moins de pesticides et donc
mais il faut trois ou quatre ans pendant
si tu veux mettre moins de produits
chimiques il faut 3 ou 4 ans pour que la
terre retrouve sa fécondité que les vers
de terre reviennent et fassent que le
musc soit assez donc pendant trois ou
quatre ans les paysans ont besoin d'une
aide financière d'une aide que d'autres
leur expliquer comment changer les
pratiques tu parles des bassines
qu'est-ce que tu penses des gens qui
s'amusent à balancer des cocktails et
les motos sur des camions de gendarmerie
je pense c'est légitime pas légitime
est-ce que c'est une anticipation à la
violence que le climat va faire subir
est-ce que tu penses que c'est des
gamins qui veulent simplement leur
décharge d'adrénaline c'est quoi ta
vision de la violence
la radicalisation
des mouvements
écologistes écologiques est-ce que tu
penses que ça s'accentuer est-ce que
entre les cocktails Molotov les
cocktails Moloto fallacie ou du moins
les bouteilles avec des pétards à
l'acide est-ce que c'est légitime pas
légitime qu'est-ce que c'est pour toi
c'est d'abord une grande tristesse et
une grosse inquiétude parce qu'on est le
seul pays d'Europe et autant de violence
depuis que je suis député je suis sous
très souvent à Bruxelles quelle violence
là la violence dans les manifs la
violence dans les manifs
depuis quelques mois mais je me souviens
il y a quatre ans j'allais la même
semaine à une manif fois le climat à
Bruxelles pas un gramme de violence et
le samedi j'arrive pour la même raison
c'est la manif pour le climat au niveau
voilà et on est Nassé Nasser ça veut
dire qu'on peut rentrer dans un endroit
et on peut plus en sortir je me suis un
prêt du jardin du Luxembourg et on se
reçoit des lacrymogènes on est un samedi
après-midi juste pour dire il y a
climatique et je me suis un autre Dame
des Landes il y avait un samedi
après-midi une très très belle manif au
moins de 10000 personnes toute la
générations tu vois tu arrives sur la
nasse
est-ce que tu penses que c'est une
technique contre insurrectionnelle de
faire ça c'est-à-dire dissuader à force
de se prendre des lacrymo dans la tête
nasée comme des petits moutons pour
dissuader de la semaine prochaine
dissuader du mois prochain ne marche pas
pour faire l'exemple j'allais dire ça
détruit la République faut pas exagérer
mais c'est scandaleux géante et c'est
pour ça que je parlais de
Notre-Dame-des-Landes passer
effectivement une stratégie à
Notre-Dame-des-Landes un samedi
après-midi on arrive 10 ou 20 000
personnes c'est compliqué de compter
il y a quelques années pendant je
n'étais pas éteindre
quelques semaines mais là je te reviens
pour te dire que hélas depuis Manuel
Valls je pense qu'il y a une cassure
dans la façon dont on utilise et ceux
qui sont en cause c'est pas les CRS ou
les policiers c'est ce qui leur donnent
des ordres débiles et est-ce qu'on a le
et donc je me suis un très bien cette
manif à Notre-Dame-des-Landes il y avait
un sondage qui allait sortir qu'ils
aient que 80% des Français pensaient
qu'il n'y avait pas besoin d'un deuxième
aéroport on a les stérilisé des
centaines d'hectares et quand
modernisant le premier aéroport ça
suffisait et puis il faut limiter
l'avion donc une enquête qui va dire que
80% des gens pensent qu'il n'y a pas
besoin de cet aéroport une manif super
joyeuse il y avait des papiers des
mamies il y avait des jeunes coupes il y
avait des gens de tous les âges moi
j'étais avec un homme une amie qui était
député à l'époque on répondait à des à
quelques jeunes qui avaient une caméra
et qui voulait faire une interview voilà
et j'ai vu vraiment j'ai vu comment
quelques jeunes comptes qui arrivent qui
sont là pour la castagne qui sont
masqués qui ne baladent donc on aurait
la police aurait très bien pu les choper
dans le contrôle identité vous n'avez
pas quand tu quelqu'un arrive avec des
boules de boules de pétanque ou des
matraques dans son sac et qu'il est
masqué tu te dis qu'il vient pas
uniquement pour défendre la biodiversité
et le climat donc tu as le droit de
faire un contrôle d'identité et donc je
les ai vu comment il y avait des CRS il
y avait vraiment plusieurs dizaines de
CRS de Paris doit d'une banque ils ont
laissé ces jeunes qui ont péter la
banque et à partir de là c'est 16 images
qu'on a vu en permanence sur les réseaux
sociaux et sur BFM ailleurs et à partir
de ce moment-là on s'est pris de
lacrymogène il y avait l'hélicoptère qui
nous fait qui nous suivaient c'était
panique à bord et le soir on a retenu
quoi on n'a pas retenu une belle manif
avec des milliers de gens de toute
génération totalement Pacifique on n'a
pas retenu le sondage qui disait que 80%
des gens voulaient que on stoppe le
projet on a juste retenu des images de
violence et je pense que Manuel Valls
c'était tout content parce qu'il a
pourri la manif mais moyenne en quoi
quelques mois plus tard on a quand même
obtenu d'arrêter ce cet aéroport et
c'était une très bonne décision parce
qu'on voit que le premier aéroport n'est
pas saturé donc je pense et là ce qu'il
y a une stratégie de pourrir des gens
qui quand même occupé le terrain jour et
nuit
qui avait érigé des barricades anti
gendarmes pour éviter d'être envahissent
quand même autre chose la violence toi
ça y est c'est grâce à vous les les noms
de violents que ça a permis de
d'arrêter le projet il y avait des gens
sur place c'était
on va dire pas appeler ça des résistants
mais dans l'âme dans les dispositifs qui
ont été
installer sur place
c'était de la vraie guérir avec pas la
guérilla
des miradors qui rentraient à gauche à
droite vous allez même leur radio sur
place
que des gens qui veulent protéger une
zone se donnent les moyens d'avoir une
radio entre pour se parler c'est pas
choquant toi tu fais une émission qui
regardait par un certain nombre de
centaines de milliers de personnes il y
a des communautés qui se créent là il y
a une communauté qui s'est créée qui
voulait protéger cet espace en disant on
n'a pas besoin d'un aéroport on veut que
c'était reste agricole et reste pour la
biodiversité et pour la forêt et qui se
crée une radio pour se parler entre eux
c'est pas choquant je reviens sur les
sur les Hassan solid où il y a eu des
images des pirates
peut-être mais voilà c'est pas très
grave c'est pas il faut quand même voilà
c'est pas très très grave je connais pas
le détail mais c'est pas choquant c'est
pas une atteinte à la liberté des gens
c'est pas une atteinte à la République
c'est pas il y a pas mort d'homme de
créer une petite radio pirate où on a
des dialogues et de faire des des je
vais pas dire des barrages mais si que
des points filtrants anti gendarmes pour
éviter qu'il rentre avec des gens qui
font gay c'est que je crois je crois
décris le truc et je te pose la question
de la violence légitime on peut légitime
c'est plus le réchauffement climatique
va avancer
il y a des gens qui vont se radicaliser
est-ce que tout de suite il faut leur
expliquer que la radicalisation de
change rien
ou ça va changer quelque chose ou pas du
tout c'est bien
violentes moi j'ai fait des actions non
violentes de la fin mais j'en ai fait
d'autres avant j'étais allé quand il y
avait à Pau le avec les journal
alternatifs il y avait un saut un sommet
international des forages au fur et les
gens qui font des trous au fond de
l'océan de plus en plus loin de la côte
façon de plus en dangereuse pour trouver
du pétrole et chaque année il y a un
grand colloque international où il
compare leur méthode une année sa
Chicago une année c'est dans un pays
arabe une année à Pau et à Pau n'était
400 moi je n'ai fait que 24 heures mais
avec des gens d'alternatiba et d'annuler
comme 21 et de façon tout à fait non
violente pour dialoguer il y en a un qui
a réussi à rentrer dans la salle des
congrès et qui habillé comme un
businessman il a rusé il a réussi à
parler aux autres alors qu'en science
pour dire mais les amis pourquoi est-ce
qu'on continue à faire des forages
offshore donc on s'est pris de
lacrymogènes mon année n'est pas mort
les quatre jours d'action non violente
de même qu'il y a eu des actions non
violentes quand la Société Générale
voulait faire un gros un gros une
forage de de charbon en Australie je
crois et les copains d'alternatiba se
déguisent en kangourou et rentrer dans
des agences de la souhaiter générale de
façon non violente pour dialoguer avec
les cadres de l'agence de Bayonne pour
les salariés
aurait permis de bloquer le Notre Dame
des Landes
a fini par abandonner quand déguiser en
kangourou John palais ils arrivent
pardon
mais si tu es donc je pense que les
actions non violentes sont efficaces que
moi j'ai donné un coup de main avec
d'autres députés comme Marie Toussaint
on a donné des coups de mains quand
extinction rébellion était devant la
Banque de France en disant au niveau il
y a une étude qui était sortie à 18 mois
qui montrait que avec la crise du covid
au niveau mondial il y avait moins
d'investissement tout était un peu
paralysé et de mémoire que tous les
investissements dans les énergies
pétrolières une année ABC de moins 6%
mais les banques françaises avaient fait
le contraire plus 20% pour les
imbatissements pétroliers et donc on est
allés de façon tout à fait non violente
devant la Banque de France pour dire à
la Banque de France vous ne faites pas
votre boulot vous avez un rôle de
régulation
français sont les pires et vous regardez
ailleurs donc je crois que les actions
non violentes et je sais que ça fait
réfléchir des salariés de la et des
cadres dirigeants de la banque de France
le fait d'avoir des jeunes et des moins
jeunes qui étaient de façon non violente
en disant mais [__] qu'est-ce que vous
faites oui ou non votre boulot de
régulateur les banques françaises sont
les pires et continuent à financer des
projets climaticides et pour sensualité
tout le monde nous a lancé depuis une
semaine avant que ça allait être très
violente très violent très violent et je
crois que y compris au sein des forces
de l'ordre il y en a qui se demandent
pourquoi ils ont pas fait débarrasses
filtrant parce que quelqu'un qui arrive
avec 8 balles de pétanque dans son sac à
dos et qui arrive masquée il vient pas
pour protéger la planète il vient pour
casser du flic et donc cela tu as le
droit de les mettre à l'écart tu fais
des barrages filtrant et l'autre jour
moi j'étais à une manif en actif c'était
peut-être de détruire la bassine
parmi les manifestants il y en a qui
disent mais pourquoi on a pourquoi on a
eu une telle violence alors qu'on savait
depuis une semaine tout le monde de
l'armaden dès que vous d'autres que ça
allait être très très violent mais si tu
sais que c'est très très violent et si
tu penses qu'il y a 400 jeunes cons qui
sont là juste pour faire de la violence
qu'un a des milliers qui viennent qui
ont fait la route qui ont pris des
transports pour venir pour au nom du
climat et de la biodiversité qui pense
que ce n'est pas une bonne idée de les
prendre au lots de la pratique et la
faire s'évaporer donc tu en as des
milliers d'hommes et de femmes de toutes
générations qui sont honnêtes qui
viennent pour le bien commun et si tu en
as 300 ou 400 qui viennent pour casser
du flic et pour faire les cons et bien
tu la République te permet de faire le
droit de faire des barrages filtrants
avec et pendant monsieur Boulogne manip
bonjour monsieur j'avais mon sac à dos
est-ce qu'on peut contrôler votre sac à
dos et j'ai trouvé tout à fait normal
qu'un agent de police ou un gendarme
demande ou un CRS me demande mon sac à
dos il a vu mon sac à dos il m'a laissé
passer donc non non mais j'avais mon
bonnet les choses c'est choquant les
gens me reconnaissent à ma coiffure et
puis tout le monde me connaît pas tout
le monde ne regarde pas ses cardio donc
moi j'ai du respect pendant je voudrais
dire aussi un truc j'ai fait mon service
militaire à Matignon et
je pensais partir au Burkina Faso et
puis je me suis dit que ce serait bien
de comprendre comment marcher la sphère
politique pour essayer de décoincer donc
j'ai fait évidemment mon service
militaire et tous les matins je fais du
sport avec les CRS et j'étais
impressionné par ils étaient presque
faire tuer qu'ils aient voté à droite ou
à gauche ils étaient prêts se faire tuer
pour le Premier ministre tout à fait et
donc moi depuis ce temps-là j'ai
vraiment du respect voilà et donc je
répète ce à qui j'en veux c'est pas les
CRS ou les gendarmes qui sont dans les
manifs je l'ai dit l'autre jour à la
Bastille ça c'est très mal passé quand
j'ai voulu une autre fois dans la manif
les CRS m'ont empêché et j'étais
absolument furieux et je me suis mis en
colère mais je lui ai dit je n'ai pas à
vous que j'en veux ce n'est pas vous
c'est au ministre à Darmanin qui vous
donne des consignes scandales donc et
j'ai vu à Matignon comment ils sont
prêts à se faire tuer qu'ils aient voté
pour la gauche ou à droite ils ont
presque faire tuer pour Shera comme pour
rocaro pour une Tartempion il défendent
la République voilà et eux aussi
souffrent d'une réforme des retraites
qui pour eux pour leur conjoint va les
affaiblir voilà donc j'en veux beaucoup
d'armanin aujourd'hui qui joue le
pourrissement comme Manuel Valls avant
quelques mots de la semaine de 4 jours
ah bonne idée c'est une idée très
séduisante
il faut faire appel à des cabinets de
conseils pour la semaine de 4 jours
est-ce qu'il faut faire appel non blague
à part ce qui est vraiment bien c'est
que le débat sur la semaine des quatre
jours revient dans plein de pays
d'Europe il y a quelques années quand on
parle de la semaine d'occasion on
passait pour un fou furieux il y a eu
trois pages en Libé en disant ceux qui
n'ont jamais cru ceux qui n'y croient
plus et puis ceux qui croient encore il
y en avait deux étaient Michel Rocard et
moi et donc voilà le Libé avait et là il
y a plein de pays d'Europe où le débat
revient il y a une expérience très
réussie en Angleterre où il y a
plusieurs dizaines d'entreprises qui
sont passés à 4 jours et on voit comment
l'absentéisme recule comment le stress
diminue et de mémoire je crois que c'est
92% des patrons et des salariés qui sont
passés à quatre jours qui veulent y
rester j'ai vu dans le Dauphiné libéré
il y a quelques jours une enquête qui
dit en France 84% de ceux et celles qui
ne sont pas à 4 jours voudraient y aller
donc je pense que le covid-19 bouger les
lignes et qui a beaucoup de gens qui
veulent un nouvel équilibre qui a
beaucoup de gens qui veulent en même
temps un vrai boulot et un vrai revenu
et un boulot intéressant si possible et
en même temps avoir du temps pour soi du
pour sa vie perso pour les gens qu'on
aime pour faire des activités qui sont
en dehors du cadre économique donc je
crois que beaucoup de gens veulent vivre
pleinement et veulent un nouvel
équilibre et que la semaine de quatre
jours permet cet équilibre et la bonne
nouvelle c'est qu'en France on a le
débat était lancé en 1993 certains
disent que c'est moi en fait non c'était
Antoine Ribaux en septembre le patron de
dadonne de mémoire le 25 septembre 93
c'est Antoine Ribot qui avait dit dans
le monde il faut passer à quatre jours
32 heures sans étape intermédiaire
Antoine Riboud était pas un blagueur
c'était un grand patron d'industrie il
avait demandé à toutes les équipes de
Danone de façon confidentielle depuis
six mois de réfléchir dans tous les
métiers de Danone est-ce que c'était
possible de passer à 4 jours 32 heures
avec le financement que je vais
expliquer et il avait conclu que oui et
sa fille devait y aller papa du courage
fais ta déclaration et donc ça avait été
un énorme choc un des plus grands qui
dit il faut passer à quatre jours 32
heures sans baisse de salaire et le
lendemain moi j'avais publié mon paquet
dans le monde et on avait argumenté si
vous allez sur le site semaine de 4
jours.fr vous allez retrouver des vidéos
qui viennent de Lina c'est assez marrant
vous retrouver Gérard Larcher qui est
maintenant le patron du président du
Sénat et en décembre 93 c'est Gérard
Larcher qui est le premier à défendre
les 32 heures comme parlementaires
j'avais passé une heure et demie avec
lui et Gérard Larcher devant les caméras
explique avec les gains de productivité
avec les robots on va produire deux fois
plus avec moins de travail c'est pour ça
qu'il faut aider les 32 heures et donc
on avait obtenu petit à petit vous fait
la version courte une loi qui a permis
aux entreprises de passer à quatre jours
32 heures sans baisse de salaire avec
une idée très simple si l'entreprise
passe à quatre jours et qu'elle crée au
moins 10% d'emploi elle arrête de payer
les cotisations chômage ils ont tout à
l'heure je parlais des yaourts Mamie
Nova tout le monde chez Mamie Nova et
passe sa 4 jours et je voyais les
ouvriers les commerciaux les directeurs
générales les directeur financiers tout
le monde est passé à 4 jours il y a eu
15% de création mais le prix du yaourt
n'a pas augmenté parce que l'entreprise
arrête de payer les cotisations chômage
et c'est comme ça que tu peux passer
tout au moins dans 15 jours sans baise
de salaire créer des emplois et ne pas
augmenter la masse salariale et ce qui
est frappant j'ai retrouvé ce matin dans
les archives à l'époque c'était en 95
c'est un rapport il y avait un consensus
un rapport du plan c'était à l'époque le
rapport boisonna demandée par baladio
donc c'est pas l'extrême gauche qui
expliquait qu'il fallait réduire de plus
de 20% le temps de travail je sais pas
si on le voit donc le rapport bois soda
qui est recommandé une réduction de plus
de 20% du temps de travail et pour
assurer les bourgeois décide alors
j'allais finir pour être sûr qu'il y
avait aucun problème de compétence
passer des secteurs on peut le faire en
deux ou trois ans dans l'agroalimentaire
c'est facile mais chez les médecins chez
les infirmiers chez les viols il y a des
métiers il faut plus de temps donc pour
être pour faire un consensus je t'avais
dit d'ici 20 ans et tout le monde avait
dit ah oui évidemment d'ici 2015 oui
évidemment tout le monde dit que c'était
possible Jacques Chirac première visite
quand Jacques Chirac était élu le 13
juillet 95 il
pour qu'on puisse passer à quatre jours
32 heures sans baisse de salaire
concernant la sécheresse est-il au
courant du projet ou contre hydrocarbure
évoqué par Marianne en octobre non
non personne n'est parfait je n'ai que
24 heures par jour
pour venir au cabinet de conseil
il faut en utiliser pour qu'on utilise
quel est ton point de vue sur les
cabinets de conseils pourquoi la
République est devenue ci-dépendance des
cabinets de conseils c'est très mal ça
parce que du coup on perd des
compétences on coupe des budgets dans
les ministères et on dit que quand il y
a une crise on m'a demandé un Mac Insee
de nous aider pour organiser les vaccins
de nos ministères
ubérisation je sais pas parce que c'est
gentiment c'est très très bien payés
donc c'est pas des petits boulots
précaires où tu te risques de passer
sous un camion en livrant ta pizza le
soir sur un vélo voilà donc mais par
contre c'est volonté d'assécher à faire
une volonté je ne sais pas là je n'ai
pas la preuve donc je ne le dis pas mais
clairement c'est on met de moins en
moins d'argent je l'ai dit tout à
l'heure les gens qui luttent contre
l'évasion fiscale on a coupé des
milliers de poste alors que c'est pas ce
qu'ils sont très très rentable depuis
Sarkozy on a coupé des milliers de potes
chez ceux et celles qui étaient là pour
lutter contre l'évasion fiscale mais
c'est pareil dans des ministères dans
d'autres ministère on ne donne pas les
moyens aux salariés permanents qui ont
une expertise qui a une mémoire et puis
on demande une mission pendant trois
mois à mackinsey qui est très très très
bien payé avec la même somme on aurait
pu payer des fonctionnaires pendant un
an et puis McKinsey qui a une vision
quand même très court terme il découvre
le sujet ils sont pas débiles mais ils
découvrent le sujet et parfois ils ont
un biais un peu intellectuel voilà pas
forcément service public interprétation
c'est mon interprétation
je reviendrai j'étais pendant 11 ans
d'un cabinet de conseil donc il y a des
fois où c'est utile il y a des fois
c'est utile d'avoir regardé extérieur ça
t'arrive dans ma vie perso comme dans ma
vie d'avoir de temps en temps je me dis
c'est compliqué je vais demander à un
copain ça fait trois mois que je l'ai
pas vu mais lui il est extérieur moi
j'ai l'impression d'être englué au
Parlement il y a des fois d'avoir un
regard extérieur sa tête ou dans ta vie
perso sur un truc dans ta famille tu as
pas mal non mais il y a des fois les
conseils pas non moi il y a des fois où
j'ai aidé des entreprises à débloquer
des soucis des problèmes il y avait
aucun dialogue entre les ouvriers les
contremaître et la direction avec ma
bonne mine de berner voilà j'écoute tout
le monde pendant 6 mois et j'arrive à
remettre du dialogue et quelqu'un même
avec le même quelqu'un de l'entreprise
n'aurait pas pu avoir le dialogue avec
tout le monde donc il y a des fois avoir
quelqu'un de l'extérieur permet de
débloquer des situations ou d'avoir
parce qu'il a fait le tour déjà de plein
d'entreprises tu apportes des idées que
tu n'aurais pas eu parce qu'il est allé
voir ailleurs donc il y a des fois où le
conseil est utile mais c'est malsain
quand on voit en plus les volumes
financiers c'est des centaines de
millions à là depuis que Emmanuel Macron
est au pouvoir depuis 16 ans ce sont des
centaines de millions je n'ai lu qu'en
diagonale les gens de chez ma Kinsey
qu'il avait aidé pour se faire élire il
y a 6 ans donc là je ne sais pas
exactement mais en tout cas
et la prochaine fois s'il y a de nouveau
un virus on nous expliquera que le
ministère ne sait pas comment gérer la
vaccination parce que c'est making c'est
qu'il a fait cette fois-ci donc on va
bien le cercle vicieux on nous fait
croire que les miliciens n'ont pas la
compétence donc on confie à des boîtes
très très chères et ça a un
appauvrissement du service public qui
est très dangereux pour pour notre pays
et sur Internet son avis sur la chasse
j'aurais dû apporter la carte de vœux
des chasseurs c'est la plus drôle qu'on
a reçu au Parlement européen à mon avis
sur la chasse c'est que
[Musique]
je comprends qu'on puisse passer le
sanglier quand il y en a trop dans mon
coin des Pyrénées il y a des paysans qui
tu les vois ils ont le jeu il y a 3
sangliers qui sont passés qui à la fin
de l'hiver chercher des réserves des
petites souris ils ont foutu à l'air un
champ et donc il y a plus d'herbe pour
les vaches il y a plus de il y a plus de
et donc tu as des paysans dans tout le
boulot est foutu en l'air parce qu'il y
a des sangliers et donc je me souviens
quand j'étais seul quand j'étais
étudiant je travaillais pour le parc
national je comptais les isards et je
m'occupais des populations d'ours et
bizarres et je me souviens qu'il y avait
une le préfet avait autorisé une chasse
aux sanglier parce que le sanglier on
voyait la montagne qui était foutue en
l'air toutes les donc tu auras pas de
foin cette année parce que les sangliers
ont tout foutu en l'air donc il y a une
chasse aux sangliers dans ces conditions
là ça me choque pas mais par contre les
gens qui
élèvent des bestioles et qui les
relâchent juste pour le plaisir de les
flinguer ou ceux qui vont chasser en
Afrique le gros gibier je trouve ça
assez sinistre
est-ce que tu as un sujet que tu
souhaites aborder qu'on a pas abordé
ok non ce que j'aimerais vraiment dire
c'est que il y a un moment où beaucoup
de gens aujourd'hui sont dans le
désarroi ils sont un peu désespérés et
je me souviens de mes dernières
discussions avec Stéphane et Stéphane et
elle était un pour les plus jeunes c'est
un grand résistant monsieur qui avait
été dans les camps nazis qui avait fait
un petit livre indignez-vous qui avait
beaucoup de succès et il disait il était
sur son lit la dernière fois que je l'ai
vu il m'a dit Pierre est-ce que tu vas
me dire voir il était sur son lit on a
parlé de sa vie de la beauté de tout ce
qu'il est fait il me disait il faut
absolument lutter contre le
découragement beaucoup de gens pensent
que c'est foutu qu'on y arrivera jamais
il faut dire que à chaque fois dans
l'histoire humaine on peut avoir des
bonnes surprises ils ont connu
l'apartheid et on a connu la Nelson
Mandela a fait 29 ans de prison il y
avait un système qui était inhumain je
suis allé à mesure au musée de
l'apartheid quand j'étais à Johannesburg
pour pour le climat c'était l'horreur la
partie mais on a fait tomber l'apartheid
des hommes et des femmes se sont ne se
sont pas découragés ils ont fait
à Bruxelles là j'ai une photo derrière
moi au Parlement européen c'est la fin
du mur de Berlin et on voit des jeunes
qui poussent moi quand j'étais à
Sciences Po le meilleur spécialiste de
l'Allemagne en avril 89 nous a dit que
le mur de Berlin est encore là pendant
50 ans et que jamais jamais on ne
verrait la fin du mur de Berlin et 5
mois plus tard le mur de Berlin est
tombé et c'est pas les virus non je
pense pas et c'est pas les grands chefs
c'est pas elmouth colle et Gorbatchev
qui ont décidé ce sont des gens comme
toi et moi qui ont dit [__] je n'en
peux plus ce mur de Berlin fois je n'ai
qu'une vie j'ai envie d'être heureux le
point de départ c'est je n'ai qu'une vie
j'ai envie d'être heureuse j'ai envie
d'être libre ce mur fout en l'air ma vie
et donc on va le faire tomber et au
début c'est des gens qui faisaient pas
de politique bah qu'il avait la des
pages très beaux vaclaves son truc
c'était de faire du théâtre de la poésie
de sortir avec ça ça Olga son amoureuse
et de se promener et puis un jour on va
Clavel se dit je n'en peux plus de ce
système et ils sont au début ils sont
trois ils sont 30 ils sont 3000 ils ont
fait tomber le mur de Berlin on voit une
photo très belle on voit des jeunes qui
poussent physiquement et derrière les
grands chefs politiques Gorbatchev et le
mode call ont géré les conséquences mais
c'est des hommes comme vous et moi et
des femmes qui ont décidé de vivre en
disant on a qu'une vie on veut en
profiter donc je crois aujourd'hui qu'il
faut pas se désespérer mais qu'il faut
s'organiser si chacun et chacune reste
chez soi-même en regardant des trucs
intelligents sur les réseaux il y a de
quoi se désespérer la gravité de la
crise la multiplicité le pouvoir la
façon dont Macron exerce le pouvoir en
montant tout le monde il y a de quoi se
désespérer mais donc c'est pour ça qu'il
faut qu'on s'organise et qu'on est des
victoires d'étapes donc on ne va on rêve
tous si vous vous regardez cette
émission ce soir c'est qu'on a tous en
gros l'imaginaire on veut une société
plus juste plus équilibrée voilà mais il
faut ok pour l'image photo globale ok
pour te dire que c'est bien si dans 4
ans on prend le pouvoir pour mettre en
place une politique globale mais c'est
bien si on a des victoires d'étapes et
une victoire d'étape c'est la taxe sur
la spéculation on peut j'en suis
persuadé avoir une taxe sur la
spéculation dans les deux mois qui
viennent une autre victoire soit tenir
une loi qui permet de passer à quatre
jours un amendement qui permet de passer
à 4 jours 32 heures sans baisse de
salaire puisque Macron et qui ne pourra
pas employer le 49-3 donc on peut avoir
des députés de même qu'on avait fait
voter la loi contre la vie d'Alain Juppé
en 96 je pense que d'ici la fin d'année
on peut faire voter un amendement qui
permet de passer à 4 jours 32 heures
sans baisse de salaire donc si vous
voulez nous aider vous allez sur le site
taxon à la spéculation.com pour la taxe
sur la spéculation et sur le site
semaine de 4 jours.fr semaine de 4
jours.fr si vous voulez qu'on puisse
profiter des quatre jours sans baisse de
salaire attention politique pardon
attention à la propagande politique
c'est pas la propagande politique c'est
uniquement en dehors des élections
beaucoup de gens croient que la
politique c'est juste aller voter pour
le moins pire on peut faire bouger les
choses en dehors je ne demande pas de
voter pour moi dans un an je te propose
qu'on fasse bouger les choses dans les
six mois qui viennent tu as vu le film
network non va voir il y a une phrase à
un moment le mec qui dit fleuriste i
want you to get made
tu vas voir est-ce que tu as trois
bouquins à nous conseiller ah il a
quasiment à chaque fois
le dernier bouquin de Salomé saké sur la
précarité chez les jeunes il est super
intéressant super bien écrit et en même
temps des études statistiques globales
qui te montrent l'ampleur du problème et
des témoignages perso qui t'ont qui et
tout est 5 pages elle te fait comprendre
que c'est pas parce que tu as un vieux
depuis 50 ans non pas du tout elle est
journaliste sur un autre média mais
j'étais frappé par l'intelligence de son
bouquin je lui ai pas encore dit mais et
surtout certains montrent du doigt les
responsables est un impression que
c'était un mec blanc de plus de 50 ans
tu es forcément du mauvais côté de la
force et à chaque fois tous les cinq
pailles elles te dis que c'est pas parce
que tu es un mec de plus de 50 ans et en
bonne situation de financière ça veut
pas dire que tu responsable honnêtement
c'est un peu pénible tous ceux qui
passent leur temps à voilà et si on
passe son temps désigner des coupables
c'est pas comme ça qu'on crée une
dynamique je crois que sur les questions
de climat ou il faut comprendre les
rancœurs aussi bon oui tu as fait non
mais je l'ai dit trois fois je comprends
les gens qui sont en colère y compris
des gens qui votent pour le Front
national je vais dans des quartiers où
il y a des gens qui votent Front
national je dis je comprends que vous
soyez en colère on vous a menti on a
rien fait pour améliorer votre situation
ni perdu sur les questions politiques de
logement les politiques donc je
comprends que vous soyez en colère mais
juste le Front national ou l'URL n'a pas
les solutions et donc voilà donc un
livre intelligence le message
quoi d'autre comme livre le perdre la
terre le bouquin du journaliste
américain dont j'ai oublié le nom et qui
monte depuis 40 ans c'est un journaliste
tout à fait sérieux c'est pas du
complotisme qui monte depuis 40 ans
comment on avait le diagnostic sur le
réchauffement climatique en 79 et
comment les lobbies ont volontairement
tué toute action politique au ralentit
l'action politique est-ce que Nathaniel
perdre la terre il y a un peu trop
centré sur l'Amérique il oublie un peu
les débats en France mais hélas ce que
les montrer c'est qu'en Europe aussi les
lobbies ont tout fait pour ralentir
l'action et ne rien faire contre les
choses tranquille et qu'il est politique
ce sont bien fait bernés et puis je vous
conseille le livre que vous elle sort
cette semaine ou Jean Josel raconte sa
vie mon ami clématologue il a une très
belle vie il raconte comment il était
fils de paysan qui avait pas
l'électricité à la maison le plaisir de
jouer au foot avec les copains le
plaisir de faire les récoltes de blé
quand l'orage menace le plaisir de faire
la fête après la récolte et comment il
s'est mis il s'est intéressé à la
question du climat et donc le livre de
Jean-Joseph est une belle histoire d'un
scientifique qui découvre les problèmes
et qui avec d'autres il y a une
dimension collective qui est très sympa
qui essaye de faire bouger les choses
bon là ça fait trois heures 19 et 11
secondes qu'on est ensemble
est-ce que tu veux prendre le record de
temps de la chaîne non pas forcément on
va avoir une bière ok un conseil pour
les jeunes générations
battez-vous on peut prendre son pied on
peut être heureux en honnêtement il y a
de quoi s'inquiéter a priori il faut a
priori c'est mal parti a priori les gens
qui nous dirigent depuis 40 ans
accumuler les conneries dont vous avez
de bonnes raisons d'être en colère vous
avez bonne raison d'être inquiet moi il
y a 3 ans je rentre à la maison un de
mes filles sont à me demande papa est-ce
qu'on va vers un effondrement et je lui
ai pas dit mais non David t'inquiète pas
tout va bien gentil vous avez de bonnes
raisons d'être inquiet vous avez de
bonnes raisons d'être en colère mais
surtout ne laissez pas d'autres décider
à votre place vous pouvez nous aider
pour faire bouger les choses c'est
souvent les jeunes qui vont bouger la
société donc organisons-nous
organisons-nous trouvons des Deviers
pour faire bouger les choses et je crois
que le climat est un sujet qui peut
rassembler beaucoup et je crois que les
solutions qu'on propose avec d'autres la
taxe sur la spéculation la semaine de
quatre jours sont des moyens de faire
bouger les choses et que derrière si on
se rassemble on pourra peut-être avoir
un projet plus global dans quatre ans
mais on va pas attendre quatre ans pour
faire bouger les choses pire la route ou
merci merci
[Musique]